Intro/Outro
Danke Internet. Ehrlich gesagt.
Sitzen uns nicht gegenüber so war es ja eigentlich geplant dass dieser Podcast,
fast analog aufgezeichnet wird insofern als wir uns eigentlich darauf geeinigt hatten Ich besuche dich immer in Frankfurt und dann nehmen wir das in aller Ruhe auf. Gehen noch ein Stückchen spazieren.
Herr.
Aber jetzt halten wir Abstand wie die Bundesregierung es empfohlen hat.
Genau. Es gibt in diesem März eine allgemeine Verfügung die es uns tatsächlich einfach verbietet.
Es sind erstaunliche Zeiten. Aber ich habe jetzt ein paar Podcast gehört wo immer diskutiert wurde.
Damals Spanische Grippe Das war direkt nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg. Da waren eh alle verwundbar unverletzlich hat das voll durchgeschlagen kann man das vergleichen. Wir wissen es nicht genau.
Was wäre wenn das 3 passiert wäre da gab es ja noch keinen Flugverkehr. Was wäre in den 70ern und 80ern als politische Notlagen so ein bisschen durch haben schimmern lassen.
Ehrlich gesagt ich bin ganz froh dass es 2020 ist weil wir haben Internet.
Vorteil Es ist aber vielleicht auch ein gewisser Nachteil über den wir vielleicht noch sprechen wenn man sich anschaut was dann auch im Internet passiert in einer solchen Krise.
Ich denke da nur an die vielen WhatsApp-Nachrichten die verschickt wurden um Panik zu verbreiten wo auch gar nicht so klar war wer steckt eigentlich dahinter.
Wie kann sich überhaupt so etwas so schnell verbreiten. Aber generell können wir sagen dass wir sehr sehr froh sind erst mal dass wir diesen Podcast,
fortsetzen können gemeinsam aber auch sonst ist das Internet ja eine wichtige Informationsquelle und es geht uns auch nicht so dass wir Langeweile haben.
Wir können uns mit vielen vielem beschäftigen.
Das stimmt. Es vertreibt sehr viel Langeweile. Da muss man allerdings auch drauf überreden Wer hat gerade Zugang zum Internet.
Dieser März ist jetzt auch wirklich eine Zeit um seine eigenen Privilegien mal zu hinterfragen und so weiter.
Kommen jetzt die Werte Union mit so verschiedenen Tweets in denen es lautet Zum Glück haben man noch Virologen Professoren und es sind nicht alles Gender Studies geworden.
Da muss man aber sagen Nee die Gender Studies und die haben uns auch gut vorbereitet auf eine Situation in der sehr viele Menschen zu Hause sitzen und fünf Kinder aber nur ein iPad.
Und dann gibt es andere Familien ein Kind aber fünf iPads. Und da werden Ungleichheiten ganz neu verteilt und bewertet.
Das darf man alles nicht aus dem Blick geraten. Auch wenn zu diesen Themen noch keine großen Podcasts gibt sondern wir alle in die Nachhilfe gehen und die auf.
Man sieht ja so ein paar Podcast macht jetzt pro Folge irgendwie 500 000 Downloads in den ersten drei Tagen.
Da geht's einfach. Das ist richtig Rambazamba richtig Podcast,
Man kann das nicht anders sagen.
Und viele entdecken es jetzt auch für sich. Nachdem die Bundeskanzlerin in ihrer Rede mal sagte haben wahrscheinlich jetzt ältere Leute zum Teil zum ersten Mal überhaupt diesen Begriff gehört und sagen Ach was ist denn das macht mein Enkel das auch.
Kann mir das auch mal schicken genau so wie Merkel das benutzt hat.
Also innerfamiliäre und Intelligent rational innerfamiliäre rational.
Sie hat das nie Schichte den nie schicksten Aspekt des Podcasts überhaupt herausgehoben.
Und da wir schon immer stolz sind auf als Podcast auf Podcast als Medium der Nische fand ich das eine ganz herausragende auch in dieser Kürze einfach so ein Halbsatz und sehr viele Kinder nehmen für ihre Großalarm Podcast auf das ist wirklich herzerwärmend erwärmt gewesen.
Aber auch nicht viel mehr kam dann in der Rede. Das war schon der große Moment kann man sagen.
Es wird aber unterschätzt in Deutschland wieviel alte Menschen gibt wieviel Menschen dann doch so ein bisschen ereigne Leben nachgehen und Freiheit genießen und entkoppelt sind von vielem anderen.
Und in der Hinsicht waren ihre 15 Minuten redundant Es ist ernst es ist ernst aber bitte motiviert euch intrinsisch.
Ich möchte die Ansage vermeiden in Deutschland hat es schon einen guten funktionalen Charakter gehabt auch wenn,
wir alle Drosten und Kekulé und so weiter hören natürlich auch nicht die notwendige Botschaft war aber für viele eben doch darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Aber wer weiß solche Nachbereitung wie vor sich ging die werden ja alle erst im Nachgang gemacht.
Aber was ist jetzt an Corona Was können wir eigentlich darüber sagen was andere vielleicht noch nicht so gesagt haben.
Es ist ja nun sehr breitgefächertes tiefgehend Gespräch über Corona was so stattfindet on und offline.
Und ich glaube soziologisch kann man nochmal auch wenn es ein bisschen komisch klingt sagen das selten eigentlich nie.
Mir fällt jedenfalls kein anderes ein kein anderes Thema als CORONA hat uns so sehr ergriffen und berührt und das meine ich jetzt im Sinne von,
Es gibt einen direkten Zugang von gesellschaftlichen Vorgängen auf den Körper selbst und das sind wir ansonsten.
Symbolische Ereignisse ganz stark die auch sehr prägend waren. Beispielsweise der 11. September.
Aber das hat uns selbst in unserer Lebensführung dann doch nicht allzu arg eingeschränkt.
Es war dann mal so dass die Kontrollen am Flughafen ein bisschen schärfer wurden ein paar solcher Dinge.
Aber grundsätzlich hat sich im Alltag nichts verändert und jetzt ist das wirklich ein globales Ereignis aber auch wirklich ein Mensch Ereignis weil jeder Mensch in irgendeiner Weise,
von Corona betroffen ist und muss sein Leben ändern oder muss sich einschränken.
Und das ist glaube ich etwas was wir bislang wirklich noch nicht hatten.
Ich erinnere immer an meine Eltern oder auch überhaupt diese Generation.
Wenn man die fragte nach irgendeiner Einschränkung beispielsweise dann hörte man den autofreien Sonntag in den 70er Jahren wegen der ölkrise.
Und das ist ja ein so minimaler Vorgang verglichen mit dem was wir jetzt in den letzten zwei drei Wochen schon alles erlebt haben.
Dass man aber daran sehr gut sehen kann wie,
selbstverständlich Eigentlich war das alles verfügbar ist das alles das und das nur eben das einmal sonntags nicht mit dem Autofahren schon als ein solches Ereignis als ein solcher Einschnitt angesehen wird dass man sich auch noch Jahrzehnte später daran erinnert.
Und da ist Corona jetzt doch das erste richtige Ereignis kann man sagen dass unsere Generation aber auch die ältere Generation also die Generation nach 45 erlebt..
Es findet nicht nur auf dem Bildschirm statt der 11. September ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Damals gab es ja auch den Künstler kennst du vielleicht namentlich.
Ich habe mir gerade entfallen der von Stockhausen der vom größten Kunstwerk der Menschheitsgeschichte sprach weil es eben für alle sichtbar war.
Aber so wie Kunst Man könnte auch sagen interessiert mich nicht.
Man konnte Fernseher einschalten hat man es gesehen. Man hat nicht gesehen das ist diesmal anders. Wir sind tatsächlich selbst betroffen.
Und selbst wenn wir es nicht wollen so wissen wir doch dieses unsichtbare Virus macht vor uns nicht halt.
Und da gibts in der Soziologie gerade bei Luhmann der ja nun die abstrakte Gesellschaftstheorie wo immer alle da spielen ja nicht mal Menschen Rolle und so.
Das ist ja sozusagen die Legende die immer erzählt wird.
Luhmanns Gesellschaftstheorie Da besteht ja Gesellschaft nur aus Kommunikation und gar nicht aus Menschen aber es gibt eben diese ganze kleine Feinheiten nämlich den symbiotischen Mechanismus,
alle funktional differenzierten Funktions Systeme sind irgendwie an den Körper gekoppelt weil sie entweder über Knappheit unsere Bedürfnisbefriedigung direkt betreffen weil sie über Wahrnehmung uns Sachen vermitteln.
Lernen spielt dann eine Rolle alle möglichen Bedürfnisse die Familie so befriedigt die Gewalt des Staates alles kommt jetzt auf einmal also wir sind aus alle Funktions Systeme nehmen derzeit wirklich Zugriff auf unseren Körper.
Die Familien rücken viel enger zusammen also die Kernfamilie die zusammen dürfen die dürfen auch zusammen raus sobald jemand anders dazu kommt kommt die Polizei und setzt dann auch gewaltsam wenn auch erst mal nur mit Geld abzocken.
Aber noch wird man nicht inhaftiert.
Das steht ja auch im Raum Diskussion und das ist wirklich eine ganz besondere Situation sowas hatten wir die letzten Jahre und Jahrzehnte nicht.
Und die Generationen danach die erste Nachkriegs Geburten Kohorte die dann so langsam in diese Babyboomer Wirtschaftswunder Generation Eintreten für die ist das das allererste Mal.
Es gibt jetzt noch Menschen die können sich dran erinnern wie es im Krieg war und dann gibt es junge Menschen die noch so von 2008 geschädigt sind dass sie eh nie zu irgendwas kam.
Die haben keine Eigenheime und haben auch keine Autos und so weiter also alle unter 30 sind völlig abgemeldet oder unter 35.
Und dazwischen gibt's diese goldene Generation absolut glücklicher Menschen die sich in sechsstelligen Beträgen ihr Eigentum aufbauen konnten entweder direkt als nutzbares Wohneigentum oder es liegt auf Continuum oder so.
Und die machen es erst einmal so eine richtige Krise mit.
Auch den Eindruck dass die erst zum ersten Mal am resistent waren gegen diese Maßnahmen die sagten Das kann ja wohl nicht sein.
Die den kleinsten Einschnitt das ging ja sehr langsam peu à peu los. Man könnte auch sagen zu langsam.
Schon als eine große Bevormundung als einen Einschnitt in ihre persönliche Freiheit in ihr Lebensglück empfunden haben,
und die sicherlich sich in erster Linie auch über Konsum und Freizeitaktivitäten seien sie noch so sinnlos definieren die dann,
ganz ganz große Probleme plötzlich bekam während die jüngere Generation die man ja immer als stark Konsumismus inszeniert und die schauen nur auf ihr Smartphone und die kaufen eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur Markenklamotten,
viel bewusster meines Erachtens damit umgegangen ist das trifft selbstverständlich nie auf alle zu aber es war doch eine gewisse Tendenz zu erleben dass die Jüngeren den älteren sagten da passt man lieber auf jetzt bleibt mal drin und Ihr müsst heute Abend nicht noch in die Kneipe gehen.
Es gab hier aus Rheinland-Pfalz noch Bilder von CDU Kommunalwahlen die man dann abends noch fröhlich in der Kneipe feierte und Kommentare bei Facebook. Wir lassen uns nicht unterkriegen.
Unter 40 jährige Menschen in Deutschland haben nicht gerade noch ein Chilehaus Ausflug nach Japan geplant der Zweck wegfällt oder wollten ich jetzt nach Wolfsburg fahren um sich den neuen VW abzuholen oder so sondern die sitzen eh zuhause und gucken Netflix.
Und wenn dann die Bandbreite also die Einschränkungen die Bandbreite ist ein bisschen niedriger das heißt ein paar mehr Pixel oder so..
Ich erlebe das auch an mir selber.
Ich bin ja eh immer nur im Homeoffice schreibe meine Bücher Kram bereite Podcast vor und so weiter und die Einschränkung Für mich ist nicht sehr groß.
Ich habe zwar auch heute zwei Töchter zu Hause die ihre Schulaufgaben zu Hause machen die soweit alleine klarkommen dass ich hoffe dass sie sich nachher ihr Mittagessen selber machen können.
Aber im Vergleich zu anderen Einschränkungen die ich so mitbekommen habe ist es wirklich erstaunlich.
Es gibt ja von draußen nicht nur Virologe sondern für uns auch sehr viel Ersatz Politiker und Ersatz Seelsorger und Ersatz Soziologe ist die sehr interessante These.
Der größte Einschnitt für sehr viele Menschen in unserem Alter sind große Veranstaltungen ausfallen und dann hat er die sehr spektakuläre These nachgeschoben umso größer die Veranstaltung,
umso systemrelevanter eigentlich sind Konzerte Es sind Ausstellungen Es ist irgendwas.
Es ist jedenfalls nicht die Vorstandssitzung des Kabinetts treffen weil das kann man auch nicht machen.
Aber alles ab fünf hundert oder tausend Leute dient allein der Unterhaltung.
Es war für uns eigentlich die einzige Lebenszweck.
Also doch wieder große Einschränkung. Aber wir kriegen jetzt nochmal vorgesetzt. So systemrelevant ist das aber nicht was ihr gerade macht.
Naja gut. Was mich ein bisschen wundert ist dass unser Smartphone gar nicht große Rolle spielt.
Die Diskussion ist ja sehr zögerlich welche Apps man jetzt mal da möchte und einsatzbereit haben will.
Man guckt ein bisschen nach Südkorea und hat Angst vor überwachung und so weiter.
Da bin ich mal gespannt wie die Diskussion weitergeht denn wir hören nachher noch vom Smart Distanzierungen im Vergleich zum Social dispensieren klingt zwar erstmal ein bisschen komisch.
Bisher war immer alles was smart ist irgendwie doch ein bisschen blöde.
Aber da stecken doch ein oder andere Potenziale. Es ist das Gummi Kautschuk das uns die papierene Barriere vor den Mund hält die fehlt ja Papier und Kautschuk fehlt. Die allergrößten Erfindungen auf der Welt überhaupt.
Und Wir kriegen unser Smartphone nicht ordentlich genutzt sondern wir nutzen es rein zum Konsum.
Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Naja diese Normalisierung der Corona Pandemie da gibts jedenfalls schon ganz gute Texte.
Zumindest bei meinem Lieblings Publizierens komme ich weiß nicht ob du das kennst.
Das ist mal ganz gute Texte dabei genügend iPads Computer viele Quadratmeter zuhause ein Garten Leute sind zufrieden.
Man kommt im Grunde klar da wie gesagt muss man seine Privilegien mal hinterfragen. Gleichzeitig.
Bleiben können muss man hinzufügen Es gibt ja auch etliche die raus müssen die jetzt nicht problemlos Homeoffice machen können.
Ja genau da gibt es jetzt ganz neue. So wie die Liste angelegt werden wurde.
Wer darf jetzt eigentlich eine Kinder betreuen lassen. Und dann sind plötzlich die Kassiererinnen die wichtigsten Menschen auf der Welt gibt's jetzt sehr viele neue Ungleichheit Unterscheidung die muss man sich genau anschauen muss.
Im Tagesspiegel hab ich gelesen Jugendämter schlagen Alarm wegen Coruna lock down kinder leid und niemand sieht mehr hin.
Das ist natürlich auch gerade für Großstädte und auf jetzt.de hat Eva Stein es war vielleicht einer der besseren Texte auch mal das Coronavirus zeigt mir wie privilegiert ich eigentlich bin.
Keine Krankheiten keine Kinder kein Künstler ein Dasein.
Zack sitzt man zuhause und hat so eine Art Urlaub und nutzt das Internet zum zum Spaß.
Dann gibt's ein sehr interessantes Buch. Darauf wurde ich hingewiesen ich habe es nicht gelesen deswegen spreche ich hier kurz anstatt im Salon.
Aber das sollte man sich vielleicht wirklich mal vornehmen. Sparprogramme töten die ökonomie der Gesundheit.
Die ökonomisierung der Gesundheit von David Stickler und Sanja.
Nach jahrelanger Recherche auf fünf Kontinenten haben zwei junge Epidemiologen ihre haarsträubende Ergebnisse zu einem provokanten und dringlichen Pamphlet zusammengefasst.
Das Denkmal sehe ich weil mir das Buch als Sparprogramme töten es sind bestimmt irgendwelche komischen Leute die aus der linken Blase und so weiter ausbrachen aber nein es sind tatsächlich zwei Professoren die sich mit Epidemien befassen und sich die Austeritätspolitik angeschaut haben,
unter anderem auch innerhalb Europas.
Was haben eigentlich Spanien und Italien angetan und in Spanien.
Warum das in Italien so ist.
Es ist Blaupause also wenn man ein Buch wenn man sich ein Buch gewünscht hätte das mit einer politischen These kommt dass es nicht in einen Praxis Experiment umgesetzt wird dann ist das so ein Buch.
Aber genau das erleben wir jetzt und zum Thema Austerität tötet hat ja Marc Shiraz Europäische Union.
Europa lässt Italien hängen geschrieben.
Man konnte sich tatsächlich nicht auf Corona Bonds verständigen und das ist vielleicht der Sündenfall.
Man weiß gar nicht wie man das.
Zur Frage Wo ist eigentlich Europa wo ist eigentlich die EU.
Wir haben das Video von von der Leyen gesehen indem sie sich fröhlich die Hände wäscht.
Aber sonst hatte man nicht den Eindruck dass wir hier als Europa gemeinsam dastehen sondern es wurde sofort taktiert.
Naja was ist das jetzt für eine Politik wenn wir denen jetzt Beatmungsgeräte hinschicken da müssen wir noch warten wir wissen noch nicht wie das bei uns sein wird.
Es gab nicht ein Miteinander sondern man hat sich so kritisch beäugt hat geschaut ob man irgendetwas sich abgucken kann oder irgendwas besser nicht macht ist man eher vorbereitet.
Wenn die das da unten schon mal gehabt haben Das ist sehr erstaunlich.
Das straft doch alle Sonntagsreden Lügen die dann immer von dieser großen gemeinsamen Identität Europas sprechen und diesem großen Projekt das auf Zukunft ausgerichtet ist so schien es ja anfangs Anfang des Jahres auch.
Auf den Green Deal hingewiesen den von der Leyen angestoßen hat dass man wirklich dachte es gibt so ein gesamteuropäisches Projekt dass man sagt wir wollen eine Lebenswelt schaffen in der wir Europäer auch,
gut durchatmen können zum Beispiel ganz basale Dinge.
Und jetzt erleben wir eigentlich etwas das man schaut.
Naja wem hilft man eher wer steht uns am nächsten das ist dann immer erst der eigene Nationalstaat.
Und dann schaut man wer eigentlich die guten Verbündeten sind merkt aber schon an O nicht dass das Italien genauso teuer zu stehen kommt in Anführungszeichen teuer ist.
In Wahrheit ist es ja eine Lüge so zu sprechen wie Griechenland der einst in Griechenland hat man ja auch die Krankenhäuser ganz runtergefahren.
Ich kenne einen Bekannten der dessen Großvater in Griechenland zur Dialyse muss und dann irgendwann selbstverständlich Aids bekam weil man,
überhaupt nicht die Möglichkeiten das Equipment mehr hatte alles zu desinfizieren eine ständig neue Nadel auszutauschen wo man dann sagt Na das funktioniert jetzt mit dem Gerät dann bekommen wenigstens die Leute noch ihr Dialyse.
Das andere ist Kollateralschaden das muss man sich vorstellen das passiert in Europa.
Ich meine selbst Deutschland hat von der Bertelsmann-Stiftung diese Studie vorgesetzt kriegt ihr habt so viele Krankenhäuser und so weiter und so fort.
Deutschland konnte sich halt dagegen wehren aber für Spanien oder Italien werden solche Studien Pflichtprogramm gewesen da hätte Deutschland sofort gesagt haben Mein Programm endlich. Dann setzt man das mal um.
Da muss man einfach sagen.
Auf Friedrich Merz hat ja ein Buch geschrieben Sammelband herausgegeben über die ökonomisierung des Gesundheitssystems und hat da ähnliche Vorstellungen wenn man mal so,
quer liest oder man schaut wer da noch alles Beiträge publiziert dann geht das in die Richtung wie man Reibach mit der Gesundheit machen kann und dass das nicht zum Wohl des Patienten oder des Pflegepersonals ist. Ist ja klar.
Vor allem kommt diesmal dazu. Während wir 2008 noch öl erleiden konnten das Schulden mit Schuld zu tun haben stimmt das diesmal bei Corona absolut gar nicht.
Italien konnte überhaupt nicht sehen was da passiert weil es diese Tests nicht gab und so weiter und es ist völlig unverschuldet in diese Situation jetzt gekommen.
Und trotzdem wird in Deutschland weiter dieses Programm gefahren. Schulden ist gleich schuld.
Wir können Italien jetzt nicht helfen weil die gehen da nicht gut mit dem Geld. Und das ist wirklich ungeheuerlich Das wird Europa.
Es gibt jetzt verschiedene oder sagen wir mal so Ursula von der Leyen hat ja noch versucht ein bisschen zu retten.
Sie schrieb zum Beispiel auf Twitter unser Europa hat alles in der Hand was nötig ist und wir sind bereit alles zu tun was es braucht diese Krise zu meistern.
Die Geschichte schaut auf uns Lasst uns gemeinsam das Richtige tun mit einem großen Herzen statt mit 27 Kleinen.
Das verhãlt allerdings absolut und in dieser Diskussion die ja jetzt schon läuft muss man auch sagen sehr viele Think Tank Mitarbeiter sitzen jetzt zu Hause gerade richtig zu arbeiten.
Sie sitzen nicht in Flugzeugen sondern sie sitzen alle am Schreibtisch und brüten irgendwelche Ideen aus und Carnegie Europe hat dann schon mal darauf hingewiesen in seinem Tweet.
Man kann das auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg vergleichen die ganze Idee Europa zu gründen hatte mit einer Schadens Bewältigung aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg zu tun.
Wir haben darüber gesprochen wie man dann mit Kohle und Stahl anfing.
Wir haben noch gerätselt könnte nicht Holz und Wind jetzt eine neue Gründungsidee für Europa sein und die stellen das schon auf eine Stufe eher sagen diese Coruna Krise ist im Grunde eine Herausforderung wie der Zweite Weltkrieg,
ist kein sachlicher Vergleich sondern einfach nur ein funktionaler dem ich auch erst mal sehr viel Sympathie entgegen bringe und die Stelle eben ganz konkret die Frage,
wird werden die europäischen Politiker den Test bestehen der gerade vor ihnen steht.
Es ist eine Herausforderung und man kann jetzt zuschauen wie sie das meistern und in Deutschland schaut man sich die Zahlen so an und man denkt da man schafft das irgendwie mit Plattenverkäufe und so weiter.
Man vergisst darüber hinaus den Rest Europas obwohl so großes Umdenken in Sachen schwarzen Innovation stattfand.
Und trotzdem vergisst man da Europa und das ist keine schöne Ausgangsposition für die da kommt man nicht drum rum er hat Diskussionen die dann die nächsten Jahre geführt wird,
wär ja schön gewesen wenn man jetzt nicht nur Infektionsschutzgesetz neu macht sondern tatsächlich auch hier mal so ein bisschen an die Säule geht und einfach mal neu baut.
Aber es ist wie es ist fragen uns Warum wurde jetzt so viel gekauft.
Das Statistische Bundesamt hat ja schon die erste Vorjahresvergleich Studie gemacht zum Thema Einzelhandel Seife plus 373 337 Prozent also eine Verdreifachung der Seife das heißt,
Der Supermarkt ist elf Uhr morgens leer ist nicht bis 19 Uhr noch bestückt sondern da muss man früher Toilettenpapier plus 211 Prozent.
Da muss man allerdings sagen wie bei der Seife wenn Leas ist leer dann kann nicht mehr verkauft werden. Also die Nachfrage da muss man glaube ich nochmal einen Faktor drauflegen.
Man ist locker bei 5 6 7 facher Nachfrage.
Desinfektionsmittel im Halbjahr als Vergleich 751 Prozent im Plus.
Also wirklich ganz erstaunlich. Und weiß Deutschland hat man bei Lilly nachgefragt die ist 65. Warum kaufst du so viel Toilettenpapier. Und sie sagt weil ich kriege wie alle in Panik verfallen verfalle ich in Panik Klammer auf lacht Klammer zu.
Ich würde sagen dass ich es aus Vorsicht kaufe. Mein ganzer Freundeskreis ist verrückt wegen Toilettenpapier alle.
Dann fragt Weisner hast du schon davon gehört dass Toilettenpapier bei Ebay weiterverkauft wird.
Daraufhin sagt sie Ja das ist furchtbar. Menschen nutzen andere aus. Es gibt kein Mitgefühl.
Ich würde das sogar als kriminell bezeichnen.
Sie geht selber los und hortet auch wenn sie es nicht auf Ebay verkauft sorgt sie für diese Preise dort findet sie dann kriminell.
Das zeigt aber den Effekt Es reicht ja wenn bei einer Wirtschaft wie der unseren dann doch ein paar durchdrehen und sagen Ich muss jetzt 10 15 Packungen horten.
Dass das dann selbstverständlich dann knapp wird ist klar und das führt aber dann dazu dass ein jeder im Kleinen dann Ach ich nehme lieber mal jetzt ist es da die doppelte Menge mit.
Man weiß ja nicht ob morgen die verrückten wiederkommen und wieder wie wahnsinnig hamstern.
Inzwischen haben die Supermärkte das ja auch eingeschränkt bei Amazon ist es ja so dass die auch jetzt dafür gesorgt haben dass nicht diese Mondpreise genommen werden dürfen für Desinfektionsmittel.
Die haben ja da sie ja selbst den Marktplatz zur Verfügung stellen da auch alle Möglichkeiten das zu machen.
Aber das ist eine interessante Sache das Desinfektionsmittel grundsätzlich jetzt mehr gebraucht wird ist denke ich klar die meisten Menschen verwenden Desinfektionsmittel so gut wie nie.
Und jetzt tun sie das weil es auch quasi empfohlen ist das zu machen ein bisschen zu achten darauf dass man vielleicht mal ein Türgriff reinigt oder so oft angefasst wurde.
Das ist vollkommen klar.
Während Toilettenpapier exakt so viel gebraucht wird wie zuvor.
Da kann ja niemand sagen da durch die Krise müssen die Leute jetzt 7 mal zur Toilette am Tag dann würde man das auch sagen Genauso auch Mel oder so. Es sei denn die Leute werden jetzt alle zu großen Bäckern aber wer möchte das schon. Also ich möchte nicht mein Brot selbst backen.
Vor allem es bei mir gestern oder vorgestern einen lustigen Tweet.
Da hat ein Supermarkt die Großmarkt Packung die die Restaurants jetzt nicht mehr abnehmen einfach auf eine Palette direkt so verpackt in den Supermarkt gestellt und es sind 25 Kilo Packung.
Und dann haben Sie so ein Schnäppchen Text daneben geschrieben Ihr wolltet mehr Mehl kauft sie gerne 25 Kilo Packungen weil die kriegt man gerade eh nicht weg. Also die ganzen Restaurants die da sonst abnehmen sind ja geschlossen.
Es mangelt nicht an mehr. Es ist halt nur eine Frage wie man es jetzt verteilt. Man kann auch einfach die 25 Kilo Paksas in den Supermarkt legen.
Irgendwann wird das schon mitnehmen und braucht dann aber ein halbes Jahr und Mehl zu lagern ist gar nicht so einfach.
Was auch steigt ist der Alkoholkonsum. Da gab es jetzt einen kurzen Text im Man kann das noch nicht so genau erheben aber es scheint wohl so zu sein dass die Leute jetzt,
zur Flasche greifen im Supermarktregal was auch daran liegt dass da eine Zunahme ist dass die Leute nicht mehr auswärts trinken gehen was sie sonst wahrscheinlich tun.
Am Wochenende aber ist es dann für viele auch so eine Möglichkeit die Krise besser zu bewältigen und das nehme ich auch so.
In meinem Freundeskreis war das man sagt ab 19 Uhr Gott sei Dank. Wir machen schon mal den Rosé auf.
Warum auch nicht. Man muss sich ja irgendwie unterhalten eine gute Entwicklung die es aber tatsächlich gibt.
Farina hat angefangen sich auf Twitter als Einzelhandelskauffrau über die Leute zu beschweren die einkaufen gehen und arbeitet sozusagen an ihre Kundschaft ab.
Im Sinne von in der intellektuellen Nachbetrachtung auf Twitter.
Aber sie verbinde das immer schon auch gleich mit gewerkschaftlichen Forderungen und Organisations aufrufen.
Und ich finde da sollten sich alle die da irgendwie betroffen sind anschließen.
Also gar nicht lange nach neuen Lösungen suchen sondern einfach mal gucken was waren sowieso die grundsätzlichen Probleme und werden jetzt nur noch strapaziert wie wollen wir sie eigentlich vor einem Jahr schon lösen und wie sollten wir es jetzt mal machen.
Und dazu zählt einfach wenn man jetzt als systemrelevant eingestuft wird dann sollte das irgendwas bedeuten und dann kann man da auch neue Kraft daraus schöpfen um Organisations geradezu erhöhen..
Jemand wie Alexander Jordan für die Pflege hat dass er verstanden hat dass er von Anfang an auch so besetzt dieses Thema und ich glaube das fehlt noch da hast jetzt ein Beispiel genannt sonst fehlt es aber noch da.
Und dann gibt es auch häufig diese Kritik dann an der Kritik auch die die sagt Na ja ihr habt die Krankenhäuser ausbluten lassen oder ihr habt uns ja an der Kasse immer so schlecht bezahlt und nur Minijobs und all das.
Da gibt es dann die Kritik an dieser Kritik die lautet Jetzt ist nicht der Zeitpunkt dafür.
Jetzt müssen wir ja erstmal die Krise bewältigen so als sei man in einem Jahr wenn die Krise dann wirklich bewältigt ist noch daran interessiert wenn dann die Kassierer kommen und sagen Hallo,
wir haben doch damals so fleißig gearbeitet aber jetzt hätten wir dann doch mal gerne mehr Lohn oder mehr Absicherung oder irgendetwas.
Dann sagt man Na ja jetzt ist aber auch nicht der Zeitpunkt jetzt kümmern wir uns gerade um das.
Nein man muss jetzt schon das Momentum ergreifen wenn es quasi eine historische Möglichkeit sich bietet.
Das wird so schnell nicht wieder vorkommen dass überhaupt der Beruf des Cassirers so im Fokus steht dass so viel darüber gesprochen wird dass diese Leute so viel in Mikrofone sprechen können vor Kameras stehen dürfen das ist sonst nicht.
Man hat schon mal so eine menscheln der Quatsch in irgendeiner Talkshow dann sitzt dann mal eine Kassiererin oder eine Pflegekraft die darf mal ein bisschen was erzählen aber sonst sind sie total marginalisiert in der öffentlichkeit.
Und die sollten das auf jeden Fall jetzt ergreifen und sich nicht da vertrösten lassen irgendwann denn dieses irgendwann das wird niemals geschehen.
Es immer so im Nachhinein das ist wie wenn man jetzt sah was damals mit den Rettungsschirmen passiert ist bei der EU.
Nein die muss man da kritisieren 2008 nicht jetzt.
Im Nachhinein ist das zwar schön retrospektiv noch mal zu sehen aber das wird dann nicht mehr geändert.
Ganz genau. Die Diskussion über Organizations gerade in solchen wie wir jetzt wissen systemrelevanten berufen muss genau jetzt geführt werden. Jetzt ist genau der richtige Zeitpunkt dafür.
Und sei es nur dass es darum geht jetzt auch jetzt konkrete Probleme z.B.
Was die Sicherheit der Mitarbeiter angeht. Wir müssen jetzt alle mal ordentlich getestet werden die sollten jetzt alle ihre Schutz Materialen bekommen die brauchen ihre Gefahrenzulage Die brauchen jetzt ein ordentliches überstunden Geld und der ganze Kram.
Und das sollte jetzt eingefordert und auch alle Bedürfnisse befriedigt werden und sei es dass der Staat dann einspringen muss.
Die Organisationen also die Arbeitgeber können ja dann später immer noch mit dem Staat über die Neujustierung der Geldströme reden aber trotzdem muss das jetzt erst mal bezahlt werden und so weiter.
Es ist völlig klar man darf sich da nicht rausreden lassen das jetzt nicht die Zeit weil man gerade ein akutes Problem löse so schlimm ist das auch nicht.
Man könnte auch durchaus sagen wir mal in Deutschland Bescheid Einkaufen nur noch bis Freitag 15 Uhr weil danach ist drei Stunden Mitarbeiterversammlung und das würde nun Deutschland auch nicht kaputtmachen oder so. Das wäre alles im Rahmen des Möglichen.
In der Medizin ein bisschen anders Natürlich aber die Versorgung der Bevölkerung angeht kann man da hingehen und das wäre auch absolut empfehlenswert.
Sonst greifen nämlich andere Mechanismen in Rio de Janeiro wo der Staat ausfällt in Brasilien gerade.
Man hat zum Beispiel gesagt Wir müssen Unternehmen jetzt schützen suspendieren alle Arbeitsverträge für die nächsten vier Monate.
Das ist auch eine Problemlösung haben mittlerweile die Gangs in diesen.
Da wo sie alle zusammen in diesen Ghettos und so weiter die Gangs übernommen die Ausgangssperre durchzusetzen und zwar mit der klaren Ansage und so stehts auch gedruckt auf Papieren die da aushängen,
Government Don't won't Right Thing Crime.
Da ist absolut irre was da gerade passiert. Bettina Schulz hat mal nach England geblickt das fand ich auch krass weil die hat Text geschrieben mit der überschrift Das ist wie Folter.
Da kommen wir gleich zu dass sie in England Herangehensweise hatten.
Man hat eine Weile gewartet bis man einem bewusst war ach das betrifft uns alle auf die gleiche Weise und so viel distanzieren ist erst mal das einzige was wir machen können.
Dann sind wir ein bisschen spät dran aber wir können uns ja behelfen indem wir erst einmal Menschen über,
siebzig für drei Monate in Quarantäne schicken und zwar damit es richtig persönliche Quarantäne Gmeind woraufhin dann schon einige meinen das ist wie Einzelhaft Das ist wie Folter.
Und auch mit dem Hinweis Ich weiß gar nicht ob ich in drei Monaten noch sprechen kann wenn ich jetzt nur noch rumliegen und so weiter Menschen wissen überhaupt nicht wie sie sich verhalten sollen.
Sollen jetzt quasi völlig abgekapselt von der Gesellschaft und auch ihrer Familie werden deren Sicht ist wirklich dramatisch und Nils Markwardt hat auf Twitter noch einmal aus so einem Halbsatz CZ zitiert,
Merkel will vermeiden.
Und dann bin ich herausgehoben und sinngemäß sagt sie das auch in kleiner Runde dass es am Ende mehr Tote durch Suizide in der Einsamkeit und Gewalt hinter verschlossenen Türen gibt als durch Coronavirus.
Die Gesellschaft geht ja weiter. Das wird man so vergessene mehrmals am Bildschirm feststellt und von anderen eben auch sozial distanziert ist kriegt man ja gar nicht mehr.
Aber die Gesellschaft geht ja tatsächlich weiter Crooner liegt ja nur obendrauf und vielleicht sogar als Katalysator für viele Probleme die einfach schon so schlummerten 16 dass jetzt Abwägungen die gemacht werden müssen wir hatten ja zum Beispiel in Hessen hat sich der Finanzminister.
Den Freitod gewählt. Suizid.
Man kennt noch wenig Hintergründe aber es gibt wohl einen Abschiedsbrief in dem wohl auch drin stand er fühlte sich überfordert.
Die Gesamtsituation ist einfach eine Ausweglosigkeit das war das Wort was wohl als Zitat aus diesem Brief fällt keine Ahnung.
Das darf man alles nicht ausblenden dass natürlich psychische Probleme jetzt nochmal ich meine.
Meine Frau arbeitet ja Kinder und Jugendbücher Therapien.
Viele die kommen mit Zwangsstörung z.B. Händewaschen der ganze Familie die sich den ganzen Tag nur Hände wäscht und Angst vor allem hat.
So klingen jetzt zum einen weniger therapeutische Betreuung und hören zum anderen überall da sich die Hände waschen sollen.
Und sowas ist natürlich katastrophal.
Ältere Leute wenn es um die ganz kleinen Dinge des Alltags geht.
Viele Menschen leben allein sind verwitwet beispielsweise und gehen dann am Nachmittag immer zwei drei Teile einkaufen.
Nicht weil sie nicht einmal alles auf einmal kaufen können sondern sie wollen einmal am Tag im Supermarkt sein und mit der Kassiererin vielleicht nur zwei drei Worte wechseln und das reicht und dass man mal wieder begrüßt wird dass man angesprochen wird Ach Frau Müller.
Oder dass man irgendwo in einer Cafeteria eine Freundin trifft.
Das ist ganz existenziell damit überhaupt das Leben im Alter auch noch Sinn erfüllt ist gerade wenn die Familie ohnehin vielleicht weit weg ist wenn man,
noch eine Krankheit mitzuschleppen hat weil man sich vielleicht zehn Jahre um den Mann gekümmert hat der dann gestorben ist und jetzt ist man selbst aber allein und weiß um,
um nicht wird sich niemand auf diese Weise kümmern wie ich mich kümmern konnte.
Wir haben ja auch so etwas wie Alters Suizide.
Sehr sehr stark. Und da ist es schon eine sehr sehr ernsthafte überlegung und man muss da sehr abstrahieren was man dann auch bei Twitter bei manchen Journalisten merkt dass sie das nicht können.
Wir leben ohnehin ein sehr eigenartiges Leben.
Wir können mit ein paar stapeln Zeitungen oder mit dem E-Paper oder was sehr lange uns beschäftigen wir können eben auch Texte schreiben wir können mit Journalisten auf eine ganz andere auch.
Abstrakte Art und Weise mit Dingen umgehen wie das eben nur eben die können die diese privilegierte Position haben.
Und das ist auch nicht vergleichbar mit was was normale Leute haben mit irgendwelchen Künstler Existenzen oder so.
Und das ist auch nicht vergleichbar mit Marlene Dietrich hat 15 Jahre in ihrer Wohnung gelebt hat jetzt 15 Jahre ihres ihres Lebens zum Schluss in der Wohnung verbracht weil sie nicht wollte dass man draußen sieht dass sie altert.
Die letzten zehn Jahre lag sie im Bett freiwillig gewählt.
Das sind halt Ausnahmen die nichts mit einem alltäglichen Leben zu tun haben.
Die sind jetzt interessant sich auch mit diesen Fragen zu beschäftigen der Isolation.
Und selbstverständlich hat die Vorteile und es kann auch wirkliche Muße Zeit entstehen und das kann auch dazu kommen dass man vielleicht etwas Neues denkt sein Leben neu organisiert.
Aber es ist für viele eine große Katastrophe Du hast auch angesprochen die häusliche Gewalt die verschwindet ja überhaupt nicht durch Coruña sondern da würde ich auch sagen Das ist ein Katalysator der jetzt nochmal wo,
es wenig Ausweichmöglichkeiten gibt das Ganze sich nochmal verschärfen könnte.
Robert hatte nachdem ich auf Twitter diesen Buchdeckel zum Thema Einsamkeit von Manfred Spitzer,
getwittert hatte Einsamkeit Einsamkeit das Problem in Deutschland ist nicht dass die Leute zu eng aufeinander hocken und wir jetzt mal Social dispensieren machen müssen sondern das Problem Deutschland ist eigentlich Einsamkeit unter Millennials unter alten Menschen erst recht,
und Manfred Spitzer hat auf seinem Buchdeckel schon drauf geschrieben.
Einsamkeit ist nicht nur tödlich sondern auch ansteckend.
Und ich wollte es eigentlich unbedingt heute auch thematisieren Ich habe es nicht geschafft ins Buch rein zu lesen da ich hier wie übrigens auch Max und so weiter.
Interessant dass sich viele auf Twitter auch äußern mit wenn man Familie. Das ist ganz schön anstrengend.
Es betrifft mich auch ein bisschen. Aber im April da es ja so aussieht als würde dieses flatternde Crafting jetzt doch irgendwie funktionieren Es ist jetzt genau zwei Wochen alt.
Wir sehen jetzt die ersten Erfolge davon also werden wir das wahrscheinlich auch noch drei vier Wochen machen im April kommen wir aber mal auf dieses Einsamkeit und wieso ist Einsamkeit eigentlich ansteckend.
Denn man darf auch nicht übersehen dass sich sehr viele Sachen die sich jetzt einstellen wie zum Beispiel Man wechselt die Straßenseite wenn einem Leute begegnen oder Sohne.
Das sieht man ja schon es wird auch bewusst gemacht es nimmt keiner übel und so weiter aber,
wir haben ja lange mit Philipp Hübel und so weiter kann man immer die Ideen von naja so Rassismus das beruht eigentlich auf diesen ganz basalen emotionalen Grundbaustein Ekel.
Und es wird uns gerade alles so eingeimpft ekelt euch mal bitte vor anderen Menschen und es gibt jetzt schon Berichte Menschen reden in ihrem Podcast darüber dass sie Filme gucken in denen sich Menschen die sich gerade zum ersten Mal sehen auch küssen und so weiter.
Und man fragt sich die ganze zeit Haben Sie keine Angst vor Coruña und er sitzt schon richtig tief drin und ich bin auch mal gespannt wie lange es dauern wird es wieder rauszukriegen dass man sich wieder umarmen kann zur Begrüßung und dass man,
nicht erst wie ein Geheimagent sondiert.
Wie nah sind denn die Tische hier gestellt im Restaurant das man betritt und so weiter sondern ist mal wieder völlig freien Gedankengängen einfach mal wieder normalen Alltag macht.
Das war ja alles Große Nachwirkung das kann man solche Sachen dann im April ein bisschen ausführlicher denn so wie es aussieht haben wir ja noch viel Zeit über sowas nachzudenken.
Als kleine Sache für die die die noch nicht gesehen haben obwohl das wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so viele sind.
Das ist jetzt gerade der Film der Stunde Konnotation von Steven Soderbergh Ich weiß nicht ob du den kennst.
Dort bricht eben ein Virus aus.
Ein Impfstoff ist nicht da die Leute fallen reihenweise um und es geht auch darum das Prinzip wie ein Grippevirus übertragen wird durch Husten Schnupfen und all das.
Steven Soderbergh zeigt dann auch immer nicht einfach so einen Thriller sondern er zeigt dann immer auch solche ganz alltäglichen Dinge die plötzlich fragwürdig werden.
Wo greift man hin wenn man in der U-Bahn steht dass klar ist dass mir der Kellner reicht ist da nicht schon etwas dran.
Und diese kleinen Szenen fängt der eine und diese beobachten wir jetzt auch im Alltag dass man tatsächlich überlegt Na wenn ich aber jetzt diesen Einkaufswagen von dem nehme dann muss ich aufpassen dass das und das und dann macht man ja auch immer sehr lange Ketten und man kommt am Ende,
bei eigentlich ganz Verzweifelten Dingen raus denn es ist,
dann auch irgendwann gar nicht mehr zu machen.
Man kann dann höchstens sagen Ich bleibe hier zu Hause im Bett liegen und stehe überhaupt nicht mehr auf. Aber wie komme ich dann an mein Essen.
Das ist etwas was Steven Soderbergh in diesem Film gut zeigt was wir vielleicht auch mal sagen können.
Auch dieses Alltägliche das Umarmen sich über Dating werden wir auch dann noch einmal sprechen müssen.
Thilo hatte ja schon da eine Virologen gefragt im Interview wie das denn jetzt ist sollte man noch tun.
Und dann empfahl sie auch dass man sich nur noch so eine Person dann,
bei der eigentlich ist man jetzt zur Monogamie verdammt ja bindet euch wieder also eine Person bei der ihr das Vertrauen habt dass die jetzt nicht sonst noch irgendwo rumläuft die ganze Zeit und sich mit anderen infizieren könnte.
Es gab auch von Dating Plattformen schon so rund Mails wurde mir jetzt erzählt in denen abgeraten wurde von Gruppensex.
Ja wir werden alle in gewisse Zwangsstörung.
Aber gewisse Verhaltens Erinnerungen die sehr viel auf Angst und Ekel beruhen Reihen trainiert.
Es gab ja auch bei Drosten zum Beispiel im Podcaster diesen kurzen Moment als er gefragt wurde weil ich gehe.
Auch da hatte der Kellner Tausende Menschen angesteckt die dann alle nach Hause fuhren und ihre Länder jeweils anstecken und er meinte ja wenn ich irgendwo unterwegs bin trinke ich Bier aus der Flasche.
Sie denkt Ach so alles klar. Und dann hört man diesen Kekulé Podcaster und der meint ja wenn ich draußen bin ich fasst also Sachen an.
Ich fasse mir dann konsequent nichts nicht ins Gesicht und wurde so gefragt wie man festlich ins Gesicht meinte.
Ja ich stelle mir vor ich hätte in Hundehaufen gefasst und das kriegen jetzt von Virologen denen wir so sehr vertrauen gesagt im Sinne von Das haben die schon immer so gemacht.
Also ich fasse mir draußen nicht ins Gesicht Das habe ich auch vor fünf Jahren schon gemacht.
Also ich trinke nicht aus Gläsern wenn ich im Restaurant bin. Aber da habe ich auch schon immer so gemacht und so werden wir das schon immer.
Das geht ja demnächst auch für uns irgendwie alle.
Da bin ich mal gespannt inwieweit wir wieder auf.
Bis gestern dachten viele Menschen Erkältung ist wenn man im Zug sitzt im Luftstrom und dann ist man halt krank.
Nein es ist auch eine Infektion Man erholt sich Erkältung also sehr viele Lernerfahrungen die wir jetzt machen die sehr viel psychologisch einfach schleppen und wir werden es auch mit einer psychologisch angeknackste Gesellschaft,
zu tun haben im Nachhinein apolitisch.
Eine neue ära an.. Das kann man sagen.
Wir fangen eine neue ära an.
Es wird im Salon nach Textteil.
Ging gestern eine Wir sprechen ja heute an einem Montag gestern ging eine zu Ende und zwar die Lindenstraße.
Nach knapp 35 Jahren wurde eingestellt Du hast wahrscheinlich 35 Jahre lang verfolgt.
Nein natürlich nicht ich auch nicht hab mir aber die letzte Folge angesehen weil ich ja etwas wissen wollte.
Wie reagiert die Lindenstraße auf Corona. Die Lindenstraße war ja dafür bekannt dass sie immer auf aktuelle Ereignisse wie z.B.
Eine Bundestagswahl reagiert.
War das damals als Stoiber Schröder gegeneinander antraten war dann auch am Ende nochmal so ein Satz zu Else Kling hin.
Na da bleibt ihr Stoiber doch in Bayern oder sowas kam dann immer.
Und jetzt war es aber so dass man die Lindenstraße ja schon vor vielen Wochen abgedreht hatte als die Welt noch in Ordnung schien.
Und so gibt es nur einen einzigen Moment es ist ein Radio zu hören und da sagt eine Sprecherin dass sich die Korona Epidemie immer weiter ausbreitet.
Mehr Korona gibt es aber nicht und stattdessen hat man das Ganze auch einen Krimi Plot verlegt und hat auch es versäumt wirklich ein großes Finale herzustellen so wie man es eigentlich sich gewünscht hätte aber man sieht er auch,
an diesem doch sehr sehr schwachen Finale das da ist einfach vollkommen die Luft raus und das ist eine.
Bundesrepublikanische Wirklichkeit die diese Serie eine lange Zeit versucht hat abzubilden und das auch geschafft hat die heute mit unserer Realität nichts mehr zu tun hat.
Und das war gestern interessant zu sehen Man sah da ein Gegenwart das Museum das aber schon vollkommen veraltet ist.
Ich meine dass man es überhaupt dass man so darüber spricht dass man im Grunde schockiert ist wie normal ist da noch war obwohl doch eigentlich alles schon auf dem Kopf steht.
Mark Rutte zum Beispiel ist der Premierminister in den Niederlanden das erste der erste der seit 1973 überhaupt mal mit dem Volk direkt gesprochen hat.
Ansonsten ist das ja königliche Aufgabe und der Supreme Court in Amerika hat seine Geschäftsordnung das erste Mal in 102 Jahren geändert um einfach dem Mündlichkeit Prinzip da mal ein paar Schranken einzuziehen.
Wir haben die größten Börsen Bewegung aller Zeiten jetzt in diesem März gehabt und eine weltweite Reisewarnung des Auswärtigen Amtes.
Es geht wirklich drunter und drüber es ist nichts mehr normal und ich will bevor wir ein paar Clips zum Thema Hören Macron nochmal vorlesen denn dieses Zitat hat uns alle aus den Socken geholt und zeigt auch die Zensur,
denn schon vor zwei Wochen als es in Frankreich noch nicht zur großen Triage Notwendigkeiten und so weiter kam hat Macron.
Am Freitag wurde es auf Deutsch dokumentiert gesagt morgen müssen wir die Lehren ziehen aus dem was wir gegenwärtig durchmachen.
Das Entwicklungsmodell hinterfragen in das sich unsere Welt seit Jahrzehnten verwickelt hat und dessen Mängel nun ans Licht kommen die Schwächen unserer Demokratien hinterfragen.
Eines hat sich durch diese Pandemie schon jetzt herausgestellt die kostenlose Gesundheit unabhängig vom Einkommen Stellung und Beruf.
Unser Sozialstaat sind keine Kosten oder Lasten sondern wertvolle Güter unverzichtbare Trümpfe.
Wenn das Schicksal zuschlägt diese Pandemie hat jetzt schon deutlich gemacht dass es Güter und Dienstleistungen gibt die außerhalb der Marktgesetze gestellt werden müssen.
Es ist verrückt unsere Ernährung unseren Schutz.
Die Gestaltungs Fähigkeit unseres Lebens Rahmens im Grunde an andere zu delegieren. Wir müssen die Kontrolle darüber zurückgewinnen.
Mehr noch als bisher ein souveränes Frankreich und Europa errichten ein Frankreich und Europa das sein Schicksal fest in die Hand nimmt.
Die kommenden Wochen und Monate werden Entscheidungen erfordern die in diesem Sinne einen Bruch darstellen. Ich werde die Sache in die Hand nehmen.
Das ist eine Sensation.
Und Deutschland macht nicht mit.
Das ist eine Kehrtwende.
180 grad.
Und ich habe bei meiner Kritik an der Bundeskanzlerin ist genau das was man so etwas aus Deutschland momentan aus der Bundesregierung nicht hört,
das ganze erstaunliche und gerade von Macron der eben die verspätete.
Alles was Sarkozy und Hollande noch nicht neo liberalisieren konnten jetzt er liberalisiert hat oder versucht ist dabei. Und dass er plötzlich da ein Einsehen hat weil ich hier Politik daraus resultiert wird man sehen.
Aber zunächst einmal dass man das in einer solchen Klarheit äußert ist sehr erstaunlich.
Und man kann es aber auch nicht herunterbrechen. Wenn man jetzt sagt Wenn man jetzt feststellt sagen wir mal Mei die ersten Studien sind da,
so ein einfacher Mundschutz der einfach nur eine Barriere für fette Tröpfchen darstellt und dieses Coronavirus sind nun mal fette Tröpfchen.
Also es bleibt einfach hängen im Gewebe Filz z.B.
Ein einfacher Mundschutz hätte erlaubt dass alle großen Konsumtempel offen bleiben allerdings mit der Pflicht da nur mit Mundschutz rein zu gehen.
Man hätte sich also fünf Milliarden an Hilfen in Form von Direktzahlungen Kredit und Bürgschaften sparen können,
wenn man einfach nur vorher für 50 Millionen Euro 800 Millionen Gesichtsmasken auf Lager hätte.
Dann kommt man plötzlich in Kalkulation. Da muss man gar nicht groß Moral an schmeißen oder Forderungen stellen sondern da kommt man einfach in Kalkulation wo man sich fragt warum.
Warum werden diese Mundschutz Mask.
Auf der anderen Seite der Welt produziert und nur in 100 Millionen Paketen rüber geschickt.
Weil man an Lieferkosten an Produktion sparen wollte.
Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht heraus wenn man das alles so hört. Aber da kann man ja gleich nochmal drauf auf die knappen materialistischer.
Hema Daten auch Mundschutz. Mundschutz herstellen. Trigema stellt jetzt.
Genau Trigema macht. Viele sehen eine große Chance für Absätze.
Finde ich auch gut denn es leben in Deutschland 80 Millionen Menschen und wir sind nur wir sind eigentlich schon an dem Punkt wo es die allgemeinen Verfügung.
Zum Thema draußen nur noch mit Mundschutz aber dafür halt wieder draußen gibt es gibt halt nur keine Mundschutz. Ansonsten hätten wir es ja schon längst gemacht.
Es mangelt ja wirklich nur an Material ansonsten hätten hätten wir ja schon längst den Mund Schutzpflicht für 80 Millionen Deutsche oder sagen wir mal 75 Millionen.
Das ist natürlich ein riesiger Markt. Den kann man natürlich auch einfach mal bespielen.
Was ich ganz interessant fand ich habe seit Januar sagen wir mal so Wir machen es jetzt zum dritten Mal Es ist März es ist der dritte Monat von diesen 120 Monaten neue Zwanziger,
und im Januar gab es schon einen Clip den ich unbedingt spielen wollte aber der im Januar schon nicht gepasst hat und im Februar erst recht nicht.
Ich will aber jetzt spielen weil er einfach auch witzig ist.
Also nicht mal zwei Wochen nach dem Ereignis hat Stephen Colbert dem Publikum gefragt ob ich damals als Trump diesen iranischen Dings getötet hat und alle dachten das ist jetzt Weltkrieg III,
und man denkt sich Ja was für eine sinnlose kleine,
Nebenschauplatz artige Ereignisse die damals passiert ist oder wir alle dachten es geht jetzt los.
Würde man sagen Ja ja ja.
Also nicht wirklich verrückt. Und dann habe ich mich daran erinnert Yuval Noah Harari in den ich sehr schätze seit ich ein bisschen im Talk Radio gehört habe.
Ich habe kennen seine Bücher noch nicht groß aber das bin ich ziemlich gut. Der hat jetzt auch noch einmal.
Homo Geus müssen wir sehr empfehlen. Muss ich sie empfehlen. Homo Geus sollte man unbedingt gelesen haben.
Humor der ist ja auch die 21 Flexion und das scheint doch alles sehr. Man kommt gar nicht dazu kommen mir das dann auch mal genauer anzugucken.
Der saß jedenfalls hat ja diesen Podcast rein gemacht und so weiter. Mark Zuckerberg hat ja auch die Idee ich jedes Monaten ein Gespräch mit irgendwem der sich auskennt.
Und da wir jetzt alle nur Virologen zuhören und die Stimme der Historiker und Soziologen so ein bisschen fehlt ist diese Gesprächs Eröffnung von Harari mit Zuckerberg sehr interessant.
Da
Wird philosophiert.
Corinna Questions of Technologie vier,
Jobs Chronic events.
As.
Das war natürlich in dem Moment wo das so ausgesprochen wurde vor einem halben Jahr hat so ein humoristischer Halbsatz.
Die Menschen sind ja tot. Warum sollte man sich für Sie noch interessieren.
Er hat ja immer diesen Satz Geschichtswissenschaften. Klar kann man sich für das vergangene interessieren aber ich interessiere mich für Wandel und der findet halt jetzt statt.
Und jetzt haben wir einen Wandel der sehr viele Tote bringen wird. Aber die Menschen leben ja noch.
Und dieser Halbsatz den er damals hatte finde ich jetzt umso interessanter dass er sozusagen auf die Toten abstellt weil man könnte ja jetzt eine Geschichtswissenschaft machen die sich für den Wandel interessiert und auf die noch nicht gestorbenen abstellt.
Also genauso mit Leben und Tod spielt aber dringlicher aus einer gewissen Dringlichkeit heraus.
Das qualifiziert auch Harari doch sehr um sich das jetzt mal die Herausforderung genauer anzugucken und dann und das finde ich auch interessant.
Unser Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn der jetzt nur mit Krisenbewältigung befasst ist hat vor drei Wochen also zwei Wochen vor der Ausgangssperre von der Beschränkung der Schulschließungen und so weiter im Interview der Woche.
Beim Deutschlandfunk zwei Themen gehabt.
Seine Coruna und das andere war dass Sterbehilfe Urteil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht als sie sagten Ja wenn man weiß dass es dem Ende entgegen geht dann darf man selbst darüber bestimmen.
Wie und vor allem wann.
Wann will ich eigentlich sterben wenn ich weiß meine Lunge wird versagen darf ich dann einfach ein halbes Jahr eher gehen.
Aber aus freien Stücken und da gab es ja eine sehr große.
Wie soll man sagen Liberalisierung vielleicht das falsche Wort aber ein sehr großes Zugeständnis an dieses individuelle Recht.
Frei darüber zu entscheiden wie man stirbt und dieses Sterbehilfe betrifft natürlich jetzt die eine oder andere überlegung die man sich jetzt noch nicht ganz traut aber,
wir wissen In Deutschland gibt es unglaublich viele ältere Menschen die sehr große Angst vor einem qualvollen Tod haben und die natürlich auch die Berichte lesen wieso ein Lungen versagen stattfindet.
Und ja gut man kann die Leute gut anschließen und es gibt auch sehr viele Betreuungsplätze in Deutschland aber gibt es eigentlich Heilung dadurch oder wird einfach nur der Sterbeprozess verzögert,
beatmet werden muss ja wohl bis zu 21 Tage in Deutschland und es läuft nach italienischer Erfahrung sehr viel darauf hinaus dass man sagen kann Ich anschließen und ich sterbe zahlen.
In Deutschland sind niedrig weil recht viele dann doch auch einfach beatmet werden aber haben wir auch schon Clips von deutschen Medizinern aus der Intensivmedizin die sagen Ja das sind Zustände Zitat schlimmer als der Tod.
Man kann was das körperliche Leben angeht die Menschen fast unendlich lange am Leben erhalten mit allen möglichen Unterstützungen aber das ist halt nicht mehr da ist der Geist schon längst ausgeschaltet man liegt irgendwelchen Koma und so weiter und leidet im Grunde nur noch.
Da will ich nochmal diesen kleinen Ausschnitt von Jens Spahn zum Thema Sterbehilfe kurz vor der Corona Tragödie spielen.
Wenn Arzt Patient in einem Verhältnis miteinander zu einer Entscheidung kommen okay aber der Anspruch gegenüber einem Ministerium oder einer Behörde des Ministeriums todbringende Medikament zu bekommen.
Das Verwaltungsgericht hat gesagt er muss Kriterien dafür entwickeln dann tue ich mich echt schwer das ministerielle dann entscheiden wer in Deutschland sterben darf und wer nicht.
Wenn man mal so ein bissel zu Ende denkt welche Bahn das eröffnet dann habe ich dann Probleme das will ich auch so formulieren.
Gleichwohl werden wir im Lichte des Urteils des Verfassungsgerichts jetzt und auch eines noch zu erwartenden Urteils in dieser konkreten Situation natürlich damit damit umgehen.
Es ist und bleibt ein Rechtsstaat und derzeit nicht nur wahrscheinlich am Ende nur relativ. Die Meinung des Bundesministers.
Ich habe noch keine Diskussion darüber gehört. Ich kann es nur.
Sparen sind ja bekanntermaßen recht beschränkt aber hier würde ich auch sagen dass da ein sehr heikel und auch richtigen Punkt spricht.
Also ich bin sowieso kein Anhänger der Sterbehilfe in dem Sinne.
Das liegt sicherlich auch an meiner christlichen Sozialisierung.
Grundsätzlich ist das aber was was ich eigentlich auch von Moment zu Moment erwarte dass jetzt eben diese Sterbehilfe Debatte die nur ganz kurz dann noch einmal aufflammt mit dem Urteil jetzt wie du es gesagt hast verknüpft wird mit,
dem was wir jetzt vorfinden.
Und wir müssen glaube ich sehr aufpassen denn wir sprechen noch über Intellektuelle die sich einmischen gerade wer sich nicht bei dieser Rundschau vorkommen.
Aber jetzt glaube ich immer stärker nach vorne preschen werden das sind die utilitaristischen die sagen Na ja.
Wir müssen jetzt auch mal argumentieren mit,
volkswirtschaftlichen Berechnungen die sagen Na ja wir müssen jetzt auch mal schauen wie schlecht geht es dann einer Volkswirtschaft am Ende wenn sie so lange einen Shutdown hat können wir nicht dann sagen für das Wohl aller ist es viel sinnvoller.
Man wirft den Laden jetzt wieder an lässt das Ganze wieder losgehen und hat dann eben auch sehr viele ältere die sterben werden aber was sie sich dann nicht trauen auszusprechen ist und damit sind noch andere Probleme gelöst und man Renten und sowas.
Aber man sieht schon hin und wieder ein paar Halbsätze.
Oder es gab jetzt auch von einem Ethiker das sind ja immer so eigenartige Ethiker die sich dann zu Wort melden im Spiegel die dann eben sagen Na ja dann ist halt das Vorrecht der Jüngeren.
Und das ist halt ein ganz ganz großes Problem weil dann hat man wirklich einen Krieg der Generationen plötzlich den man zum einen aufmacht zum anderen würde dann der Mensch bewertet und das ist eben eine ganz große Sache.
Du hast es angesprochen dass es da sicherlich auch in Krankenhäusern Dinge gibt in denen Leute zu ganz schlimmen Bedingungen am Leben gehalten werden.
Zugleich muss man aber sagen dass durch solche Dinge auch ein Druck entstehen kann dadurch naja wie willst du denn eigentlich noch anfangen das Ganze zu berechnen.
Es gibt wenn man mal schaut was Krebspatienten kosten.
Wenn man das wirklich mal als Kosten beziffern. Dann sind da ein zwei drei Reihenhäuser sofort mit eingepreist und dennoch würden wir,
ja ganz klar sagen Ja aber der Wert des Menschen ist nicht daran zu messen ob man sagt Na kostet 200 000 ist eigentlich zu viel ist ja schon über 60 wird nicht mehr produktiv sein.
Das ist eine ganz große Problematik die jetzt da auftaucht und noch wird das alles hinter vorgehaltener Hand gemacht.
Ist es auch so dass die bekannten utilitaristischen sich nicht dazu so sehr zu Wort melden.
Also ich hatte extra noch geschaut hat Peter Singer der ja auch manchmal so Euthanasie.
Ideen wieder neu in den Diskurs einführt hat sie schon dazu geäußert.
Corona Ja er hat sich geäußert Er ist aber weil er zugleich Tir Ethiker ist,
eben dafür dass man merkte wie es heißt in China diese Märkte wo dann bis hin zu Wolfs Welpen alles lebend verkauft und geschlachtet wird.
Dass man diese grundsätzlich verbietet weil das ein zu großes Tierleid produziert.
Er hat sich noch nicht zu dieser anderen Sache geäußert.
Aber diese Debatte wird kommen und ich will vielleicht zwei Dinge an diesem Punkt erinnern.
Es gibt einmal jetzt eine Studie von,
Chicago Boys von Nachfolgern von Freedman die jetzt schon einmal ausgerechnet haben wie viel Geld das eigentlich jetzt kostet wenn wir bei diesem Chatham bleiben und wie viel Geld man jetzt gerade ausgibt um Leben zu retten.
Und sie kommen dann auf gewisse Summen dass Sie sagen dass es mit dem Bruttoinlandsprodukt schon so ist.
Die Summen sind egal aber man rechnet dass da schon mal durch.
Es ist noch alles sehr zögerlich formuliert aber man tut das schon mal.
Und dann gibt es diesen neoliberalen der auch diesen ominösen Wirtschaftsnobelpreis bekommen hat.
Gary Becker der hat ja schon in den 50er 60er Jahren gesagt Wir müssen eigentlich die ökonomie auf alles anwenden zum Beispiel auch darauf warum haben Menschen Kinder.
Und dann sagt er Ja Kinder sind eine Investition in die Zukunft.
Sie sind eine risikoreiche Investition denn du weißt ja nicht ob deine Töchter da gerade fleißig lernen wer weiß vielleicht wird nichts aus denen und so. Dann hast du umsonst investiert.
Ich höre schon wie sie wieder Geschichten hören.
Ja diese Sachen und der hat wirklich alles auf diese ökonomie zurückgeführt und hat dann damit auch ein Denken eingebracht das wir alles nur noch unter.
Der Mensch ist vollkommen bezifferbar. Und dann ist eben sich,
das ist dann die Schlussfolgerung die er nicht direkt zieht die man aber dann natürlich sofort daraus ziehen kann dass es eben wirtschaftlich keine gute Investition ist sich um alte zu kümmern.
Da muss man allerdings glaube ich immer sozusagen zweigeteilt arbeiten Zum einen Welche Kennziffern vernimmt man,
dann Woran orientiert man sie also an reinem Profit sozusagen der sich morgen realisieren lässt oder preist man gefahren mit ein.
Das haben wir jetzt beim CO2-Preis zum Beispiel oder eben auch bei der Frage und da kann man ja die Katastrophen fast austauschen.
Aber kann man mit irgendeinem Kennwerte der politisch auch abfragen ist ja so eine Kleine Anfrage der Linkspartei wie steht es um den Kennwerte.
Könnte man ein Kennwort generieren der darstellt wie sehr Deutschland beispielsweise Rücklagen hat um ein halbes Jahr lang die frei Künstlerszene rauszuhauen also dass der Staat einfach Gehälter übernimmt.
Wie sehen die Kennwerte aus zum Thema medizinische Material Versorgung für die nächsten 18 Monate oder Sohne.
Man kann es bei der ökonomisierung lassen aber trotzdem mit kennen. werden gegen die man wo man sich auch politisch sperrt da wo man sagt Die halten wir einfach ein. Das ist sozusagen Daseinsvorsorge.
Über den reinen BWL Profit hinaus.
Und da würde ich sagen Die Kritik sollte sehr scharf sein beim Thema reines Profitstreben,
aber man sollte sehr sensibel mit den Kennziffern umgehen und die sollte man aber trotzdem weil wir es beim Thema Geld und so weiter sehr mit vergleichbaren Maßstäben und so weiter zu tun haben und weil es auch,
über die Genner über die Gesellschaft zu Spannendes.
Wie soll man sagen Geld ist als symbolisch generalisierte Kommunikationsmedium einfach sehr flexibel einsetzbar wir haben nichts Vergleichbares.
Alles andere sind Zugeständnisse beim Thema Geld. Können wir es einfach immer sehr genau herunterbrechen.
Die Deutsche Bahn macht ja auch klingt immer so albern aber ihre interne Abrechnung ein.
Ein Regionalexpress oder eine S-Bahn fährt in einen Bahnhof ein und dafür werden irgendwo 18 Euro 17 verrechnet und am Ende dieser Rechnung wird derjenige bezahlt.
Aus diesem Topf aus diesen Geldern der dann den Bahnhof sauber macht und so weiter.
Also die Kennziffern sind genau richtig aber das Profitstreben ist halt falsch.
Weil wir die Kennziffern rausnimmt dann hat man es auch mit Blindheit zu tun und das ist auch eines der größten Probleme die wir grad haben wir wissen nicht wo das Virus ist und es ist selbst unsichtbar.
Wir haben zwar weniger sichtbar zu machen aber das dauert alles unendlich lange und es Verfahrens aufwendig.
Man darf sich nicht selbst blind machen. Nur dadurch dass man so eine Kennziffer Kritik macht oder so eine so eine ökonomisierung.
Haben wir uns ja blind gemacht insofern als wir ja sehr spät auf Coruna dann doch reagiert haben indem man sagte dass man hat da tatsächlich an kurzfristigen Profit gedacht.
Gut wenn wir jetzt die Großveranstaltung auch noch verlieren und die Carneval und all das wenn wir das jetzt absagen dann kostet das aber so und so viel und dann kommen da drei Veranstalter und verklagen noch uns am Ende also machen wir das nicht.
Und hat jetzt ja ökonomisch viel größeren Schaden angerichtet weil es jetzt gar nicht mehr anders geht.
Da hätte man sicherlich ökonomisch denken müssen und dann hätte man glaube ich erkannt dass man ökonomisch sinnvolleres hätte machen können auch wenn man einfach gesagt hätte am 15.
Januar also am 31. Januar waren noch viele davon überzeugt oder fast alle. Im übrigen Unsere Promis.
Virologen nahmen mit Sars das wird schon nicht so schlimm hier werden und so aber dennoch hätte man ja sagen können Gut.
Wir haben jetzt das Geld Wir nehmen jetzt hier mal 50 oder hundert Millionen Euro in die Hand und produzieren einfach schon mal Masken fragen schon mal alles ab.
Könntet ihr dann auch Masken produzieren was geht da Giermann nach Deutschland.
Wir fangen einfach mal an sonst liegen die ja gut die werden ja nicht direkt schlecht.
Macht ja nichts ist einfach mal eine Investition und dann gucken wir mal.
Und ansonsten verbuchen wir das irgendwo unter Spesen kosten.
Und dass man das aber nicht gemacht hat.
Da hätte man ja ganz ökonomisch gedacht sondern erst mal geguckt ob man ganz ohne ohne irgendwelche Kosten rauskommt indem man das Virus einfach nicht hier hin gerät.
Hat man jetzt den ökonomisch größeren Schaden Quarte.
Ich bin auch nicht gegen gegen ökonomisches Denken Gotte denn ich glaube nur dass problematisch wird es wenn man wenn man anfängt sagt ja welcher Mensch bringt uns ökonomisch etwas.
Die meisten Leute sind. Also wir sind auch nicht Systemwandel.
Na ja genau also der Begriff Systemrelevanz ist nicht falsch aber auch nicht auf alles anwendbar.
Das muss man etwas sagen wir leben nicht nur aus diesen utilitaristischen.
Da geht es Utilities ja das Wort was da drin steckt.
Man darf gerne auch zweckfrei Das ist der Sinn von Freiheit einfach mal zweckfrei.
Und zwar auch individuell sich dafür entscheiden gefährliche Sachen zu machen.
Ja es ist ja verrückt dass man jetzt keine Fallschirmspringer mehr macht weil man Angst vor Corona hat.
Das muss man ja auch erst einmal verarbeiten irgendwie intellektuell was das eigentlich bedeutet.
So eine Abwägung zu machen und ist deswegen so wie du es eben formuliert Das ist genau richtig.
Ich würde auch sagen der Drusen hat trotzdem recht wenn er sagt Jetzt sind keine Schuldfrage zu stellen aber ich finde auch wir müssen jetzt auch mal darüber diskutieren,
das Dezentralität und Daseinsvorsorge einfach Sachen sind,
die wir jetzt beachten müssen zukünftig da dürfen wir nie wieder hinten zurückfallen weil wir nämlich mit ökonomischen Argumenten sagen können warum das einfach sonst zu teuer wird.
Auch wenn es mal ein bisschen teurer ist die Leute in Brandenburg damit zu beschäftigen Mundschutz herzustellen und nicht nur die in China die paar Cent pro Maske sondern einfach einrechnen.
Aber ich glaube es ist wichtig dass man jetzt auch einfach eine ökonomische Diskussion dafür dass man es mit der Mittelmacht.
Im Privaten ja auch. Wir machen das im Privaten auch.
Du wirst zwei Festplatten zu Hause stehen haben obwohl du nur eigentlich eine brauchst oder manche haben drei zuhause oder haben das nochmal in der Cloud und bezahlen da auch nochmal monatlichen Betrag für Mann.
Eigentlich kann ich mich ja auch einfach darauf verlassen Mein Computer ist halt ganz und wird nichts passieren fertig.
Aber man sagt Gut ich gehe diese Mehrkosten von 80 Euro Festplatte oder was das kostet gehe ich ein und sage dann Was ist dann hab ich aber die Festplatte da.
Ähnlich wäre das mit so etwas wie Masken. Jetzt muss man sich fragen welche anderen Szenarien gibt es wo man vorhalten muss wenn man sagen muss Das brauchen wir.
Hier leben wir am Rhein. Wir haben selbstverständlich Sandsäcke also nicht wir persönlich aber die Feuerwehr hat die.
Und wenn dann weiter vorne an der Straße wenn da der Rhein überschwappt dann kommen die eben mit Sandsäcken da fangen die nicht erst mal an und sagen Da wo kriegen wir jetzt Sand her.
Dafür ist gesorgt und so haben wir ja verschiedene Krisenszenarien. Und ich glaube da muss man sich schon darauf vorbereiten.
Es geht ja eigentlich auch in der Demokratie ganz viel darum dass sie auf vieles vorbereitet ist.
Dieses Stressresistenz ist eigentlich sehr entscheidend in komplexen Gesellschaften denn sonst kann es nicht funktionieren denn es ist ja eigentlich eine relativ kleine Sache die jetzt zu einer globalen Eskalation führt.
Also Wir denken bei globalen Eskalationen ja tatsächlich an Weltkrieg und denken an große militärische Konflikte und wir haben aber jetzt das Unsichtbare Virus das für die meisten muss man ja auch wieder sagen,
nicht besonders problematisch ist sondern die bekommen halt einen Schnupfen vielleicht bisschen Fieber und dann ist gut.
Ja das ist das Allerwichtigste überhaupt beim drüber nachdenken.
Es ist kein Atomkraftwerk explodiert und hat in diesem Moment 500000 Menschen getötet und droht im nächsten Jahr.
Und da kann man dann auch nichts dagegen tun nochmal 30 Millionen Menschen zu töten weil man einfach zu dicht wohnt im Elsass oder so. Keine Ahnung sondern wir haben im Grunde mit einer Krise zu tun die klar global auftritt.
Aber selbst wenn man jetzt keine Menschen medizinisch hilft dann hat man eine Sterberate von einem Prozent und das kann man auf die Weltbevölkerung hochrechnen.
Und im Vergleich zu zur grundsätzlichen sterbe Zahl würde das vielleicht gar nicht mal so statistisch auffallen.
Wir kennen die Zahlen aus Italien wo es wirklich hart ist das Durchschnittsalter der Todesopfer ist 79 Jahre.
Das kratzt schon an der Lebenserwartung in Deutschland ist es 81 Jahre liegt also genau auf der Lebenserwartung Wir haben es also auch mit dem Problem zu tun das Leben die sowieso.
In Deutschland sterben jeden Tag zweieinhalb dreieinhalbtausend Leute. Das ist einfach Der ganz normale.
Irgendwann hört das Leben halt auf der Kreislauf schafft es dann nicht mehr und dann ist es der ganz normale natürliche das natürliche Ende des Lebens.
Und statt das man einfach im August stirbt stirbt man jetzt schon im März nach zwei drei Wochen Strapaze auf der Intensivstation.
Und es schlummern hier die ein oder anderen.
Wie soll man sagen Gefahren für eine politische Auslegung die nicht noch nicht und vielleicht später einmal falsch nicht adäquat diskutiert werden.
Denn wir haben es tatsächlich mit einer Herausforderung zu tun die wir uns noch nicht so richtig trauen auszusprechen Es war hier nur ein Halbsatz im Daily Podcast.
Deswegen haben wir damals kurz rein mit der Frage Warum sind eigentlich Kinder so wenig betroffen.
Smog.
Es könnte sein dass Menschen Kinder sind einfach gesünder. Die haben noch nicht so lange diese Strapazen dieser Naturzerstörung und wie man halt in New York rauchend an der Schnellstraße steht und so da ist halt die Luft einfach schlimm.
Nicht mehr als in manchen Städten noch glaube in New York nicht.
Jetzt nicht mehr aber man sagen wir mal so stand da jahrelang irgendwie an der Straße keine Ahnung es war der dichteste Autoverkehr der Welt und man hat eine Zigarette nach der anderen geraucht eines Abends noch zum Saufen irgendwo hingegangen hat zu wenig geschlafen,
und die Diskussionen die jetzt die nächsten Monate beginnt ist ja,
Wie hält man eigentlich Jugendliche im Zaum.
Die sagen es betrifft mich doch nicht. Es ist mir doch egal. Meine Oma ist eh schon tot. Ich habe schon getrauert da muss ich jetzt für alle anderen Omas auch noch und so weiter.
Es beginnt jetzt der Frühling. Es wir haben in Deutschland 250 000 Polizisten,
das heißt wir können so ungefähr 40 Prozent der Jugendlichen polizeilich betreuen was ein bis Missachtung der allgemeinen Verfügung angeht. Aber nicht alle.
Es ist nicht nur diese wirtschaftliche Diskussion.
Zieren ginge am Rhein sah ich dort sehr viele Jugendliche und ich glaube nicht dass das alles Kernfamilie waren um es mal so zu sagen.
Ist dadurch dass Frühling ist wenn jetzt Herbst weil wir ein bisschen anders aber es ist jetzt Frühling.
Die Leute werden jetzt nach draußen drängen und man wird auch so unter der Hand im Garten ist doch nicht so schlimm und dann kommen ja trotzdem die drei Freundinnen rüber oder so. Also irgendwie. Diese Diskussion geht los.
Und noch gibt es ja in Deutschland deswegen werden wir Immunität.
Dass die Gesellschaft wirklich entzweien kann in ungefährdet und vielleicht auch schon Coruna Absolventen. Da kommt ja auch mal eine große Gruppe dazu.
Und Menschen wirklich Hilfe brauchen also Menschen die 60 Jahre alt sind und Asthma haben.
Wenn die hören Es gibt vielleicht im Sommer 2021 eine Impfung.
Dann heißt das für die jetzt 13 Monate 14 Monate Quarantäne die man vielleicht immer mehr selbstorganisiert muss weil der Staat ja immer mehr ausfällt dafür zu sorgen.
Und deswegen fangen wir mal an das zu dokumentieren. Im März klang Olaf Scholz noch so.
Sehr sehr viele schwer infizierte die sehr intensiv behandelt werden müssen begleiten und unterstützen kann.
Aber es geht ja hier ein Ausgleich zu finden zwischen dem Schutz der Gesundheit der Bevölkerung der ganz ganz wichtig ist und auf der anderen Seite die Frage Wie lange hält die Wirtschaft das aus. Wie lange halten die Menschen das aus.
Diese Interessen gilt es ja jetzt auszugleichen was sind die nächsten Schritte in den Tagen und Wochen.
Ich kann Ihre Alternative nicht ganz akzeptieren wenn sie das gestatten. Das Allerwichtigste ist die Gesundheit der Bürgerinnen und Bürger.
Im März ja im April werden wir das so nicht mehr da muss er mehr liefern wenn er den Punkt machen will.
Ich glaube auch der interessanteste Konflikt werden.
Und das wird auch noch nochmal vielleicht ein. Stadt und Provinz Konflikt.
Man hat ja gesehen dass in Berlin in der Clubszene man auch ziemlich beratungsresistent war.
Dass dort sich immer noch sehr viele in Parks treffen zwar versucht man jetzt mit ein bisschen Distanz und so aber es ist doch da sehr viel los und es ist,
auch eine Stadt in der viele Leute ihre Familien hinter sich gelassen haben die Familien leben irgendwo in der Provinz die leben nicht in Berlin und das sind,
junge Leute die sind unter 40 oder unter 45 und sagen Naja so schlimm wird es nicht werden und ich will aber jetzt hier auch meinen Lifestyle Eigentlich leben sie werden jetzt nicht gleich in den nächsten Flieger mehr steigen das sicherlich auch nicht,
da sie auch wissen naja wenn was passiert bin ich vielleicht in einem deutschen Krankenhaus doch ein bisschen besser aufgehoben.
Aber das wird ich glaube auch da können wir einen Blick dann die nächsten Monate drauf werfen.
Ein sehr entscheidender Konflikt werden und dann ist die Frage der Solidarität.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen dass einige ein bisschen so sind dass sie jetzt quasi den älteren zeigen wollen na guck mal wir passen auf euch auf während ihr vom Klimawandel nichts wissen wolltet.
Das kann passieren oder eben auch Leute die sagen Na ja Ihr Euch ist der Klimawandel ihr Fahrer doch vollkommen egal aber ich soll mich jetzt um euch besonders bemühen die ihr jetzt gefährdet seid.
Ich glaube auch dass da auch inner halb der Familien oder der bekannten Kreise kann da der eine oder andere Konflikt entstehen.
Das mit dem Klima ist wirklich interessant wie parallel es eigentlich läuft.
Schellnhuber Ich habe nur so eine Karre gesehen ich weiß nie ob das Zitat echt ist aber da hat ja schon verglichen Corona zu verstreuen ist genauso unvernünftig wie CO2 einfach gedankenlos in die Welt zu blasen.
Ich finde auf unterschiedlichen Ebenen statt aber ich fand das erst mal einen ganz triftigen Vergleich den sollte man auch so nicht zu schnell abwehren.
Der zweite Druck in der Diskussion ist natürlich dieser ökonomische.
Das Ifo-Institut hat es ja mal nachgerechnet Wir hören jetzt eine Spannweite an Wirtschaftsabschwung,
der eigentlich interessante Faktor da drin der eigentlich so richtig den Hebel auf die Politik anwendet. Der wurde allerdings gar nicht ausgesprochen.
Wir haben eine Rezession die wohl tiefer ist als in Zeiten der Finanzkrise. Die Wirtschaftsforscher des Ifo-Instituts erwarten einen Rückgang des Bruttoinlandsproduktes von 7,2 bis zwanzig komma sechs Prozentpunkten.
Das Coronavirus werde Deutschlands Wirtschaft Hunderte von Milliarden Euro Produktionsausfälle bescheren.
Kurzarbeit und Arbeitslosigkeit in die Höhe schießen lassen und den Staatshaushalt erheblich belasten teilte das Institut am Montag mit.
So 7,2 bis zwanzig komma sechs. Was ist das für eine komische spannende fragt man sich oder die Rechnung ist allerdings ganz klar pro Woche ein Prozent,
das heißt sieben Prozent bei fünf Wochen oder was weil da kommt so eine kleine Delle mit rein.
Und bei 18 Wochen sind es 20 Prozent.
Das weiß die Politik auch die wissen ganz genau und sie haben wenig Anhaltspunkte aber das ist erst mal die Kalkulation pro Woche ein Prozent Minus.
Und dann kommt man natürlich ins überlegen.
Die sagen ist dafür dass es zu krass ist theoretisch.
Zu simpel als sich dagegen wehren kann.
Am Ende Ende April vielleicht sagen Komm wir machen noch zwei Wochen Mai in der Hoffnung dass die Krankenhäuser irgendwie damit umgehen können weil wir weiß noch nicht genau wie es die Diskussion Ende April und jede Woche ist minus ein Prozent,
in Sicht.
Hoher Druck auf die Politik weil dieser Zeitrahmen hier so klar ist.
Und Michael Hüther hat im SWR 2 Forum noch einmal dargestellt außer dieser ganz simplen Rechnung pro Woche minus ein Prozent BIP kann man eigentlich sonst noch irgendwas sagen und die Antwort ist wirklich schlimm.
Ist man inzwischen in der Lage zum Beispiel ein Modell zu bauen das uns mit einer Pandemie vertraut macht und sagt So und so könnte würde wird wahrscheinlich die Dynamik verlaufen.
Nein ein ganz klares Nein antworten Nein weil wir ja solche Pandemie Verläufe nicht kennen.
Wir wissen gar nichts über die ökonomischen Folgen dieser Panik Wir wissen nur wir wirtschaften gerade nicht einfach mal pro Woche ein Prozent.
Wir haben durch die Pandemie einen Vorteil gegenüber anderen Wirtschaftskrisen die in einzelnen Ländern oder einzelnen Kreisen Konti auf anderen Kontinenten stattfinden.
Die Pandemie ist total global das heißt allen geht es schlechter.
Das heißt diese Wettbewerbsvorteile haben wir schon mal nicht dass man sagt Okay wir haben jetzt gerade hier im Westen eine Krise und deshalb sieht jetzt was weiß ich wer an uns rasant vorbei ist.
Das heißt Wir alle müssen auf die Bremse treten und dadurch hat man sozusagen erst einmal da keinen neuen Wettbewerb der entsteht sondern es ist der alte Es wird am Ende aber ein Wettbewerb darum gehen wer als erstes wieder einsteigt.
Da versucht man das jetzt schon. Und da versuchen dann Politiker zu sagen Na ja wir müssen die Arbeiter halt wieder in die Fabrik rein.
Trump hat ja da gewisse Vorstellungen Johnson auch und da gibts von Beust ganz zu schweigen.
Das wird sicherlich einen Druck ausüben und wir müssen sagen diese Coruna Krise könnte eine Sinnkrise bedeuten dass Leute tatsächlich über Dinge anders nachdenken.
Sicherlich wird es einige Zweige ganz ganz hart treffen.
Vermutlich ist die Urlaubsfotos der meisten Deutschen für das Jahr 2020 egal wie sehr die Lockerungen kommen werden auch wenn die in vier Wochen alle wieder gelockert alles wieder gelockert sind alles wieder gut ist die Reiselust dahin.
Das wird ganz deutlich sein ob der allgemeine Konsum auf denen man jetzt gerade verzichtet auch weil man jetzt nichts braucht nicht in Geschäfte kann oder nicht so das Gefühl dafür hat ob der wieder anzieht.
Ich könnte es mir schon vorstellen. Denn an sich kann man sagen lief es ja in diesem Land relativ gut und.
Deswegen ist es jetzt gerade eine Bremse und man hat,
wenn man auch mit kleineren Unternehmern spricht bei all diesen den Eindruck Ja wir wollen wieder Wir überlegen jetzt gerade und jetzt machen wir uns wenigstens mal gerade nochmal eine neue Homepage machen und so und so gehen wir dann an den Start.
Dass es da schon so ein Gefühl geben wird jetzt wird wieder in die Hände gespuckt wir steigern das Bruttosozialprodukt in diese Richtung wird es glaube ich schon etwas gehen.
Aber einige Zweige werden aus dieser Sinnkrise so schnell nicht rauskommen.
Ob das ein allgemeines Umdenken im Konsum gibt wie das manche meinten auch der Post Wachstums ökonomie oder so.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube auch schon deshalb nicht.
Man wird eben gewisse Lieferketten und das schon angesprochene Masken und all das wird man in Frage stellen.
Das könnte einen gewissen Trend zur derGlobalisierung geben.
Aber was es sicherlich nicht geben wird dass das auf Wachstum und Konsum jetzt plötzlich kritischer blickt.
Wir haben das gleich noch einmal bei den Intellektuellen aber das Virus ist ja nicht daraus entstanden das Virus ist ja nicht deshalb entstanden ist weil wir zu viele Smartphones produziert haben.
Im Gegenteil Das Virus ist an einem Ort entstanden wo noch eigentlich eine ganz archaische Form des Wirtschaftens nämlich auf einem Marktplatz.
Das ist so was die neoklassische ökonomie sich immer noch vorstellt wenn sie über Wirtschaft redet was in der Regel nicht mehr zutrifft nämlich der Marktplatz.
Und dort treffen sich dann die Akteure.
Hier war es dann der Naschmarkt wo es zugleich auch dann noch gewisse Traditionen gibt die uns als Westler besonders fern erscheinen die dort aufrecht erhalten werden.
Dort ist das Virus entstanden sehr wahrscheinlich so heißt es dann eben durch diese Wildtiere die da verkauft werden die einander vor Ort geschlachtet werden und all das.
Das heißt wir haben hier eigentlich noch aus einer alten Zeit die überhauptnicht aus dem 20.
Jahrhundert stammt haben wir ein Virus jetzt in unsere Gegenwart bekommen.
Deswegen ist das Virus glaub ich nicht der Anlass dafür dass die Leute jetzt sagen Jetzt denken wir plötzlich über unsere Wirtschaft neu nach in der Form dass wir sagen Wir haben auch alle viel zu viel konsumiert.
Diese Märkte die tatsächlich funktionieren wie vor 700 Jahren in China.
Das ist ja nun wirklich. Die Chinesen haben ja eine 4000 Jahre alte Archive in denen minutiös aufgeschrieben wurde wer wann welchen Laden irgendwie mal irgendwo an welcher Straßenecke hatte und diese Märkte funktionieren seit Jahrhunderten genau gleich.
Man kommt da dahin und holt sich sein Tier möglichst frisch und lebend und in der einen Sendung hat ja auch,
Hirschhausen dieser deutsche Promi Arzt Drosten mal gefragt,
was ist mit diesen anderen 700 Tieren die dann noch so in Tieren schlummern von denen man weiß die sind auch nur so eine kleine Mutation davon entfernt sich bei dem der das Tier ist breitzumachen und das ist eben jetzt genau so passiert in diesem Fall,
und man hat diese Märkte erstmal verboten zumindest in China.
Aber wir wissen ja genau in China wird etwas verboten und auf dem Hinterhof findet das dann trotzdem noch 80 Jahre lang statt weil hat man ja immer so gemacht.
Wieder die ausgesetzt wurden Peter Singer hat er auch in seinem Aufsatz drauf verwiesen. Das ist noch nicht durch die Sache.
Die Märkte werden irgendwann auch wieder kommen.
Eine,
große Veränderung und dann diese Herdentrieb erhärten Immunität Diskussion der Kekulé der nun den zweiten als zweit erfolgreichsten Podcast in Deutschland macht auch als Virologe gleich nach Drosten nicht für den Ende.
Sondern für den MDR er also auch große Konjunktur bei den öffentlich-Rechtlichen.
Der geht hier mal dieser Abwägung durch. Ist es denkbar Risikogruppen gezielt zu.
Wenn wir jetzt in der Lage wären die Risikogruppen konsequent zu schützen dann wäre es für die anderen eine Erkrankung die ungefähr so schlimm ist wie eine schwere Grippewelle.
Natürlich ist eine schwere Grippewelle auch nichts Tolles aber wir müssen ja auch immer beide Seiten sehen die wirtschaftlichen Schäden die psychologischen Schäden die sozialen Schäden die wir machen durch diesen lock down.
Und deshalb glaube ich schon dass man sagen muss an irgendeinem Punkt Wir nehmen so etwas wie eine Grippewelle jetzt einfach mal hin.
Da wird es dann passieren dass die Menschen zum Teil natürlich auch immunisiert werden. Und wir sorgen aber dafür dass nicht besonders viele Fälle ins Land kommen.
Wir sorgen dafür dass das langsam abläuft indem wir eine konsequente soziale Distanzierung machen da kann ich gleich noch was dazu sagen.
Und wir sorgen vor allem dafür dass unsere Risikogruppen geschützt sind indem wir die Alten und Menschen mit Vorerkrankungen entsprechend schützen.
So jetzt haben wir aber das Problem Wir wissen nicht genau wie groß sind eigentlich die Risikogruppen,
und jetzt kann man natürlich nach Schweden gucken und sich dieses Bild vor Augen haben ja die gehen ja eh morgens erst mal alle schwimmen im Teich und so kommen gestellt.
Raus dann nochmal kurz auf 180 nehmen sie eine Berg hoch rennen und leben im Grunde gesund und sind deswegen vielleicht ein bisschen anders.
In Deutschland ist das ganz anders Wir sind ein unglaublich Altes Land. Bei uns sind demnächst ist es auch so eine Zahl von dem Deutschen Institut für Wirtschaft in Köln.
Sieben Prozent der Ostdeutschen werden in Pflegestufen erwartet in den nächsten zehn Jahren.
Wir haben in Amerika die Situation dass dort die Lebenserwartung sank,
weil die Männer mit 55 Jahren einfach reihenweise weg starben,
durch falschen Lebenswandel und so weiter und wenn da so ein Virus sich raumgreifend dann kann man natürlich nicht einfach sagen Ja gut da müssen wir die Risikogruppen isolieren im Sinne von vor einem Altenheim einfach einen doppelten Zaun aufmachen oder sowas nenne.
The daily wurde das mal diskutiert und ich höre so ein bisschen raus. Die Risikogruppe ist vielleicht sogar in der Mehrheit.
Conditions.
Jetzt.
Selbst wenn es nicht um Todesfälle geht. Allein die kritischen Verläufe.
Da hat man glaube ich schon in Amerika eine andere Zahl. Die Leute sind da so abhängig.
Krankheit im übrigen aber auch hier in Deutschland. Emmanuel Todd hat sich ja auch mit der Bevölkerungsentwicklung in seinem,
letzten Buch auseinandergesetzt indem er auch auf die Sterblichkeitsrate der weißen Männer dieser dieser weißen Unterschicht der sogenannten eingeht.
Und kommt da auch zu erschreckenden Zahlen.
Und wenn man sich das Ganze in Deutschland ansieht.
Wir hatten ja jetzt sofort eine ganz große Debatte weil du auf die Pflegestufe da abgezielt hast.
Es ging darum denn die polnischen Altenpflegerinnen noch eingeflogen werden oder noch mit Bussen hier rüber gefahren werden wenn jetzt die Grenzen gesperrt sind.
Und wollen die überhaupt jetzt noch kommen denn die haben ja auch ein Risiko und wollen sich nicht hier infizieren und das dann vielleicht ihrer alten Verwandtschaft dann nach Hause bringen.
Und da sieht man direkt wie groß die Abhängigkeit der eigentlich da war.
Und da haben wir auch wieder eine Lieferkette die unter brauchen.
Wird ein bisschen und sofort gibt es ein ganz ganz großes Problem denn wer kümmert sich dann um die Alten wenn das eben dann nicht die polnischen Pflegekräfte sind.
Die Eltern sind jetzt schon mit den Kindern zum Teil überfordert und sollten sich jetzt auch dann noch um die Alten kümmern.
Also auch hier sehen wir wieder diese ganz ganz große Abhängigkeit die wir haben gerade weil wir so ein altes Land sind.
Ja es sind Hunderttausende eher ältere aber noch im Berufsalltag,
polnische Frauen die die private Pflege in Deutschland,
übernehmen weil die kriegen dann von der Schwiegertochter irgendwie 1000 Euro im Monat und ein Zimmer und dann sind die halt hier wie so Au-Pair-Mädchen und pflegen im Grunde die alten Angehörigen und das betrifft 80 Prozent der Deutschen Pflegefälle nur 20 Prozent wird,
stationär gemacht oder so dass man,
80 Prozent der Pflege findet tatsächlich in privaten Räumen und privat organisiert statt in Deutschland.
Und wir haben sowieso schon das Problem dass es da eine sehr hohe Zahl von Gewalt gibt also Menschen die dement werden.
Sind einfach nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen und reagieren auch sehr emotional und sehr aggressiv auf alles Mögliche in einem Umfeld.
Sehr häufig ist es so dass sie nicht von den eigenen Kindern sondern es sind,
die Schwieger Die angeheirateten die eigentlich so die lange Beziehung also nicht so die emotionale Bindung haben als dass sie da so liebevoll mit,
alles einstecken sondern es ist einfach sowieso eine große schlimme Lage gewesen in der viel zu wenig Geld ist und die Politik hat sich halt immer darauf ausgeruht dass es noch so funktioniert weil die Selbstzahler Beiträge für die stationäre Arbeit einfach zu hoch ist leistet man sich nicht dann,
zahlt man lieber tausend Euro Monat für so eine Politik und diese Hunderttausenden von Frauen Die fallen jetzt alle aus gerade die sind jetzt wirklich,
die haben eigene Familien und so weiter meistens machen die es auch nur mäßig die sind dann so 4 Monate hier um sich einen Urlaub zu leisten oder sowas.
Arbeitsrechtlich wurde da immer so ein bisschen nicht ganz so genau hingeschaut wie beim Babysitting. Das fand dann einfach statt.
Genau da ist einfach da ist ein großes soziologisch interessantes Gefüge das jetzt politisch neu organisiert werden muss weil diese Menschen auch auf dem Arbeitsmarkt ausfallen.
Wer pflegt zuhause Hause nicht auf die Politik zurückgreifen kann der muss halt einfach selber ran.
Man kann ja die Leute dann nicht irgendwie ganz liegen lassen und selbst wenn man noch arbeitet dann arbeitet man einfach an einem anderen Modus weil dann hat man zu viel um die Ohren um das ordentlich zu machen.
Wir haben sozusagen auf vielen Ebenen so eine Schieflage und mit Blick auf Amerika und die Risikogruppen wie groß sind Sie eigentlich.
Hier nun mal so ein 5 Sekunden habe ich mir vor einem Jahr herausgesucht aus einer beliebigen ZDF Doku aber das ist jetzt eines der großen Probleme hier.
Die unbequeme Wahrheit heißt das moderne Leben ist eine Gefahr für unsere Gesundheit.
Das moderne Leben ist eine Gefahr für unsere Gesundheit nicht nur in Amerika sind die Menschen ab 50 wenn man ihnen seine Fitness macht die immer so ein bisschen mit Monitoren was vor sich geht dann zeigt die biologische als 74.
Sie bewegen sich zu wenig und sie essen zu falsch und sie schleppen zuviel Gewicht mit sich herum.
Das ist eine wie soll man sagen.
Man konnte sich gegen alles Mögliche wehren in dieser Welt gegen alle möglichen Gefahren mit einem noch so großen Vorgarten einem noch so großen Auto was auch immer.
Aber jetzt Butter bei die Fische Er ist jetzt die Losung Entweder man ist fit und hält so eine Krankheit aus oder eben nicht.
Und da kann man sich auch nicht länger selbst belügen und einfach denken.
In meinem Tesla sind der medizinische Luftfilter drin.
Nee man kann jetzt nicht ein Jahr lang in seinem Tesla leben sondern muss jetzt aussteigen und sich der Gefahr stellen und dieses Virus ist gnadenlos.
Das lässt sich nicht wegdiskutieren.
Und da nützt auch kein Donald Trumps Binn oder sowas sondern es ist halt einfach da und es ist genau so wie es ist.
Wie bewertet denn dieser Diskurs aktiv bis ins hohe Alter Fitness mit über 80.
Das gibt es ja auch alles. Es gibt ja doch auch diese Senioren die mir entgegenkommen in Funktionskleidung mit Stöcken.
Wenn ich an meine Großeltern denke wäre das niemals passiert dass mein Großvater nicht im Anzug spazieren gegangen ist sondern da irgendwie mit Stöcken mir entgegengekommen ist.
Das wäre ja lachhaft gewesen auch hat man nie ein Fitnessstudio besucht und man hat auch immer das gegessen was man gerade wollte und das war vor allem Fleisch weil man das ja mal vor 60 Jahren entbehren musste.
Und die sind ja auch entsprechend alt geworden.
Nicht jetzt aber doch über 80 und dann hat man auch mal einen Infarkt oder so gehabt aber das war dann halt so das war gewissermaßen ein Zeichen für Wohlstand dass man sich das auch noch leisten kann.
Aber wie wäre zu diesen Diskurs dann wenn man sagt wir haben ebenso viele die übergewichtig sind die sich nicht bewegen und zugleich aber so eine große Dominanz,
sehen wir doch zumindest in der Werbung und im alltäglichen Diskurs vom fitten Rentner.
Ich habe ich antworte mal ganz privat ganz persönlich. Ich habe diesen Diskurs komplett in mich inkorporiert.
Schon allein durch die Befassung mit Rentnerehepaar.
Ich sehe unendlich viel Leid unter alten Menschen.
Das allein darauf zurückzuführen ist dass man zu lange dachte wird schon gutgehen und so weiter und plötzlich war man abhängig und kam dann nicht mehr raus.
Ich habe zwei große Vorbilder was das angeht Das eine ist Jan Frodeno das andere.
Udo Jürgens Udo Jürgens ist 80 Jahre alt geworden und war von heute auf morgen tot.
Mitten in der Tournee Mitten in der Tournee.
Mitten in der Tournee war er sozusagen auf seinem Zinni da er konnte noch mit 80 Jahren alles machen was er wollte und dann hat.
Also sagen wir mal so Man kann die Lebenserwartung nicht mehr länger ausreizen.
Das wissen wir jetzt aus der zivilisierten Welt so bei diesen 81 Jahren im Schnitt ist irgendwie Schluss und ab 91 wird man wirklich gebrechlich. Da führt nichts dran vorbei.
Man kann allerdings die Phase des guten qualitativen Lebens auch bis dahin ausreizen Man muss nicht mehr zehn Jahre leiden.
Dann sterben soll man kann also das was Udo Jürgens geschafft hat ist machbar das ist bei ihm nicht Zufall oder so gewesen sondern das ist im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten.
Wenn man ein Leben so führt dass man am Ende sozusagen einfach stirbt und mit 80 Jahren stirbt man nicht zu früh das darf man dann nicht sagen.
Nur weil man denkt man hätte doch noch zehn Jahre leiden können oder so ne mit 80 Jahren hat man lange gelebt und viel erlebt und wenn man es so lange wie möglich schafft fit zu bleiben ist genau richtig.
Und Jan Frodeno hat hier in Frankfurt diesen Menn gewonnen als es so heiß war es war der heißeste Tag des Jahres.
Wir waren damals bei uns hier in so einem See den sie jetzt am Baggersee fertiggemacht haben mit schönen Muscheln Sand und so.
Ich lag so da und hab das in dieser Hitze geguckt auf meinem Handy wie Marathon läuft mit einer Peake von drei 53 durch Frankfurt am Main.
Während ich selbst es geradezu ausgehalten hab aber nur wenn ich mit der Hüfte im Wasser stand da stehen war schon belastend.
So ein Marathon der am Ende gelaufen nach 180 Kilometer Fahrradfahren und hat dann am Ende in einem Interview gesagt direkt fünf Minuten nach Zieleinlauf.
Ja das war schon echt krass. Ich brauche jetzt mehr Hitze Training. Ich dachte selbst Er sieht noch Potenzial sich noch besser anzupassen.
Und seitdem mache ich auch Triathlon Training. Also Ich achte einfach drauf dass ich einmal im Monat so ein Allmann schaffe also vier Kilometer Schwimmen und dann Aufwärmen sodass einmal im Monat sozusagen die Strecke absolviert ist.
Weil ich an den beiden an Jan Frodeno und an Udo Jürgens gesehen habe.
Es zahlt sich aus am Ende man führt tatsächlich die ganz reine ökonomische Abwägung wie jetzt diese hätten wir doch nur genug Mundschutz.
Dann hätten wir jetzt ganz viel von dem sparen können hätte es doch nur einmal im Monat die Strecke absolviert dann hätte sie mit 60 und so weiter.
Und wenn der Klimawandel kommt war das für mich zum Klimawandel Dinge.
Wenn der Klimawandel da ist und wir hier drei Wochen lang Phasen mit 45 Grad haben will ich Fitna durchgehen.
Ich habe nicht den Anspruch an Marathon zu laufen.
In dieser Hitze aber ich will fit durchkommen und mir wurde gezeigt dass es geht.
Also Jan Frodeno hat mit der Hitze gar kein Problem wenn Wettkampftag ist halt ein bisschen unangenehmer.
Aber ohne Wettkampftag hätte er mit Hitze gar kein Problem. Und das finde ich beeindruckend und auch erstrebenswert.
Und deswegen habe ich das richtig eingebaut jetzt in mein Leben dass ich jetzt anfange vorzusorgen. Wenn der Klimawandel kommt.
Und als jetzt Corona kam habe ich mir schon gedacht Okay es zahlt sich auch dafür aus weil es anscheinend doch eine Krankheit die einfach,
die Lebenserwartung raubt am Ende aber irgendwie den Fuß.
Auf das Glück und auf Zufall. Ich möchte hier sehr alt werden aber ich muss dann irgendwie darauf vertrauen dass es mir dann so wie Helmut Schmidt oder so ergeht dass man trotzdem so alt wurde und man sagt ja unglaublich.
Und ich werde dann immer noch rauchen und Cola light trinken obwohl ich ja sehr wenig rauche muss ich sagen Ich habe ja mit um auch eine Anekdote zu erzählen,
Ich habe als Jopie Heesters 103 war habe ich einen Konzertabend von ihm besucht und das war sehr beeindruckend.
Eine ganze Stunde am Klavier gestanden und noch gesungen hat auch noch eine Zigarette geraucht und das ging aber das sind natürlich eher die Ausnahmen oder es ist eine absolute Ausnahme der hat glaube ich auch relativ gesund gelebt.
Er war zwar Raucher aber doch in Maßen hat seinen Champagner oder was getrunken aber auch nicht zu viel und ist immer schlank geblieben.
Insofern hat das irgendwie funktioniert bei ihm wird es sicherlich auch eine Rolle gespielt haben dass seine Frau 45 Jahre jünger war denn das ist ja auch eine Sache wenn man ja wenn man 80 90 ist wenn man so gemeinsam alt und dann auch trutzig und all das,
bleibt natürlich bei solchen Lebensläufen wie bei einem Udo Jürgens dann auch nicht aus dass da noch mal ganz neue Lebensmodelle ausprobiert werden.
Bei dem gab es ja da viel weniger Routinen als bei den meisten Menschen.
Man sieht es auch an den amerikanischen Politikern Trump beiden Sanders waren das aktive Leben die die führen.
Ja ja.
Deswegen sieht man denen ich an dass sie alle über 50 sind die fühlen sich an wie 50. Wenn man das so sieht.
Eben würde ich ja aber dazu kommen wir bestimmt noch häufiger an diesem Podcast bei beiden habe ich nicht den Eindruck dass.
Aber der blüht jetzt auch schon wieder so ein bisschen auf der wirkte schon jetzt wo er diesen Erfolg eingefahren hat das hat ihn ja auch ein bisschen jünger gemacht finde ich.
Eine sehr interessante Wahrnehmung aber das gehört jetzt nicht hierhin.
Ich wäre trotzdem nicht falsch verstanden werden diese persönlichen privaten Ansichten die wir jetzt gab kann man nicht übertragen auf das soziale Phänomen denn wir können natürlich jetzt nicht den ganzen alten Menschen vorwerfen Sie haben zu wenig Sport gemacht oder so.
Sondern Die haben ihr freies Leben geführt und genau das hätten wir auch weshalb wir jetzt in diese politische Diskussion.
Zumal auch Asthmatiker Asthmatiker oft sind das ist ja nicht was verschuldetes muss man auch dazusagen.
Das genau Vorerkrankung. Das ist wirklich kritisch.
Das Crooner eingreift und wir wissen Menschen mit Vorerkrankungen die halten sich im Grunde an die Ratschläge ihres Arztes.
Da spielt man im Grunde nicht mit einem Leben und es kommt diese Bedrohungslage und deswegen fand ich diese amerikanische Diskussion.
Wir haben alle von den Patrick gehört. Das ist der stellvertretende Gouverneur von Texas wie er meinte die alten sollte sich doch einmal opfern. Es geht doch hier ums große amerikanische Ganze.
Während wir ihn sehen schon dachten er Du hast doch selber dein dein intensiv Bett im Keller weil das so ein Pröpper bist oder so.
Glaubst selbst nicht an die Worte die du sagst Wir hören das Zitat nicht direkt sondern wir hören wie bei HeX an Tapp die David Axelrod darüber spricht der damals Obamas Wahlkampf geführt hat.
In Texas.
Mindestens.
Und daran kann man die Verlogenheit erkennen. Während die in Deutschland alle die ganze Regierungsbank die schwarze Null kippt um nur,
ein paar alte Menschen mehr zu schützen als es ohne mit schwarzer Null gelänge steigt man in Amerika nachdem man live war.
Wir greifen natürlich in die Rechte der Frau ein kann doch nicht sein dass sie unser Nachwuchsabteilung und Obamacare ist aber wir wollen ja nicht dass jemand stirbt.
Jetzt mit einem Argument zu kommen das ist so inkonsistent und deswegen schon von sich aus so banane.
Aber trotzdem haben sie sich so geäußert.
Ich kann es nicht glauben aber ich habe den Clip natürlich auch gesehen und es ist unglaublich.
Ist ja auch eine Toleranz für eine solche Aussage in der Gesellschaft. Also ich glaube dass das sehr schwer wäre wenn jetzt ein CDU-Politiker eine solche äußerung tätigen würde. Der könnte gehen.
Aber hier haben wir es dann mit einer Figur zu tun die vermutlich wiedergewählt wird.
Und ich hoffe nicht dass wir hier einfach nur in Amerika schon mal sehen was wir dann im Mai auch diskutieren.
Ja ja.
Besteht natürlich immer eine gewisse Gefahr irgendwie. Naja jedenfalls gibts da noch so einen kleinen Nachsatz.
Ein Fall wenn nicht vielleicht eines noch erinnern darf Wir hatten ja den Junge Union Vorsitzenden Mißfelder der inzwischen verstorben ist der ja auch schon mal solche äußerungen machte.
Naja die alten Leute was da noch alles für teure Operationen dann Krankenhäuser für die gemacht werden also der auch sich ganz ähnlich da schon geäußert hatte mal dass es schon einige Jahre her und fast vergessen aber das kann durchaus wieder kommen.
Kuban macht das Argument ganz ähnlich auch der saß bei Maybrit Illner und sagte ganz ausdrücklich zum Thema Grundrente Ich will nicht dass wir für diese alten Leute mehr bezahlen aus dem Sozialstaat wie bisher,
leider ganz unverblümt ist einfach so gesagt jedenfalls weil du schon meinte Es gibt ja dann eine Wahl im November das stimmt und da gibt's ja noch so einen humoristischen.
Auch wenn es schwerfällt aber einen humoristischen Nachtrag von wirklich zwei Wahlkämpfer die wir.
Hey.
Ihr hier,
Bonobo.
Natürlich tatsächlich seine Wähler auch,
mehr noch als die Demokraten. Naja. Die deutsche Diskussion ist ganz interessant denn Trossen geht ja da wirklich ins Detail.
Er stellt zum Beispiel diese eine Frage Klar kann man jetzt versuchen irgendwie die Risikogruppen zu schützen aber müsste man nicht auch über die Jugend reden.
Da kann man ja nicht einfach sagen jetzt infizieren wir doch mal einzelne Bevölkerungsgruppen durch.
Die haben ja im Zweifelsfall dann doch auch noch ein Mitspracherecht. Also da sagt irgendjemand man müsste doch mal die jungen Leute infizieren.
Da muss man doch mal zurück fragen Hat denn jemand die jungen Leute überhaupt gefragt ob sie darauf Lust haben wollen die sich diesem Risiko aussetzen.
Also das so So einfach ist das ja nicht.
Finde ich interessant dass überhaupt noch von einer Einwilligung ausgegangen wird.
Denn wenn sich nur 10 prozent nicht solidarisch an die Ausgangs Beschränkung halten findet sie sowieso statt.
Da wird ja dann nicht mehr groß darüber diskutiert. Wir haben ja alle mitbekommen wir haben alle mitbekommen wie in England die Diskussion am Anfang anders geführt wurde.
In der Tat.
Wir haben ja auch im letzten Salon z.B. Dominic Cummings Dominic Cummings lag das ja im Grunde.
Also geht das halt ganz eiskalt durch. Mit diesem Nützlichkeit Prinzip das unausgereifte Potenzial findet man bei den jungen und nicht bei den Alten also können die Alten auch einfach mal weggeschickt werden ins Grab wahrscheinlich,
hast du die Bilder gesehen wie Dominic Cummings aus dem Regierungssitz geflüchtet ist zu Fuß.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Boris Johnson hat ja vermeldet dass er Crooner hat und eine Stunde später tauchte bei Video auf.
Wir kennen ja alle die Straße voneinander trennen und so weiter. Wie die Tür aufgeht Dominic Cummings mit seiner Tasche im Arm aus dem Gebäude rennt die Straße weg.
Springt noch eine kleine Treppe runter biegt oh man ist nicht mehr zu sehen. Als hätte man ein Drehbuch geschrieben dafür.
Großartig.
Es ist einfach irre. Naja Drosten jedenfalls fand ich ein bisschen wieso beschwichtigt er hier so Trossen sieht diese englische Diskussion nachträglich so.
Was ich so zwischen den Zeilen durchlese ist dass man in England auf der Basis von Modellrechnungen die Befürchtung hatte dass es noch zu früh ist alles jetzt komplett stillzulegen.
Dass man dann vielleicht sagen wir mal eine begrenzte Zeit der Stilllegung nicht richtig investiert.
Dass man also drei Wochen alles still legt und dann der Eindruck entsteht naja ist ja nichts passiert.
Jetzt machen wir wieder alles auf. Und dann geht es doch wieder richtig los. Dass man also so eine Fel Wahrnehmung und eine falsche Investition dieser Maßnahme vermeiden wollte.
Ich glaube das nicht.
Aber glaub ich ein ganz großes Problem das wir in der Wahrnehmung jetzt haben so stark mit diesem.
Mit dieser Konzentration auf die prominenten Virologen Sie sind Virologen und sie können das was Sie da sagen.
Das können Sie. Da haben sie Ahnung Sie sind Experten.
Experten sind aber nicht dazu da dass sie auch alle großen gesellschaftlichen politischen Zusammenhänge,
erkennen und auch entsprechend genau sagen können So verhält sich Gesellschaft,
wenn er ein bisschen wüsste wie ein Cummings denkt wenn er wüsste wie ein Boris Johnson eigentlich sich Gesellschaft vorstellt dann gibt es da gar nicht diese,
noch wissenschaftlich fundierte überlegung dass man sagt Wer war vielleicht alles an sich ganz sinnvoll das so zu machen und wir haben dann nochmal sondern,
für Comics und Johnson ist das eigentlich eine ganz logische Konsequenz dass man sagt Gut dann machen wir mal ein bisschen reinen Tisch.
Auf diese Weise ist jetzt gerade etwas unangenehm aber grundsätzlich wird das unserer Gesellschaft ja dienen denn wir sind am Fortschritt interessiert und der es mit den alten ohnehin nicht zu machen.
Er formuliert als Vermutung. Wahrscheinlich haben sie einfach gedacht dass es zu früh hat für Deutschland gesagt.
Karneval zu verbieten es wäre gar nicht sinnvoll gewesen. Es gab ja noch gar keine Fälle vor denen man hätte schützen können. Und man will ja auch gar keine.
Also keine Kurve sondern nur eine flache Kurve.
Aber wir wissen aus England das ist ja auch dokumentiert dass sie dort anders darüber nachdachten.
Für die war das wirklich ein praktikables Modell zu sagen Wir machen jetzt mal hier Immunität Es werden ja nur die rausgenommen die wir nicht brauchen.
Und in Asien hat der Ex-Kollege dokumentiert in Asien wurde auch so drüber nachgedacht.
Ich kann ganz offen sagen Es gab jetzt in den Fachkreisen in Deutschland kenne ich die Diskussion nicht aber in Asien in Hongkong wurde das intensiv diskutiert da haben wir Experten die auch mit SARS eins zu tun hatten.
Und da gab es einige die gesagt haben Wir lassen es jetzt darauf ankommen weil ja die Kollateralschäden durch die durch die Maßnahmen durch die Anti epidemischen Maßnahmen die sind ja zumindest wirtschaftlich viel viel gravierender als die Schäden durch die Krankheit selbst.
Was man in Asien diskutiert wird natürlich auch in Deutschland so diskutiert aber man hat sich anders entschieden.
Ich würde sagen wir bleiben mal dabei dass man hier in Deutschland sich bewusst dafür entschieden hat das so zu machen und diese Ausweglosigkeit auch so ein bisschen vorgespielt ist denn da gab es einen sehr guten Text auch bei Verfassungs Blog,
nur weil die nur weil die das Virus so erbarmungslos mit seiner naturalistischen Logik über uns herfällt heißt das noch nicht dass unsere Antwort genauso alternativlos ist sondern hier finden Abwägungen und Entscheidungen statt.
Und so langsam kommen ja auch die Texte bei Spiegel Online die mal so dokumentieren was man noch so überlegt hatte und wieso Kursverläufe sind und so weiter.
Es gab immer Entscheidungsspielräume das darf man nicht übersehen was auch bedeutet bei sehr vielen Sachen über die wir vorhin sprachen gibt es auch Entscheidungsspielräume.
Wie geht man jetzt mit systemrelevanten berufen um und so weiter lässt man mehr Organisations geradezu. Und wie schützt man die.
Ohnehin ein positiver Effekt. Doch dieser Coruna Krise dass man,
wieder einmal begreift dass Politik eben auch Entscheidungen bedeutet und dass es Optionen der Entscheidung gibt dass dieses Mantra der Alternativlosigkeit noch ganz ganz dominant dominant war bei der,
Wirtschaftskrise bei der Finanzkrise 2007/2008 dass man das jetzt nicht mehr hat sondern dass man jetzt sagt Okay,
das ist jetzt gerade eine gangbare eine sinnvolle Lösung für ein konkretes Problem und deswegen haben wir uns für dies entschieden und machen das andere nicht.
Aber das ist schon zur Debatte steht das jetzt gerade über etwas diskutiert wird und auch diese gegenseitigen Ermahnungen Es ist noch zu früh für das oder zu früh für dieses.
Das zeigt aber dennoch dass man sagt Politik bedeutet also einen Spielraum von Entscheidungen zu haben und man kann sich dann für das beste oder sinnvollste entscheiden und kann das dann auch machen.
Während wir eigentlich den Merkel Jahren sonst ja immer.
Entscheidungen gar nicht mehr präsentiert bekommen haben als wirkliche politische Entscheidungen,
sondern es kam dann immer so wie ein Regenschauer oder wie ein Sturm über uns und dann musste man damit leben und das ist jetzt hier aber nicht da das zeigt eigentlich einmal wieder dass eine Demokratie,
durch eine solche Krise vielleicht noch einmal neu aktiviert werden könnte.
Das ist eine vage Hoffnung die ich habe.
Zumindest ist jetzt gerade dieser Diskurs und zeigen aber auch die Aufrufe Zahlen dieser Podcast dass Leute wieder bereit sind verschiedene Szenarien einmal durchzuspielen denn das bedeutet ja auch immer demokratische Entscheidungen.
Dass man zunächst verschiedene Szenarien durchspielt Das war eine Zeitlang ja überhaupt nicht mehr da da hat man sagt Schwarze Null.
Wir können nichts machen und wir müssen sparen. Und damit war alles vom Tisch.
Und so waren ja dann auch viele politische Kommentare und man merkt man ja doch bei einigen Journalisten die man schon so ein paar Jahre quasi als Leser betreut.
Dass da auch hin und wieder der ein oder andere Satz steht wo man dachte Ach ja da muss auch ein Denkprozess eingesetzt haben soll in den letzten Wochen.
Und wir hoffen einfach dass du damit Recht hast. Es ist nicht zu optimistisch sondern dass es tatsächlich so ist,
denn es hat natürlich auch gewissen funktionalen Sinn für eine Regierung jetzt so zu tun als hätte man es einfach nur mit so einer Eskalation zu tun.
Schulschließungen Ausgangs Beschränkung Ausgangssperre und jeder bleibt in seinem Bett liegen bis es vorbei.
So wie in der ARD der Presseclub am 22. März jetzt eröffnet wurde.
Bei Jörg Schönenborn Das zeigt schon ein bisschen.
Diese vielen Zuschauer Anfragen geben auch Auskunft darüber was jeden Tag gerade besonders bewegt. Da steuert alles in den letzten Tagen auf eine zentrale Frage hin.
Ist es richtig was wir gerade tun an gesellschaftlichen Beschränkungen. Ist es ausreichend oder muss noch viel mehr passieren.
Alle Leute die sich besorgt bei der ARD melden und eine Frage haben.
Die Frage wurde nur kriege ich meine Ausgangssperre. Ich habe Angst vor Crooner und genau dagegen muss jetzt dagegengehalten werden haben wir es nicht mit Alternativlosigkeit zu tun.
Da hat ja Sascha Lobo diesen Punkt der Vernunft Panik gemacht der in der Hinsicht auch stimmt.
Man sollte jetzt nicht einfach nur nach der nächsten Ausgangssperre und so weiter suchen sondern es gibt noch andere Möglichkeiten,
Kekulé hat jetzt am 18. März schon mal einen Punkt gemacht der uns dann auch bis zur Impfstoff Verfügbarkeit beschäftigen wird wir haben drüber gesprochen.
Wir werden ja demnächst Antikörper Tests haben. Das heißt bei einem Wahlkampf bei einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung zum Thema Friedrich Merz wird es heißen,
er ist ja ungefährdet da ist ja schon hinter sich selbst wenn er sich wieder ansteckt oder keine Symptome haben ist sondern für Euch alle Infektionen.
Aber wie geht man eigentlich mit einer Gesellschaft um bei der sich nachher herausstellt haben nicht nur nicht Risikogruppen also alle Menschen unter 30 würde ich mal sagen die das wirklich so als Grippe wegstecken können die jetzt keine große Todesgefahr dadurch erleben müssen.
Wir haben aber auch geheilte und die werden unterschieden von immer mehr in die Enge gedrängten gefährdeten und Kekulé kotzen auf Schlagmann.
Man muss nur andererseits überlegen Was will man mit so einem Test. Der ist in der jetzigen Lage müsste man ja dann Wir reden jetzt mal nur von Deutschland wir haben uns ja auch nach außen so halbwegs abgeriegelt.
Jetzt müsste man dann bei 82 Millionen Menschen irgendwie testen wer ist positiv Wer ist negativ. Die positiven würden dann vielleicht einen grünen Zettel auf die Stirn bekommen und dürfen dann wieder raus.
Das funktioniert irgendwie alles nicht.
Bei dem grünen Zettel muss der Journalist so leise ins Kamera lachen schnaufen.
Aber es ist ehrlich gesagt eine ernst zu nehmende Frage.
Generell jetzt schon mit der Test Geschichte so dass man getestet wird man muss dann warten bis man das Ergebnis hat.
Wenn man das Ergebnis hat dann informiert man wieder mit wem man alles Kontakt hat.
Dann wird diese Kette wieder nachvollzogen die Infektionsquelle und wird dann wird es mit den anderen durchexerziert.
Das ist ja etwas was noch leistbar ist wenn man ganz wenig erkrankte hat.
Und das ist auch dann noch auf sagen wir Heinsberg oder so. bezogen dann ist das noch leistbar und so kann man tatsächlich fragen Was ist denn das am Ende dann noch für eine Information die ich da erfahre.
Wenn ich dann weiß Okay die sind jetzt gerade nicht aber die anderen wo bleiben die dann Und was ist mit mir und gerade wenn du sagst,
man kann geheilt sein aber ist wieder Träger der Infektion dadurch dass man eine zweite Infizierung hat die einem dann persönlich nichts mehr ausmacht dann ist das glaube ich auch das Testen etwas was,
irgendwie ein gutes Gefühl vermitteln soll aber sinnvoll erscheint es mir nicht.
Ja es ist tatsächlich sehr zweischneidig also das was die Epidemiologen am liebsten machen würden ist ja wirklich eine Querschnitts Testung dass man nicht mehr gezielt die Ketten nachvollzieht.
Da werden jetzt die Ressourcen dafür gebraucht sondern dass man irgendwann wirklich einfach querbeet testet.
In Deutschland hat Drosten gestern auf Twitter dass das Durchschnittsalter der positive Fälle des Median Alters 48 des Median Alter der deutschen Bevölkerung,
46 47 Wir sind vielleicht sogar super nah dran an der Stichprobe wenn es die Kapazitäten von 550 000 pro Woche auf,
zwei Millionen ausgeweitet werden dann kann es ja wirklich punktuell in Hausärzten einfach sagen Wir machen nebenbei noch so ein Test.
Und wenn sich dann herausstellt dass durch die hohe infektiöser vielleicht doch schon mehr Menschen durch sind wir einfach so das Label kriegen hat den grünen Zettel mit der Ansage Ja Sie können den Chef Bescheid sagen sie hatten es.
Wir wissen aus China 14 Prozent haben tatsächlich eine zweite positive Testung nachdem die Krankheit schon einmal durchgemacht wurde.
Alle Symptome frei aber trotzdem alle infektiös.
Also das dramatisiert eigentlich das Problem für die Risikogruppen bis zum Impfstoff.
Dann muss wirklich irgendwie Städte machen wo du kannst und dann einen Zaun drum und dann darf er auch keine Lieferung stattfinden und so weiter.
Also dieses Szenario das kann man sich noch gar nicht richtig vorstellen was das bedeutet weil so viel auf Solidarität hoffen von Menschen die schon natürliche Immunität haben würde ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht weil da ist dann der Druck zu hoch wenn es wirklich heißt Sie könnten jetzt komplett weitermachen.
Das betrifft ja dann am Ende auch ganze Belegschaften irgendwie so eine Siemens Filiale.
Und dann stellt sich heraus Auch der eine hatte es ja ich hatte mich auch krank gefühlt aber ich habe es gar nicht gemerkt und plötzlich hätte man dann so eine Testung raus dass dies alles schon durchgemacht haben.
Wieso sollte man das noch runtergefallen lassen.
Da schlummern doch noch die ein oder anderen großen Probleme weil die Gefahr für die Risikogruppen sinkt dadurch eben nicht dass sehr viele dann plötzlich aufatmen und mit einer anderen Einstellung zurück in die Gesellschaft wollen.
Naja das war jedenfalls kleiner Abriss zum Thema Herden Immunität.
Ich gehe auch davon aus dass wir in Deutschland jetzt so flach zu sein dass man in Jahrzehnten rechnen müsste wenn die Infektion so vor sich geht.
Mal gucken wie es mit der Sache weitergeht.
Eine Sache die allerdings jetzt im März wirklich dramatisch ist.
Vorhin schon kurz angesprochen die Gesichtsmasken. Der Schutz dieser ganz konkrete.
Ich vermute ja wir haben einfach die Situation Es gibt zu wenig deswegen traut sich keiner an verantwortlicher Stelle zu sagen der Mundschutz eigentlich das Beste was es gibt aber wenn wir jetzt das Sagen haben wir Krankenhäusern keine mehr.
Das hab ich auch jetzt schon erfahren aus Kreisen die sich jetzt gerade auch beschäftigen mit dieser Kampagne Maske auf.
Es geht ja darum dass man sich selbst Masken basteln kann die selbstverständlich nicht so gut sind wie eine Krankenhauskeime aber immerhin Sie halten etwas ab.
Also die Baumwoll Masken Man kann jetzt selbst tätig werden aus der alten Unterhose was auch immer sich eine Maske basteln.
Und das ist ein Trend aber man hat jetzt sogar in manchen Zeitungen schon so große Betriebsanleitung gemacht wie man eigentlich sich so Bastel Anleitungen wie man das jetzt selbst.
Man hat ja immerhin Zeit sich jetzt machen kann.
Ich glaube dass man damit symbolisch auf jeden Fall schon sehr viel tut.
Irgendetwas strahlt man damit direkt aus das ist nochmal die Gefahr.
Da gehe ich jetzt auch nicht so dicht dran und ich weiß ja nicht ist er infiziert und bleibt ich deshalb auf Abstand oder werde ich nur ermahnt Oh ich habe keine Maske deswegen bleibe ich auf Abstand.
Dieser Effekt setzt selbstverständlich ein auch so wird sie ein bisschen was bringen und so wird man warten bis man dann irgendwann die richtigen Masken hat.
Mich wundert auch dass es offenbar in Deutschland so ist dass die ja kaum noch Unternehmen hier gross produzieren sondern alle mit ganz ganz vielen Lieferketten verquickt sind sodass das gar nicht möglich ist dass man das so schnell machen kann.
Mich hat es nicht gewundert dass Trigema jetzt als erstes damit kommt denn die produzieren ja nun mal alle hier. Die haben ja auch alles da.
Da hat der Wolfgang Grupp dafür gesorgt dass das immer hier bleibt und dass das nicht alles outgesourct wird.
Deswegen kann er jetzt relativ schnell reagieren auf das Ganze.
Und sonst scheint das sehr sehr schwierig zu sein.
Ich frage mich ob das generell einen Effekt haben wird dass wir.
Verona sagen wir mal in einem Jahr so überwunden ist kein Thema mehr ist dann wirklich eine Akzeptanz für die Maske im öffentlichen Raum haben dass wir sagen Okay,
da bleiben wir jetzt zumindest in der Großstadt dabei man sieht es ja in Berlin oder auch in Frankfurt in der U-Bahn hin und wieder mal dass da Menschen mit Maske fahren.
Aber dass das dann viel stärker nochmal wird oder dass man auch sagte Es ist jetzt selbstverständlich wenn ich zu einer Großveranstaltung gehe dass ich da versuche Maske zu tragen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher denn zugleich muss man sagen Es ist relativ unangenehm eine Maske auf Dauer zu tragen. Es ist nicht schön in einem Papier zu atmen.
Ja das stimmt. Ich bin die Frage die mich am meisten beschäftigt da ist eigentlich in Asien haben wir die medizinische Maske im Straßenbild und in Deutschland sehen wir jetzt schon an diesen selbst Schneider Bewegung und so weiter.
Das hat schon Stil Farbe vor allem aber es hat auch gewisse Formen.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen dass es in Deutschland gängig wird dass man einfach so ein Tuch um den Hals trägt und dem Moment wo man in den Supermarkt einbiegt zieht man sich das Kreuz hoch auf die Nase sodass man für diese zehn Minuten die man dort zugange ist einfach sagt,
Ich atme hier nicht anderthalb Meter,
vor mich die ganze Zeit.
Und wenn ich mit jemandem spreche dann Tropfen Feuchtigkeit und Fett Tröpfchen bleiben dann einfach hängen.
Und wenn man den Laden verlässt macht man es auch wieder runter.
Gut das ist jetzt der Supermarkt Beispiel. Aber was ist im Kino. Was ist wenn ich da an der Schlange stehe sodass sich das durchsetzen wird dass wir jetzt immer dann mal schnell eine Maske hochziehen.
Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen denn es ist ja auch das Gesichtsfeld etwas was wir gerne beim Menschen sehen.
Wir flirten über das Gesicht das es für uns ganz entscheidend.
Wir sehen die meiste Zeit von den Menschen auch nur das Gesicht oder ihre Hände nackt.
Deswegen ist das für uns auch was ganz Wichtiges um überhaupt mit Menschen in Kontakt zu kommen.
Und ich stelle mir das jetzt auf Dauer nicht sehr schön vor einfach wenn wir uns auf diese Weise begegnen.
In China und in Asien allgemein Südkorea und Japan.
Da trägt man ja die Maske jetzt gerade intensiv aber hatte nach Sars eine Praxis. Wenn ich krank bin ziehe ich sie auf.
Und die Gegenfrage an dich wer würdest du es akzeptieren dass du im Supermarkt stehst und hinter dir ist die ganze Zeit.
Einer der schon dreimal geniest hat und die ganze Zeit am Husten ist aber keine Maske trägt obwohl doch alle wissen dass man einfach nur eine Maske aufsetzen müsste und dann hätte man schon für viele sehr viel.
Für viele im nahen Umfeld sehr viel Beruhigung geschaffen.
Die Frage ist ein bisschen Wer muss sich rechtfertigen. Wer steht unter Rechtfertigungsdruck.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es sehr viele Leute gibt die demnächst einfach mutig sich umdrehen und sagen,
Gehen Sie zumindest ein Meter zurück wenn sie so erkältet sind weil man jetzt ja geschult ist und weiß Erkältungen sind auch nur Tröpfchen übertragung und so..
Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass es da ein paar soziale Lernerfahrungen gibt die einfach recht Fertigungs Pflichten umdrehen dass man einfach die Erwartung hat Du musst dich jetzt dafür rechtfertigen wie du dich verhält.
Und dem könnte man entgehen wenn man einfach eine Maske trägt weil da wird man nicht angesprochen. Aber wenn man keine trägt dass man dann schon mal angesprochen wird.
Aber das sind wie gesagt Was haben wir schon gedacht dass die Leute demnächst alle irgendwelche Smart Brillen aufsetzen und so weiter.
Dazu ist es auch nie gekommen weil die Akzeptanz dann doch nie da war. Also.
Ich glaube dass es auch vielen Leuten auf Dauer lästig sind. Viele Leute erkennen ja jetzt auch gerade erst den Sinn des Händewaschen und machen es dann mal eben die 20 30 Sekunden wie man es soll und richtig mit Seife und all das.
Aber sonst merke ich ja dass das gar nicht so da ist.
Es ist ja durchaus auf der Herrentoilette noch bei vielen so vertreten dass er einfach so raus spazieren ohne sich die Hände zu waschen.
Man sieht auch im Zug nicht viel Leute mit Desinfektion. Also ich bin jemand der grundsätzlich auch mit so Sachen ausgestattet ist.
Wenn ich auf Reisen bin und das ist bei mir auch sicherlich nochmal verstärkt dadurch dass ich öffentliche Verkehrsmittel ja eigentlich nicht so gerne nutze und am liebsten mit meinem Auto fahre.
Da bin ich ja jetzt gerade in Coruna Zeiten sehr sehr sicher drin.
Und das ist dadurch bei mir schon.
Eher so dass ich sensibilisiert bin für die Bakterien die Viren die vorhanden sind wenn ich,
in einem öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel mit fahre sodass ich dann ein größeres Bedürfnis habe mir danach die Hände zu waschen oder nicht anfange in einem Zug zu sitzen den ganzen Tag schon die Sachen angefasst habe und dann auch noch Nüsschen oder so.
Andererseits frage ich mich wenn ich in der Cocktailbar wieder sitzen werde eines Tages,
dann kann ich nichts aus der Flasche trinken denn Cocktails werden im Glas serviert und da sind auch die Hände des Barkeeper mit im Spiel um die Zitrone auszubremsen oder irgendetwas und da stehen auch nach wie vor noch die Nüsschen auf dem Tisch.
Vielleicht werde ich zu den Nüsschen greifen. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Ja dieser Kellner in Ischgl hat tatsächlich wahrscheinlich jeden Einzelnen den er bedient hat infiziert.
Es gibt da keine Risikoabwägung mehr. Bei einer überreichung eines Glases sondern jeder Einzelne in dem Moment betroffen deren Sicht.
Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen dass sich da einiges ändert und ich habe sowieso nie gern die Hand gegeben.
Ich vermeide das Ja ich mache vorher festbeißen oder sonst irgendwie Ich finde dieses Ellenbogen Ding finde ich super.
Das ist genau auf meiner Linie weil es auch lustig ist das kann man mit einem ironischen Yogi machen es signalisiert dann auch Ja wir meinen es hier auch lustig aber es auch ein bisschen ernst oder,
finde ich das schön finde ich das mit dem Fuß ist natürlich albern und mit den Gläsern in der Gastronomie.
Ich bin mal gespannt Drosten war da für mich ziemlich deutlich.
Ehrlich gesagt mit seinem Ich hab noch nie. Also ich nehme mir nur eine Flasche.
Es gibt immer so Halbsätze in diesem Podcast die wirklich nachwirken und es ist glaube ich einer davon.
Davon berichten. Denn wir haben auch vor in Frankfurt wenn wir uns einmal wieder begegnen können dorthin ein Restaurant zu gehen Du hast davon erzählt indem man noch gutbürgerlich essen kann ich hoffe es überlebt die Krise.
Das wird überleben.
Und dann werden wir hier in dem Podcast selbstverständlich berichten ob wir aus Flaschen aus Gläsern getrunken haben und was auch immer oder ob wir Plastik Besteck und selbst mitgebracht haben. Wir werden all das thematisieren.
Mal gucken wann es soweit ist.
Ganz genau. Man kann allerdings auch die Getränke die ich konsumiere aus dem Glas bestellen aber trotzdem das Essen wird gekochte Teller und so weiter alles ist einfach mal gespannt wie das so im Juni Juli August.
Ich kann mir noch nicht ganz vorstellen dass im August und Juli August die Urlaubssaison tatsächlich so ausfällt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt ob sie es bis dahin so ist.
Aber man sieht gerade bei uns jetzt hier eine Ratlosigkeit aber die sehen wir auch bei eigentlich fast allen Intellektuellen.
Es ist ja erstaunlich dass man sobald irgendetwas irgendein Ereignis möchte man das Intellektuelle kommen und einem die Welt erklären.
Und das hat ja jetzt auch wieder stattgefunden in der Krise. Und ich kann sagen es ist jetzt noch nicht so dass man sagen kann Aha hier haben wir jetzt die Antwort.
Wie gut dass wir die fünf Intellektuelle haben die sich jetzt dazu äußern und jetzt wissen was sondern man sieht eigentlich eher dass da gar nicht so viel passiert ist bei den Intellektuellen.
Na so was.
Wollen wir die Intellektuellen jetzt noch schnell den Mundschutz abhandeln.
Mundschutz.
Weil das will ich nur kurz dokumentieren weil ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Wir werden über den Mundschutz ganz anders reden wenn er erst einmal verfügbar ist und er wird es auch gesetzliche Vorschriften geben und so weiter und so fort.
Und da der Drosten das immer noch runter gespielt hat immer mit dem nicht ausgesprochenen Halbsatz Leute lasst es erst mal für das Klinikpersonal Das ist eine wirklich sinnvolle beim Kekulé.
Auch Virologen Klang ist immer schon ein bisschen anders.
Diese Erkrankung wird wirklich in den allermeisten Fällen auf dem direkten Weg face to face von Gesicht zu Gesicht übertragen.
In einigen Fällen vielleicht noch indem man am Hinterkopf an gehustet wird und dann mit den Haaren in die mit den Händen in die Haare fasst und sich später am Auge kratzt.
Aber so so über drei Banden gespielt ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sich zu infizieren dann deutlich geringer und wir müssen ja hier jetzt zumindest aus epidemiologischen Sicht wenn wir auf die gesamte Bevölkerung schauen müssen wir die hauptsächlichen Infektionsquelle abstellen.
Und dazu gehört eben dass der direkte Kontakt über die Tröpfcheninfektion und diese Schmier Infektion ist sozusagen ein kleineres Problem im Vergleich dazu.
Eine Desinfektionsmitteln um die Türklingel zu machen Okay okay okay aber es ist vor allem diese Tröpfcheninfektion die man auch nicht durch Abwaschen oder so einfach bändigen kann und Christian Flood seines Zeichens aus der Medizin,
den ich sehr schätze weil er mich immer gerne auch ins Medien Quartett einlädt das er moderiert beim Deutschlandfunk hat zugeschaltet im Deutschlandfunk Politik Podcast es noch nochmal so richtig schön auf den Punkt gebracht.
Das eigentliche Problem ist dieser Mangel in den medizinischen Berufen.
Dieser eklatante Mangel an Basismaterial also ein Desinfektionsmitteln an Mundschutz an Schutzkleidung und dergleichen. Das ist ja spektakulär.
Auch im ambulanten Bereich fast mit leeren Händen dastehen Es wird also Mangel verwaltet oder verteilt.
Das ist die Frage wie weit das in den Bereich von Daseinsvorsorge,
geschlafen hat das man dort nicht gesehen hat dass hier ein Mangel entstehen könnte.
Bei Tamiflu Anti Influenza Medikament hat man ja entsprechende Vorräte seinerzeit angeschafft.
Aber die Frage ist wie der Staat hier sicherstellen kann in Zukunft dass solche Basics in Anführungszeichen,
vorhanden sind und da nicht Abhängigkeiten entstehen die dann irgendwo auf einem geregelten oder ungeregelten Markt oder sonst irgendwo her beschafft oder eben nicht mehr zu beschaffen ist dort getätigt werden.
Das ist ein riesengroßes Thema da hat der Staat sich aus der Daseinsvorsorge muss man feststellen eigentlich zurückgezogen bzw. überhaupt nicht engagiert.
Daseinsvorsorge und Dezentralität werden Zauberworte der nächsten Jahre.
Eindeutiger kann man es nicht formulieren.
Es ist spektakulär dass das so fehlt vor allem wenn man sich überlegt wie man mit der Straßenbahn am Klinikum Frankfurt vorbeifährt da sieht man die Dieselgeneratoren und die riesigen Tanks tagelang für Strom zu sorgen falls diese Art Versorgung abfällt.
Aber Papiermaschinen kein Lager nirgends muss alles über Post geliefert werden. Man kann es sich klar Wir wollen jetzt nicht so tun als ob wir es besser gewusst aber das ist einfach wirklich das muss man jetzt auch mal so sagen es ist einfach unglaublich dass es da so.
Auch nicht besser wissen aber es gibt ja Ministerien die arbeiten es gibt eben Thinktanks die der Regierung zuarbeiten Wir geben ja auch wahrlich viel Geld für Berater externe aus wie wir ja alle wissen und es ist ja die Aufgabe von Politik auch vorausschauend zu handeln.
Und die müssen ein bisschen weitsichtiger sein als wir die bei Spiegel Online rum klicken oder so sondern die müssen auch solche Dinge antizipieren können.
Und ich sage mal so Es geht ja jetzt hier tatsächlich nicht um ganz ganz große Anschaffungen.
Wir haben es nicht mit etwas zu tun man sagt Das kann eine Volkswirtschaft auf Dauer nie tragen. Man kann nicht sagen Wir müssen jetzt.
Wir müssen jetzt für jeden Fluss. Müssen wir große Dämme und Deiche bauen können das kann nicht sein das muss man dann irgendwie auch sagen Na ja alle zehn Jahre gibt's auch mal ein Jahrhunderthochwasser und dann ist auch schon mal das eine oder andere überflutet.
Im Keller ist dann schon mal unter Wasser.
Aber wir haben es hier mit etwas sehr sehr kleinem zu tun nämlich Papier Masken und das wäre ja ganz wunderbar wenn ich auch nur daran denke Stephan welche Auflagen wir ja inzwischen haben.
Mit so etwas wie Feuermelder in den eigenen Wohnungen.
Arbeitsschutz allgemeine.
Es gibt ja Arbeitsschutzes Es gibt ja ganz viele Auflagen die sagen das und das muss vorhanden sein.
Also wäre das ja ein Leichtes das noch damit zu ergänzen. Aber es ist bislang nicht geschehen Ich denke das wird auf jeden Fall kommen.
Ja es gibt so viele Paradoxien jetzt gehen alle in ihr Homeoffice und jetzt sagen die Versicherer.
Das können Sie als Homeoffice nicht benutzen weil wenn sie daran arbeiten ist ihr Arbeitgeber für sie versicherungspflichtig und ihr erhoben auf es ist zu gefährlich.
Mit sowas hat man es plötzlich zu tun. Vielleicht ist es auch ein ganz simples Paradox vielleicht hat man wirklich gedacht Herr Papiermaschinen Ich meine das ist Papier.
Wir kümmern uns um Stromversorgung Wir machen große Personal Pläne für Katastrophenfälle aber mein Papier daran wird es ja nun nicht scheitern.
Plötzlich ist Klopapier und diese mutmassen sind knapp.
Ich kriege das ja bei meiner Frau so ein bisschen mit ihr arbeitete hier im Klinikum und die haben einmal im Jahr so eine Schulung. Da wird dann diskutiert verschiedene Stufen an Katastrophenfällen und wer dann was machen muss.
Es beginnt irgendwie bei einem großen Autobahn Unfall mit 30 Verletzten oder so.
Dann gibt's einen Anschlag auf irgendwas. Dann gibt's irgendwie eine eingestürzte Festhalle oder so. mit 100 Toten und 10 000 Verletzten. Und wer all das hat man Pläne. Da weiß jeder in der Klinik. Jetzt greift ja irgendwie Plan so und so.
Ich bin eigentlich dafür zuständig aber morgen bin ich dann da. Das ist alles geregelt.
Aber dieses Papier Lager mit Kautschuk und Papier hat das so ein Gebäude hinstellt zum Container einfach mal vorrätig hat man irgendwie nicht.
Vielleicht ist es einfach zu einfach gewesen als Aufgabenstellung.
Ich muss gerade dran denken an diese Geschichte Der entwendete Brief von Edgar Allen Poe.
Ich weiß nicht ob du die kennst ist eine Kurzgeschichte findet man auch gratis im Internet Wer sie jetzt lesen möchte.
Und da wird ein Brief gesucht der die Königin kompromittieren sollte und der Detektiv hört sich an dass man dieses ganze,
dieses Büro von den Menschen da der diesen Brief entwendet haben soll man habe das links gedreht man hat da sogar noch die Teppiche aufgeschlitzt und hatte alles gesucht nach dem Brief.
Und er hört sich das an und dann schreitet der Detektiv zur Tat.
Er geht ins Zimmer hat sich angehört sie haben alles durchsucht da kann er nicht sein.
Und wo geht er hin zum Priv Stender und dort ist der Brief wo soll er sonst sein dort wo Briefe hingehören.
Und genau da hat niemand gesucht und wir haben es ein bisschen mit einem entwendeten Brief jetzt gerade zu tun.
Es ist so klar man hat wahrscheinlich auch digital tausende Szenarien bei der Charité oder sonst was wenn irgendwie was ausfällt was dann alles greift.
Aber das simpelste ist dann eben nicht präsent.
Die Maske muss erst durch das Nadelöhr Seiffen Straße von wo auch immer in China hergestellt nach Duisburg gefahren werden drei Wochen im Zug,
neben Christian Floater Uwe Jansens aus der Praxis Präsident der Deutschen Interdisziplinären Vereinigung der Intensiv und Notfallmedizin.
Nochmal zum Thema.
Wenn man mal ganz banal denkt an der Stelle ist das was uns nicht fehlt Beatmungsgerät intensiv Betten die größte und ich möchte es mal fast eine Lachnummer ist doch dass wir hier völlig unvorbereitet sie ja auch sie haben keine Masken.
Wir nähern uns Masken selber Wir fahren heute mit unserem kaufenden streckt der fährt heute nach Ulm bei irgendeinem Händler besorgt der 10000 Masken für wirklich Fantasie Preise.
Das ist unser Problem verboten.
Was meinen Sie was das für ein ethisches Problem werden wird wenn wir keine Maske und Schutzkleidung mehr haben und wir haben die covert 19 Pathfinder liegen können die nicht mehr versorgen.
Das ist die Frage. Wenn das soweit käme dann haben wir ein Problem das möchte ich mir gar nicht vorstellen wollen denn dann gibt es richtig tumultartige aufstanden.
Frau Woopen die ja im Gespräch mit Ethikrats Chefin die jetzt diese Triage überlegungen schon mal als Handreichung fertig gemacht hat sowieso mit sowas befassen sie sich gerade ja dann kommt er mit.
Hören Sie mal wir haben keine Gesichtsmasken. Was für ein Problem der Kekulé hat in seinem Podcast am 25. Sitz vor nicht allzu viel Takt. Nochmal dieses Smart Tenzing hat auch so ein Plan entwickelt.
Wir lachen immer wenn's Smart heißt aber er ist nicht ganz so schlecht.
Wir müssen uns wirklich darauf einstellen dass wir würde ich mal sagen in der Größenordnung von mindestens einem Jahr unser Verhalten ändern müssen tatsächlich,
und da ist jetzt die Frage Wie macht man das so dass es möglichst wenige soziale wirtschaftliche psychologische Kollateralschäden hat und was ich da entwickelt habe ist etwas das nenne ich Smart Tenzing statt statt Social Distinktion.
Was wir sonst machen smart ist Tenzing das heißt wir machens eine,
Stufe sanfter und da ist das Wichtigste was meines Erachtens erforderlich ist tatsächlich dass,
die Menschen in der Regel wenn sie anderen näher als zwei Meter kommen um in der Umgebung draußen dass sie dann eine solche einfache Operas getragen sondern einfach an Mund Nase Anschutz,
schützt auf jeden Fall andere und es gibt auch neuere Daten dass die Menschen selber dadurch geschützt werden bis zum gewissen Grad gegen dieses Virus.
Also ein bisschen andere Informationen als man es so bisher gehört hat.
Und es ist so dass wir aus Hongkong wissen dass dieses reine tragen des Masken was sie da alle machen offensichtlich doch einen ganz erheblichen Effekt hat um die Krankheit unter Kontrolle zu halten.
Also Smart Tenzing als große Rettung für die ökonomische Katastrophe durch dieses Social dispensieren Smart Tenzing besteht darin dass wir uns Gesichtsmasken aufsetzen. Aber wir haben sie nicht wirklich unglaublich.
Wir müssen sagen Es ist ja so dass es weitergehen muss ökonomisch.
Also ich verstehe jene Kapitalismuskritiker nicht die jetzt sagen Das ist ein prima Anlass.
Jetzt tut sich da wirklich was. Jetzt liegt ja mal alles lahm.
Ja wenn das jetzt für die großen Konzerne einfach gelten würde und man würde sagen Ja denen gehts jetzt mal ans Leder aber wir kleinen Wir zeigen jetzt was wir können.
Aber gerade die Kleinen die leiden ja jetzt am meisten darunter dass sie nicht öffnen können.
Es sind die Leute die ihren Traum nach zehn 15 Jahren verwirklicht haben indem sie ein Restaurant oder eine Boutique oder irgendwas eröffnet haben die jetzt vor einem Scherbenhaufen stehen und nicht mehr weitermachen können.
Während die Großen sich mit entsprechenden Krediten und staatlichen Hilfen viel leichter helfen können und da ganz andere Macht auch im Hintergrund haben um dann rechtzeitig wieder an den entsprechenden Stellen produzieren zu können.
Das heißt Die die jetzt glauben Na ja das tut jetzt eigentlich auch mal dem Westen zum Beispiel ganz gut da ist jetzt mal alles brachliegt.
Die glauben ja auch einfach dass sich ein System dadurch verflüchtigt dass sein Virus auftritt als sei damit dann auch das System schon direkt ein anderes. Wieso sollte das sein.
Das muss man ja. Die Politik ist ja dann immer noch die die da ist das Personal ändert sich ja nicht es ist ja nicht plötzlich der sozialismus da.
Nur weil jetzt auch mal ein Altmeier Saatgut vorübergehend können wir das eine oder andere verstaatlichen das eine oder andere Unternehmen um es zu retten das ist ja überhaupt keine sozialistische Forderung im übrigen das ist ganz ganz klassisch so vorgesehen.
Das findet man auch bei neoliberalen Theoretikern solche Modelle wie der Staat durchaus seine Nachtwächter Position in der Krise z.B. bei Kriegen verlassen kann um dann etwas zu retten das hat ja in Deutschland stattgefunden.
Dort hat man ja auch die Industrie wieder so auf Vordermann nach 45 gebracht und die die jetzt glauben das sei jetzt mal irgendwie so ganz gut.
Die sind in meinen Augen da auch bisweilen in einem sehr merkwürdigen Esoterik waren das ja jetzt steht das mal so still und jetzt wird ein anderes Wirtschaften beginnen. Nichts deutet daraufhin.
Die Lufthansa operiert jetzt bei fünf Prozent. Es ist beeindruckend 17 Flugzeuge auf der Landebahn Nordwest zu sehen.
Es ist einfach da macht der Globalisierung wirklich Pause.
Nur Man darf halt nicht übersehen so ein geschlossenes Restaurant hat wahrscheinlich in den letzten zehn Jahren irgendwann die Anfangsinvestitionen von 300000 Euro verursacht die jemand privat geschultert hat oder wenn jetzt irgendwelche Kunstmessen abgesagt werden.
Dani hat im Audio viel Podcast mal kurz über seine Lage gesprochen als Künstler in Köln.
Da geht man halt mit 7000 Euro und so eine Vorleistung weil da der Kundenkontakt zum Erstkäufer stattfindet die hat man gezahlt dann findet die Messe nicht statt und da muss man sich erst mal da man kann nicht nur in dem Moment als man nicht mal den Kopf frei für Kunst.
Man kann auch nicht Kunst machen sondern diese auch noch auf der Suche nach seinem Geld.
Man rutscht gleich ins Negative der Operette man nicht mit fünf Prozent seiner bisherigen Leistung sondern minus 50 Prozent da ist man sozusagen gleich und das betrifft eben alle lokalen.
Wir haben jetzt einen kleinen Supermarkt und typisch türkischen Opel-Händler.
Das geht halt noch eine Pizzeria da drüber gegenüber.
Also liefern sich jetzt essen da geht man doch lieber irgendwie selbst auch um Geld zu sparen. Friseurs zu alles weitere.
Diese lokalen Einkaufsstraßen sind komplett zu nicht funktioniert ja das ist alles einfach auf Null heruntergefahren.
Da darf man echt keine kapitalismuskritische Freude entwickeln dass so jetzt nicht funktioniert weil die die das betrifft das waren keine Hardcore Kapitalisten sondern das waren auch Menschen die hart arbeiten gehen sozusagen auf eine etwas freiere,
Selbstverantwortung US-Basis und die es einfach hart also wirklich hart getroffen.
Nicht so dass das Kapitalismus-Kritik bedeuten müsste dass wir da wieder zu einer Bedarfes Wirtschaft zurückkommen.
Wer möchte das denn. Wer möchte dann jetzt einfach zu sagen Gut dann machen wir jetzt nur noch das Nötigste was wir brauchen und Stefan braucht Mehl und Toilettenpapier und noch so zwei drei Dinge und dann ist gut also wenn das das,
Gegenmodell ist dann bitte wieder schnell zurück zu dem alten Nein.
Eine antikapitalistische sinnvolle Haltung wäre natürlich eine die nicht auf diese Weise Fortschritts feindlich ist und dass das jetzt überhaupt noch alles ganz gut funktioniert deswegen haben wir am Anfang gedankt.
Liegt ja am Internet dass wir überhaupt noch eine gewisse Infrastruktur haben und deswegen schlägt jetzt auch die Zeit nicht nur der Streaming-Anbieter sondern generell,
der Plattformen die für so etwas wie eine planwirtschaftliche Versorgung sorgen nämlich Amazon die sagen wir senden jetzt erst einmal keine Bücher mehr aus oder nur noch sehr verzögert Wir bestellen zumindest bei den Verlagen nichts mehr nach.
Auch Filme jetzt nicht wenn dann sollen die Leute streamen.
Wir kümmern uns jetzt um die Lebensmittel. Auch das kann man sagen ist ein Versagen der verschiedenen Landesregierungen vielleicht auch dass man nicht entsprechende Plattformen erstellt hat.
Dass das anders möglich ist. Jetzt sind die Supermärkte die auch so ein Home Service anbieten überfordert man sieht ja hier in einigen Dörfern dass es zum Beispiel solche Modelle gibt.
Die machen jetzt einen Instagram Kanal dann sollen die einzelnen Geschäftsinhaber ihre Produkte dort fotografieren hochladen mit Adresse und Telefonnummer oder E-Mail-Adresse versehen damit das dann dort bestellt werden kann.
Die versuchen jetzt schnell quasi eine Online-Plattform herzustellen aber das ist jetzt ja auch wirklich alles aus Verlegenheit.
Aus Verlegenheit.
Jeff Bezos hat es richtig gemacht. Er kann jetzt erstens liefern. Er hat den Zugang zur Haustür Er kann rationieren.
Bei ihnen kann man einfach Klopapier bestellen da kriegt man eine Packung und da kann man noch so wütend sein Man kriegt nur die Packung.
Da wird doch sehr viel übernommen. Zum Abschluss zum Material Unterversorgung ist Versagen ein Clip von Drosten zur Sache weil es mich ein bisschen ärgert dass er da,
nicht alles dazu sagt was dazu zu sagen ist denn wir wissen dass diese Dinge einfach besser helfen als erst zugestehen möchte.
Im März jedenfalls klang es bei Ihnen noch so.
Das adressiert vielleicht eher die jüngeren Hörer oder jüngeren Leute die vielleicht nicht so im Moment drüber nachdenken.
Die werden vielleicht dadurch dass alle oder viele in der öffentlichkeit so eine Maske tragen daran erinnert dass es jetzt mal ernst ist.
Und das finde ich auch wichtig als psychologischen Effekt.
Zumindest der psychologischen Effekt hat der Sache noch zugestanden Ich glaube da steckt mehr dahinter.
Die Probleme waren übrigens original aus der App mit der die selbst den Drosten anrufen.
Weil jetzt alle gerade von Zuhause über diese App am Ende die Verbindung herstellen also hat man auch mal gesehen woran es so mangelt.
Der öffentlich rechtliche Rundfunk kann keine ordentlichen Audio Verbindung herstellen es ist wie es ist,
über Medikamenten Knappheit reden wir dann mal im April oder Mai weil das ist ja sowieso ein grundsätzliches Problem gewesen und das verschärft sich natürlich jetzt auch nochmal.
Jetzt hat man nur noch Intellektuelle vor uns. Also ich Bananen und Co und du so etwas breiteren und etwas breiteren.
Nur noch haben viele Intellektuelle sagen wir mal mit unserem Haus und Hof Intellektuellen anfangen mit unserem deutschen.
Und zwar mit Richard David Precht. Ich habe da einen Clip vorbereitet der uns ein bisschen was.
Hat er sich schon geäußert.
Zur Lage sagt Man muss der Fairness halber der Fairness halber sagen das ist vom 11. März glaub ich das Interview.
Schon aus einer anderen Welt.
Man versteht dann vielleicht ein bisschen eher die Aussagen aber auch sonst sind sie in meinen Augen. Naja hören wir mal.
Ich finde zum Beispiel sehr sehr spannend. Ich meine wir brauchen im Zuge der ökologischen Umwandlung unserer Wirtschaft unseren fundamentalen Paradigmenwechsel hin zur Nachhaltigkeit.
Sicherlich ein Staat der verbietet der einschreitet der klare Grenzen setzt.
Der kontingentiert und die Leute sind offensichtlich. Sagen jedenfalls die Liberalen und viele andere auch nicht bereit dazu.
Jetzt kommt etwas vergleichsweise harmloses etwas was so gefährlich ist wie eine Grippe mit einer Mortalitätsrate von 0,3 Prozent der Betroffenen und auf einmal ist alles anders.
Der Staat greift ein setzt unter Quarantäne Verordnungen gibt es Veranstaltung werden abgesagt Die Leute fliegen weniger plötzlich ist alles möglich obwohl es sich um eine sehr kleine Bedrohung handelt.
Aber angesichts der ganz großen Menschheit Bedrohung scheint das alles nicht möglich zu sein. Das weckt den Sinn für das Nachdenken.
Und was sagt der Umgang mit dem Virus über unsere Gesellschaft aus. Sind wir eine Gesellschaft.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall eine Erregung Gesellschaft und das Zweite was es aussagt ist dass die Leute mehr Angst um ihr Leben haben als um das überleben der Menschheit.
Und das Spannende könnte sein dass in der Generation unserer Kinder und Enkelkinder beides zusammenfällt.
Ziemliche Fehleinschätzungen was die Gefahr von Coruña anbelangt ist vielleicht nicht gerade up to date. Man sieht ja aber auch Philosophen sind nicht immer die besten Ratgeber.
Es ist ein eigenartiges,
Konstrukt das er dann aufmacht die Menschen haben mehr Angst um ihr eigenes Leben als das überleben der Menschheit.
Ich würde sagen Das ist grundsätzlich immer so dass man sich sehr.
Nee da hätte ich jetzt gerade widersprochen Ehrlich gesagt überleg mal wie viel Sachen wir machen.
Wohl wissen dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit gar nicht so hoch ist gar nicht so gering ist dass es uns entweder das Leben kostet oder sehr viele Annehmlichkeiten wie zum Beispiel funktionierende Beine und Arme,
Menschen rasen auf der Autobahn machen Abenteuerurlaub rauchen trinken leben ungesund fressen sehe ich 40 Kilo übergewicht und so weiter.
Stimmt ja.
Es geht glaube ich. Man muss sich spezifizieren auf so eine Risikobewertung bin ich bereit Einschränkungen hinzunehmen und an was gewöhne ich mich eigentlich und man glaubt immer dass man es im Griff hat.
Seko auch direkt zu spüren und ist das Risiko direkt zu spüren. Corona kann eben sein dass sich das in acht Wochen bekomme wenn ich mich jetzt entscheide jeden Tag eine Schachtel Zigaretten zu rauchen.
Dann geht das auf jeden Fall mal ein paar Jahre gut da wird man keinerlei Probleme haben.
Soziologisch ist es ganz einfach zu unterscheiden Während wir bei sehr vielen Lebenswandel Sachen die nun wirklich uns negativ betreffen von einem Risiko sprechen ist corona einfach eine Gefahr.
Corona geht nicht auf eine unserer Entscheidungen zurück,
und auch nur jede fadenscheinige Herleitung von einem Risiko-Management Na ja klar kann ich 220 auf der Autobahn fahren ich mache es ja nur wenn sie grad frei ist oder so.. Man macht dann solche sinnlosen Abwägungen.
Corona sieht man einfach nicht jemand also jemand der als nächstes an einer Tür klingelt kann sich infizieren weil er selber zweieinhalb Tage bevor Symptome zeigt wenn überhaupt infektiös ist und selbst wenn er schon geheilt ist,
kann Friedrich Merz sich wieder anstecken bleibt dann völlig Symptom frei und ist trotzdem infektiös.
Das ist einfach nur eine Gefahr. Soziologisch ist das eine Gefahr.
Es liegt jenseits unserer Entscheidungs Abwägung womit Risiko entfällt.
Während wir mit Risiko wunderbar umgehen können und sei es nur durch selbst Lüge und Autosuggestion.
Aber Gefahr ist dann doch kategorial einfach davon unterschieden.
Der Klimawandel ein Risiko für uns aber nicht.
Wir nehmen es nicht als Gefahr das ist ja das was beim Klimawandel da sind wir nicht bereit solche Schritte zu gehen aber hier gibt es so ein vergleichsweise harmloses Virus und vor Ort macht man die großen Aktionen.
Da kommt natürlich die Dimension dazu. Coruña betrifft uns bis zum Sommer 2021 soweit können wir im Kalender blättern,
während es irgendwie 2050 sollten wir mal Ziele einhalten.
Und dann kommt immer dazu Man versucht uns in der Diskussion über den Klimawandel als Gefahr darzustellen bricht über uns herein wir kennen die Konsequenzen noch nicht.
Es ist unmöglich zu sagen was passiert und so weiter und so fort.
Aber in der politischen Entscheidungsfindung ist es dann doch immer wieder so dieses Risiko weil die stellen ja immer auf deine eigene dein eigenes Verhalten ab.
Und ich würde es immer wieder so ins Risiko reingeholt und dann denkt man sich so na ja das ist dann wie beim Schnellfahren auf der Autobahn hat dieses eine Mal fliegen man auch nach Mallorca oder.
Das wird ja jetzt nicht so den Ausschlag geben und dadurch ist das immer so eingepreist.
Risiko Kalkulation umso mehr man schafft den Klimawandel als Gefahr darzustellen.
47 Grad im Sommer also das ist nun mal eine Gefahr da kannste machen was du willst vorher das ist einfach zu viel das hält man nicht aus da liegt man wirklich nur noch flach auf dem Boden.
Kann man es sich in Australien angucken alles vor dort und keiner bewegt sich mehr. Aber.
Sterberate die noch einmal bedeutend höher ist als bei Coruna.
Das kommt noch dazu. Große große Sterberaten vor allem auch die Risikogruppen sind wieder besonders betroffen.
Aber sobald man es runter bricht. Was ist jetzt zu tun ist man doch wieder im Risiko und dann denkt man wieder man kriegt ja durch Abwägung irgendwie hin oder vielleicht sogar durch Anpassung auch große Diskussionsstand.
Virus nicht. Da kann ich nicht sagen na ja jetzt einmal probiere ich es jetzt mal so glaube ich ist man momentan zumindest noch so sensibilisiert es wird sich verändern dass man sagt Okay jede Form der menschlichen Begegnung kann ansteckend sein.
Es gibt aber nicht nur Richard David Precht sondern auch deren ästhetik Professor Bazon Brock der auch mit Beuys zusammengearbeitet hat und der sieht auch eine gewisse Chance jetzt in dieser Krise in der wir uns befinden.
Wir wollen zum Beispiel wie um 1900 herum.
Dafür ist Thomas Mann der beste Zeuge mal vorschlagen sich in den aufgenötigt Ruhe Phasen durch Quarantäne auf das zu besinnen was man da machen kann wenn man,
nicht nach außen agieren kann sondern nach innen.
Und bei Thomas Mann und Co.
Ideologen von 1900 war es so dass sie eigentlich der Meinung waren ohne Krankheit das heißt ohne Isolation,
durch die eingeschränkten physischen und psychischen Operationen ist keine Kreativität möglich Kreativität hängt gerade davon ab dass man defekte dieser Art produktiv werden lässt.
Diese Art von Isolation die wir bisher nicht kannten weil wir glaubten die Freiheit ist grenzenlos nirgendwo gibt es überhaupt ein Halt wir machen was wir wollen ist wahrscheinlich doch sehr förderlich für die Konzentration auf das worauf es wirklich ankommt,
nämlich unsere Perspektiven auf die Zukunft unsere Perspektiven vom gemeinschaftlichen Leben sogar vom überleben der Menschheit insgesamt.
Ich glaube dass das auch gute Voraussetzungen hat sich in diesem Sinne bemerkbar zu machen.
Statt Panik Konzentration nach innen die dann auch zur Beruhigung führt zur Beruhigung unter der Vorgabe aus dieser Situation lässt sich für uns etwas Produktives machen.
Bazon Brock versucht jetzt hier das Ganze als eine große Möglichkeit für Muße Zeit zu sehen und das trifft sicherlich auch für seinen Standort zu.
Das trifft auf sehr viele nicht zu die auch solche Berufe nicht haben und die jetzt auch nicht unbedingt sagen Prima immer wollte es schon mal lesen.
Jetzt her mit dem Proust. Jetzt kämpfe ich mich mal durch die Seiten durch.
Das ist sicherlich eine luxuriöse Position einnimmt aber grundsätzlich ist sie ich nicht falsch was er ja kritisiert ist in diesem längeren Interview,
mit dem Deutschlandfunk Kultur ist so eine ständige Betriebsamkeit im Kulturbetrieb haben und noch eine andere.
Und dass wir tatsächlich dadurch auch die Konzentration auf große Werke vielleicht auch immer wieder immer mehr verlieren.
Und das ist denke ich das was jeder so nachvollziehen kann der sich mit der Gegenwartskunst beispielsweise beschäftigt.
Ich erinnere nochmal an den Spruch Jetzt muss jeder seine Privilegien hinterfragen.
Das gilt für ihn insbesondere Man kann sich jetzt auf die Suche nach der verlorenen Zeit begeben.
Aber ich glaube ein großer Unterschied zu dem was er anmerkte mit sich selbst und Kantine von Thomas Mann oder so dieses typische Ich schreibe meine Magisterarbeit mal fertig indem ich mich auf irgendein Berg zurückziehe und drei Wochen nur das mache.
Das setzt ganz wichtig voraus dass der Rest der Gesellschaft weitergeht wenn die gesamte Gesellschaft steht.
In dem Moment dann hast du den Kopf dafür nicht frei. Das kann mir auch kein 70-Jähriger Philosoph der die Kinder schon längst aus dem Haus hat sagen dass er jetzt mit freiem Kopf plötzlich,
an seinen Themen und nicht an dem Thema der Gesellschaft arbeiten kann.
Geht natürlich umso strenger dann wieder falls er sich wirklich hinsetzt und jetzt das Corona Werk schreibt.
Es gibt ja ganz viele Tilman Rammstedt oder Carolin Emcke die setzen sich jetzt hin und schreiben Corona Tagebuch.
Und das verstehe ich wieder.
Weißt du was in zwei Wochen erscheint. 120 Seiten. Ein Buch über Corona von Slavoj žižek. Den kommen wir gleich nochmal. Der hat es schon geschrieben.
Nein.
Zum Beispiel so was er sich jetzt hinzusetzen und zu sagen Okay ich mache das Beste aus der Situation in Resonanz mit der Gesellschaft.
Ich erkenne an Es gibt jetzt nur ein Thema und es behandelt das okay. Aber ich ehrlich gesagt.
Carolin Emcke Text finde ich unglaublich.
Also wirklich richtig schlecht.
Ich hab mir gestern lange überlegt ob ich den ersten ob ich den ersten Absatz jetzt mal hier also vorlese einfach.
Ich habe nichts anderes erwartet.
Ich habe es dann gelassen. Ich habe eine gute Lachnummer gestern das hier einfach im privaten Rahmen vorzulesen. Diesen ersten Absatz.
Möchtest du es nicht mal machen. Mich würde interessieren ich habe es nicht gelesen ich habe es nur erzählt bekommen sie es schreibt und ich dachte Jetzt hab ich ja schon hier meine Philosophen. Soll ich jetzt noch.
Hat Keepers auf.
Ich lese jetzt vor.
Ich sage genau was ich vorlese während ich schnell raus suche. Ich lese den letzten Satz aus dem ersten Absatz von Caroline Corona Tagebuch von.
So der letzte Satz ist nämlich besonders lang und deswegen auch spektakulär bescheuert.
Also wie gesagt das was ihr jetzt hört ist nur ein einzelner Satz Ich muss mal kurz gucken wo er beginnt mit Niel Text nämlich.
Es wird unklarer jeden Tag den wir in diesem Modus der Pandemie erleben denn sie hat ihre eigene Zeitlichkeit Zeit.
Das ist die Währung in der die Modelle der Virologen Hoffnung und Not quantifizieren.
Zeit die wir hier in der Mitte Europas nur haben weil andere sie nicht hatten.
ZEIT In der uns die Bilder aus China schon erreichten und wir lange verstrichen lesen als ginge uns das nichts an ignorante Zeit.
Jetzt bedauerte Zeit verlorene Zeit.
Zeit in der wir die wir seit Jahren über die Globalisierung kritisch und unkritisch nachdenken so getan haben als gäbe es sie nicht,
als sei eine Krankheit in China eine Krankheit in China als stürbe sie dort anders als hier als seien es andere Körper andere Lungen Klammer auf.
Ist es das was wir gedacht haben Fragezeichen. Oder haben wir gar nicht gedacht.
Klammer zu als gäbe es das noch Doppelpunkt geschlossene Räume als gäbe es sie nicht Doppelpunkt wechselseitige Verwundbarkeit als wäre es nicht das was uns human macht.
Für jeden was dabei. Das ist doch ein nettes Angebot ein bunter Teller.
Was ist das. Ich habe mich wirklich gefragt. Das kann ja nicht wahr sein. Der erste Satz ja meine Füße gingen lieber aus der Zeit.
Und ich möchte jedem empfehlen auf Twitter die Redaktion dazu zu lesen.
Das ist natürlich ein ganz großes Problem wenn man jetzt wenn man jetzt plötzlich glaubt ein Dichter zu werden weil Coruña ist.
Ich rate da von sehr ab,
von Brockes das er sagt Wir unterscheiden wieder mehr was wichtig was unwichtig ist und das glaubt er auch würde dann auch ein kritisches Urteil über die Kunst wieder ermöglichen das wir da uns dann von sehr viel Schlacke befreien.
Man wird sehen wer auch durchaus eine Chance in all dem sieht ist Harald Welzer auch.
Er hat sich geäußert. Ich glaube das war bei Radio Eins da hat er sich wurde er dazu befragt was denn jetzt mit Coruna kommen könnte.
Klimawandel ist wahrscheinlich langfristig eine weit größere Gefahr für das überleben als jetzt aktuell das Coronavirus.
Aber wir sehen in der Klimapolitik das exakte Gegenteil. Das alles total kompliziert.
Man muss auf alle Rücksicht nehmen die Bürger die gelbe Westen die Autoindustrie die Wirtschaft die Burgruinen was auch immer,
in den Talkshows erklären Markus Söder Olaf Scholz und Christian Lindner unermüdlich dass man den Menschen nichts vorschreiben kann und Freiheit sei ja überhaupt das Wichtigste und ökodiktatur geht gar nicht und so weiter und so weiter.
Also wenn wir nur ein Spurenelement des Virus Aktivismus in der Klimapolitik sehen würden wären wir schon erheblich weiter Kona machts möglich CO2 anscheinend nicht.
Ich würde sagen die Coruna Story ist Lernen Geschichte allererster Güteklasse.
Man sieht plötzlich und wird ja auch von den ökonomen gesagt Diese hyper Globalisierung erhöht die Verletzlichkeit von Gesellschaft radikal.
Die langen Wertschöpfungsketten sorgen dafür dass bei einer Epidemie zum Beispiel keine Handschuhe und keine Schutzmasken in deutschen Arztpraxen zu finden sind weil sie irgendwo nicht mehr produziert werden oder auf der Strecke geblieben sind.
Die Flugzeuge bleiben am Boden Massenet Events fallen einfach aus und es ist ja interessant.
Im Ergebnis wird es nämlich nicht nur eine Wirtschaftskrise zur Folge haben sondern einen signifikanten Rückgang der Treibhausgas-Emissionen weltweit.
Und am Ende wird man sehen dass es auch mit weniger von allem geht ohne dass die Welt untergeht.
Also ich find Weltzeit gerade gut. Ich hab ihn auch bei Phoenix gesehen.
Allerdings hat er eben auch sehr Symptome rum und stellt die Fragen die er sich selbst nicht erklären kann.
Und vielleicht sollte man doch nochmal bei Luhmann dieser symbiotische Mechanismus Wir sind dann anders erregt wenn es uns körperlich betrifft das sehen wir auch am Buchmarkt Wir hatten auch schon darüber gesprochen.
Wenn es damit Charm heißt das Buch Es geht konkret um deine Verdauung.
Wenn das Buch irgendwas mit Schlafen thematisiert und sich wirklich mit der Frage beschäftigt warum kannst du nachts nicht einschlafen Dir fehlen zehn Prozent deiner Lebenszeit die du eigentlich zu Recreation nutzen kannst die verschwendet du sinnlos weitermachen.
Fitness welche Ernährungsweise also diese Körperlichkeit dieses direkte Ansprechen des Körpers ist beim Thema Klima noch nicht erreicht.
Mich hat es auch nur erwischt weil ich in einem Halbsatz Jan Frodeno gehört habe wie er meinte ich mache mal mehr Klima Training Hitze Training.
Seitdem hat mich das befasst mich anders als vorher.
Vielleicht muss man so im Moment irgendwie herstellen aber er hat im Grunde recht mit dieser Diagnostika beim Thema Klima kann man halt einfach ein Medienspektakel das bei Anne Will stattfindet aber es hat nichts mit mir konkret zu tun.
Das ist angebracht zu sagen dass wir jetzt gerade merken dass es auch mit weniger geht nur weil wir jetzt nolens volens hinnehmen dass Veranstaltungen ausfallen.
Es ist ja keineswegs so dass die Leute jetzt sagen Na ja gut dass sie ausfallen.
Ich will aber auch keiner mehr Besuchen in Zukunft sondern es ist eher die Frage Werde ich in diesem Jahr eine besuchen können.
Am Ring ist glaube ich noch nicht ganz gekippt. Da hofft man noch dass es geht. Es wird wahrscheinlich nicht so kommen.
Aber man möchte doch zum Beispiel ich etwa im November den neuen Bond in einem großen Kino sehen und ich möchte denen auch mit meinen Freunden zusammensitzen dort erleben und nicht so dass wir,
nur zu zehnt in den Saal gelassen werden oder was auch immer es ist einfach ein Streaming Link.
Das heißt ich halte diese Vorstellung dass man jetzt sagt Ja jetzt merken wir mal wie wenig wir brauchen.
Niemand hat in den letzten Jahren doch ernsthaft davon ausgehen können beim Konsum dass es darum geht.
Um was brauchen wir.
Man hört mitunter beim Kauf so Sätze wie Ich hab ja eigentlich zu Hause den Schrank voll.
Aber darum geht es ja bei Mode nicht Man bräuchte sonst sehr sehr sehr viel weniger als man überhaupt besitzt und die meisten von uns.
Damit meine ich nicht nur mich als Anzugträger.
Das ist aber einfach ein gesellschaftlicher Fortschritt.
Wenn ich nur immer schaue was ich irgendwie gerade brauche ja was brauche ich dann.
Man kann tatsächlich auch so in Quarantäne jahrelang irgendwie aushalten und wenn jetzt der Staat sagt Wir zahlen tausend Euro für das Nötigste damit kriege ich mein Toilettenpapier und so.
Und am und am Wochenende kann ich mich dann nochmal mit einem Weinbergs machen.
Dann kann ich sagen ja mehr braucht der Mensch nicht aber das kann ja nicht alles sein.
Also ich bin bei dieser Art der Wachstumskritik die ich grundsätzlich als wichtig erachte doch sehr sehr skeptisch wenn das immer so darauf ausgeht so ja der Konsument merkt jetzt mal dass er zu viel konsumiert hat.
Das sehe ich auch nicht dass dieser Lernprozess einsetzen wird.
Nee da wird ja auch ein großes ausatmen Aufatmen geben wenn es dann wieder funktioniert. überkompensation.
Ich meine Wahl erst einmal die richtige Diagnose macht man sieht ja dass die Politik handelt.
Das ist allerdings ein Experiment und es ist noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Wir haben ja vorhin die Zeitlinie genannt. Das Ifo-Institut sagt es könnten so zwischen sieben und zwanzig Prozent sein. Die sagen glasklar auch wenn es im Clip nicht vorkam.
Es kommt drauf an wie lange es andauert.
Da ist einfach ein Prozent pro Woche wird das BIP mäßig gerechnet deswegen.
Also es ist ein Experiment das hat jetzt im März begonnen.
Wir können jetzt im Mai vielleicht mal sagen Na ja nächstes Jahr dann das nächste Coruna kommt ja drei wenn das dann den Sprung auf den Menschen schafft dann sind wir wieder bei 20 Prozent. Nee das glaube ich nicht.
Da werden dann schon Anpassungen und Lernerfolge der Politik abzuringen sein.
Es geht jetzt auch darum so etwas künftig zu verhindern dass man mal wieder zeigen muss was man so alles plötzlich kann.
Also sozusagen die Bazooka wird jetzt oft genutzt.
Hans hat das ja bei unserem Podcast beim Aufwachen so als das ist der eine Schuss ja die Bazooka kommt ein Herr mit einmal Laden einmal schießen danach ist erst einmal finito.
Und genau das ist das Experimentelle Experiment gerade deswegen sollte man vielleicht doch ein bisschen vorsichtig vorsichtiger mit dem Hinweis darauf sein was so alles machbar ist.
Klar durch die zeitliche Straffung sieht das jetzt alles so aus als wäre das mega krass.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen wenn wir im Mai oder Juni das alles wieder ein bisschen locker machen und dann sagen Okay soll es wieder weitergehen wie bisher nur mit Mundschutz und so.
Dann wird sich sehr schnell zeigen dass die Leute nicht bereit sind nochmal zu machen schon wieder das Restaurant zumachen drei Monate habt ihr eine Meise.
Das macht man jetzt einmal und da ist sehr viel Pioniergeist drin. Aber das hat jetzt keine große Aussagekraft für langfristige Projekte wie beim Klima.
Auch diese Idee ja dann verbreitet sich so ein Gefühl und das wird bleiben aber das habe ich sogar beim Sommermärchen 2006 gehört das sagten Ja das ist so ein gutes Gemeinschaftsgefühl das wird bleiben und das ist selbstverständlich nie der Fall.
Wir blicken noch auf einen anderen Philosophen Markus Gabriel Philosoph in Bonn der sich auch geäußert der auch ein Corona Tagebuch hat für 3sat Kulturzeit.
Und wir hören da einen Ausschnitt und würden dann gleich danach noch den Harari schalten. Ein kurzer Ausschnitt aus der Kulturzeit.
Da hat er sich zu Coruna auch geäußert.
Die frohe Nachricht des Tages lautet In jeder Krise liegt die Chance auf eine Verbesserung der gesellschaftlichen Verhältnisse,
im Allgemeinen besteht moralischer Fortschritt darin dass wir moralische Tatsachen gemeinsam aufdecken und erkennen die vorher teilweise verborgen waren.
So war die Abschaffung der Sklaverei und die Befreiung moderner Kolonien von ihren Kolonialherren eine Form des moralischen Fortschritts.
Denn Sklaverei Kolonialismus und brutaler Imperialismus sind moralisch verwerflich.
Das wussten die Unterdrückten und Ausgebeuteten schon lange. Ihnen hat man aber kein Gehör geschenkt die Corona Krise offenbart moralische Missstände unserer eigenen Zeit.
Dazu gehören rassistische Vorurteile Stereotypen und nationalistische Selbstüberschätzung.
Trumps Versuch das Virus den Chinesen in die Schuhe zu schieben und es damit gewissermaßen zu Nationalisierung ist moralisch verwerfliche Rhetorik ja gefährliche politische Lüge.
Dasselbe gilt für den pinkes Märchen das Virus stamme irgendwie aus den USA.
Nicht besser ist es wenn hierzulande viele Menschen glauben unsere italienischen Freunde seien besonders vom Coronavirus betroffen weil sie eben chaotischer und schlechter organisiert als wir Deutschen seien.
Und auch die Vorstellung unser Gesundheitssystem sei ohnehin das beste der Welt wiegt uns in falscher Sicherheit.
All dies sind Beispiele für moralisch verwerfliche Denkformen.
In Zukunft werden wir nicht etwa einen Kommunismus sondern einen Coin Monismus benötigen um einen passenden Ausdruck Peter Sloterdijks zu zitieren.
Wir müssen uns gegen Keno Phobie und Rassismus impfen.
Denn vor dem Virus das haben wir jetzt hoffentlich gelernt sind wir alle gleich alle Menschen Wirte die von ihm angegriffen werden.
Ja wir sind nicht alle gleich Risikogruppen gesprochen.
Nicht alle gleich damit wie wir auch wenn wir keine Risikogruppe sind uns aus der Lemming ziehen können zum wir wenn wir über Privilegien sprechen dass wir hier miteinander sprechen können dass wir jetzt nicht gerade an einer Kasse sitzen.
Ich würde doch bevor wir den Harari machen deswegen noch den anderen Clubs spielen und zwar da gibts noch eine Dame in der Riege die ich da ausgesucht hat die behauptet auch dass wir sogar alle in einem Boot sitzen.
Vielleicht können wir die mal abspielen sollen wir ja jetzt schon sagen wäre es ist ne Wir spielen einfach mal ab und manche haben es vielleicht schon gehört.
Wir können ein Rätsel draus machen. Ich habe sie ja gelesen. Mal gucken ob man es hört.
Also es ist Madonna. Ich nehme an Sie sitzt zu Hause und hat.
Ja in einer Badewanne nackt sitzt in einem in einem Milchbar mit sehr vielen Blüten und sie sitzt dort und hält da diese Ansprache an die Menschheit.
Eine Story oder.
Ja sowas ja.
Coruna ist nicht der große Equalizer genau nicht Koda Child.
Erstens ganz neue Differenzen heraus und betont die Alten noch einmal umso mehr Leute haben wirklich wenig Probleme mit ihrer Kantine wenn sie genug iPads für die Kinder zu Hause haben und der Keller groß genug ist oder eine Kühltruhe drin steht.
Und die die.
Das ist ganz anders als wenn man zu fünft auf 50 Quadratmeter mit den Kindern lebt und so.
Es ist sobald jemand sagt irgendwie das ist ja so toll das Virus das trifft nämlich alle. Und dass es dadurch einen Gleichmacher.
Dann ist er ein Idiot denn man kann sagen das gilt ja für alle Krankheiten da kann man auch sagen ja das Tolle an Krebs ist der große Gleichmacher Jeder kann Krebs bekommen man kann sogar für die meisten Krebsarten gar nicht viel tun.
Man kann also rauchen erhöhtes Krebsrisiko. Aber es gibt ganz viele Krebsarten die bekommt man einfach das kann man ganz ganz wenig beeinflussen.
Da kann ich auch sagen dass das der große Equalizer der große Gleichmacher aber das ist eben nicht der Fall denn die Leute die vermögend sind sind es schon einmal besser versorgt auf jeden Fall.
Und es gibt viele viele andere Dinge die da hinzukommen.
Und das ist wirklich totaler Unsinn. Und ob man wirklich daraus am Ende ableitet aus dem Virus das wir in so einer Menschheit Familie sind wie Gabriel Ja sagt dass wir dadurch Rassismen oder so überwinden.
Ich bin da sehr skeptisch. Denn wir sehen ja permanent Leute die in desolaten lagen sind z.B. auf Lesbos oder so.
Und trotzdem stellt sich nicht das Gefühl ein bei denen die das vor dem Fernseher sehen.
Oh das sind ja meine Menschen Brüder meine Schwestern die dort leiden das ist ja nicht so obwohl das ja ganz evident ist.
Es ist ja nicht so als würden wir zum ersten Mal erfahren dass wir alle Menschen sind sondern wir sind Menschen aber wir sagen ja trotzdem aber in erster Linie bin ich z.B. deutscher oder so.
Deswegen sollen die in Italien nicht die Beatmungsgerät haben so wird ja häufig gedacht.
Während die im Elsass schon die 80jährigen gar nicht mehr beatmen sondern sagen Tut uns leid wir haben die Kapazität nicht sitzt man im Saarland und freut sich darüber Deutscher zu sein. 700 Kilometer entfernt in Berlin Entscheidungen getroffen werden.
Hier findet keine Homogenisierung von nur irgendwas statt bei Gabriel muss man auch noch mal sagen Man kann natürlich dieses Bild jetzt zeichnen wir wissen immer dass solche Krisen mit so einer gewissen Euphorie in der Krise liegt auch eine Chance losgehen und so weiter.
Aber lass sechs Wochen ins Land gehen und dann sieht das schon anders aus. Und bei Gabriel muss man auch noch mal dran erinnern.
Rassismus beruht dann tatsächlich auf so ekel Gefühlen.
Ich habe dieses Argument auch lange nicht akzeptieren wollen dass es tatsächlich einfach so eine basale Emotions Reaktion ist.
Aber das wird uns gerade noch antrainiert Abstand zu anderen Menschen.
Distanz Vorsicht und so weiter.
Da kommt alle mit ihren Paradoxien zusammen stehen aber in Abstand.
Was jetzt stattfindet. Aber Wir schärfen doch jetzt gerade nochmal die ein oder andere Zwangsstörung die man so hat und die eine oder andere Ablehnung die man so hört und die würden auch nochmal strapaziert.
Coruna mehr unterschied und Rassismus als zu weniger würde ich mal prognostizieren.
Rara sagt.
Harari.
Wir sind in einer besseren Lage als je zuvor in der Geschichte mit so einer Krise umzugehen und wir werden darüber hinwegkommen Es wird schwer sein.
Viele Menschen werden sterben viele werden wirtschaftlich einen hohen Preis zahlen aber ich habe nicht den leisesten Zweifel dass die Menschheit diese Krise meistern wird.
Und wenn wir die richtigen Entscheidungen treffen werden wir am Ende als menschliche Gemeinschaft sogar stärker als zuvor aus dieser Krise kommen.
Ja genau.
Wenn wir die richtigen Entscheidungen treffen ist das denkbar. Ich sehe das nicht unbedingt gerade global gesehen habe ich nicht den Eindruck dass man an einem Strang ziehen möchte.
Ja wir sind in der schicksalhafter.
Dass die ganze Gesellschaft von einem Thema dominiert ist was Besonderes.
Soziologisch würde man sagen Das schaffen nicht mehr Organisationen eigentlich die sind ja dafür da dass in Stufe zwei was anders diskutiert wird es auf Etage drei und so weiter oben getroffene unten wird Research und Development gemacht,
die werden eigentlich bewusst kommunikativ auseinander gezerrt um dann in der Parallelität leistungsfähiger zu sein als wenn sich alle im Kreis stellen.
Da fängt einer erst mal an dann kommt der andere. Es darf immer nur einer reden Es gibt nur ein Thema das jetzt die ganze Gesellschaft von einem Thema befasst wird.
Okay wir wissen aber auch dass die Organisationen ihrerseits beginnst bei Bundesministerien und erst recht in Unternehmen natürlich jetzt schon überlegen da alle in der gleichen Krise stecken wie kommen wir am besten wieder raus das ist ja schon angesprochen.
Die Lufthansa die wird jetzt strategisch aufgestellt um am ersten Tag den Markt zu erobern.
Und da wird auch nicht zu wenig Geld da sein.
Spohr hat nur die Sorge dass man noch verstaatlicht wird zwischendurch ja aber der ist frohen Mutes und hat seinen Angestellten gesagt Ab heute keine Gehaltszahlung mehr bis wir wieder,
sitzen alle in den Startlöchern und die Konkurrenz wird enorm sein danach.
50 Milliarden hat die amerikanische Luftfahrtindustrie bekommen von Trump 50 Milliarden kosten die Post.
Toilettenpapier.
Wie passend wie passend da waren noch keine Masken.
Es hat tatsächlich ja gerade geklingelt einen ganz kleinen Schnitt Marke. Ich habe vor zwei Wochen zwei Toilettenpapier Packungen Toilettenpapier aufgegeben Die erste ist verloren gegangen wurde mir gesagt sondern mir zurückerstattet die zweite ist jetzt angekommen,
sensationell gut weiter im Text.
Prima würde ich sagen.
Das machen wir jetzt auch gut versorgt sind eigentlich egal.
Man weiß ja nicht dadurch dass wir ja gelernt haben. Es gibt einen Stoff Kreislauf Es ist zu wenig Papier fängt gerade an zu wenig Altpapier,
und Toilettenpapier Branche hat nun wirklich keine Rücklagen an Altpapier weshalb es da wohl doch noch zu Engpässen kommt.
Machen wir Schiereck.
Cicek Ich fand es ziemlich gut. Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau warum deswegen.
Von Russia Today hat hier interviewt.
Gut Ding.
Denn,
allerdings Endless.
Immer in ihrer auf,
dich genommener,
Epidemie,
Mining,
kann man Immergrün.
Chemical mechanischem oder Living.
Mining,
Sink.
In der Klasse baut.
Today,
Coming,
out in der United Koordinate,
den dadurch Humanity,
bockt der BIG Loser,
Nationalist,
Country Club,
Grand Old Europe eine.
Entlohnten.
In der Middelhauve Military Markets Think niedergeht,
Coordinator Activities,
really.
Strong global international,
transparent Public,
Activity Action very very.
Kommen nochmal gleich im Anschluss etwas wo er sagt was wir eigentlich als Menschen sind.
Ich erinnere mich Ich fand an diesem Clip gut dass er mal gesagt hat dass der Virus so dumm ist,
dass man nicht mal genau weiß ob das jetzt ein physischer Mechanismus ist diese Reproduktion dieses Abschreiber was ja sehr fehleranfällig ist Man lernt unglaublich viel ob das Ding überhaupt lebt.
Ja.
Also was will der Virus und so weiter. Man weiß überhaupt nicht macht irgendwas und so seine Kleinheit und Unsichtbarkeit und Reichtum ist halt so warum man dann auf den Krieg kommt.
Krieg setzt nun wirklich doppelte Kontingenz voraus Man muss antizipieren was der andere so aber sich auch so verhalten dann versucht man es so einzuplanen und eine Kriegs,
Planung entsprechend zu machen das ist ja nun gar nicht ich sondern hier geht man einfach mit der Wissenschaft die man hat und dann reicht die Kapazität entweder oder nicht für die Experimente.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so dieses Kriegstetten irgendwie.
Er sitzt dann auch ein bisschen der Illusion auf. Wir sitzen in einem Boot.
Grundsätzlich ist das so aber die politische die realpolitische Wirklichkeit ist eine andere Die sagt nicht dass wir in einem Boot sitzen sondern dass die einen auf tollen Kreuzfahrtschiffen sitzen und die anderen eher auf schäbigen Booten und manche ertrinken.
Das ist eigentlich das richtige Bild. Aber als Hypothese kann man das vielleicht so gelten lassen.
Aber es führt auch nicht so viel wenn man sagt Wir sitzen in einem Boot das wird auch in jedem Charity Lied irgendwie gesagt dass wir World sind und sind es dann aber doch nicht.
Vielleicht kann man trotzdem komplett widersprechen oder wir sitzen ja nicht alle in einem Boot wir sitzen alle in unterschiedlichen Booten wie du sagst im gleichen Ozean und das Wasser ist per se gefährlich. Wir brauchen im Boot.
Aber wenn jetzt unser Boot kaputt geht oder das Boot der Sudanesen dann da sitzen wir nicht in einem Boot dann sind es schon Unterschiede irgendwie naja gut sind 2.
Medical Doctor.
Statt.
Drei Buchfink Ich Ich. Moment du bist in Panik Batu Back.
To be.
Back.
Epidemie.
Normal.
Normalität.
Auch das was wir jetzt schon mal gehört haben auch nochmal meine Skepsis dass das wirklich stattfindet aber es ist ja erst mal als Wunsch artikuliert. Den kann man hier haben.
Ob das so ist. Ich habe nicht den Eindruck und wenn wir jetzt mal gucken die Debatten wie sie jetzt kommen werden Wann dürfen wir wieder wann können wir wieder sind nicht darauf ausgelegt zu sagen Ja wie Wann dürfen wir wieder.
Wann machen wir es dann grundsätzlich anders. Das wird glaub ich nicht kommen.
Ich denke auch bei diesem Umbau der Gesellschaft den er da antizipiert.
Wir werden auch noch ein bisschen verstehen lernen wie dieses Virus selbst funktioniert Es ist nämlich tatsächlich einfach extrem unwahrscheinlich gewesen dass so eine Pandemie genau so passiert,
dass ein Virus entsteht der erst mal gar nicht so tödlich ist weshalb er sich so weiterverbreiten kann anders als Ebola.
Da hat man ja schon halbtot nur weil die Toten noch einmal gezeigt wurden haben sich die Leute da infiziert.
Da konnte man der Gefahr sehr einfach entgehen und das Ding eben auch lokal halten.
Dieses saß 2 damals SARS 1 das war ja als ich direkt in der Lunge ausgebreitet hat ein 30 Prozent der Betroffenen getötet.
War aber auch nicht infektiös bevor bevor man selber Symptome hatte und diese,
Spezifikation diese rein mechanische Spezifikation dass das SARS 2 Virus jetzt zweieinhalb Tage bevor man.
Symptome hat ansteckend ist.
Das ist ja auch erst mal ein Lottogewinn gewesen für dieses kleine Virus und das muss es auch erst mal aufrecht erhalten während sich so weiter rum mutiert deren Sicht klar ist es jetzt ein absoluter Sonderfall für die Virologen.
Aber es ist halt auch völlig unwahrscheinlich gewesen dass das genauso passiert ist.
Wirklich krass. Und genau das muss man später auch erst mal aufrecht erhalten wenn man dann eine Nachbearbeitung machen will weshalb wir beide nochmal das Plädoyer machen Nee die Veränderungen müssen jetzt gefordert und dokumentiert werden.
In den Supermärkten bei der Beschaffung von was weiß ich dass man einfach so ein bisschen Resilienz Resistenz drin hat und vielleicht wirklich mal ein Shutdown von sechs Monaten machen kann aber dass wir es machen müssen ist nun wirklich ein Lottogewinn für dieses Virus gewesen.
Kommentar zu dem Virus. Ich hab mich nochmal ein bisschen mit Richard Dawkins beschäftigt und mit seinem Buch Das egoistische Gen.
Und da geht es auch um Viren untersagte nochmal sehr schön auch nochmal in Bezug auf die Maske oder was du jetzt,
gerade sagst Wir müssen uns da erst einmal im klar werden was das eigentlich für ein Glück ist für so ein Virus wenn es überlebe das es erst zwei Tage später festgestellt wird.
Und da schreibt er an einer Stelle in das egoistische Gen wenn wir Schnupfen oder Husten haben betrachten wir die Symptome gewöhnlich als ärgerliche Nebenprodukte der Viren Tätigkeit.
In einigen Fällen scheint es jedoch wahrscheinlicher dass sie von dem Virus absichtlich hervorgerufen werden um ihm bei seiner Reise von einem wird zum anderen zu helfen.
Nicht zufrieden damit einfach in die Atmosphäre hinaus geatmet zu werden bringt das Virus uns zum Niesen oder explosionsartigen Husten.
Bei ihm ist das ja immer auch ein bisschen so ja fast teleologische da meine Intention.
Dabei ist es Intention Oslos und Assia dieses Modell vom egoistischen gehen und überträgt das dann auch das Prinzip auch solche aggressiven Gene sind die dann weiter Fortkommen aber man kann es hier tatsächlich ganz gut damit beschreiben.
Es ist wahrscheinlich biologisch nicht so ganz statthaft das so zu tun aber doch als Bild ist es ganz treffend.
Dieser Intelligent Design Gedanke Das ist ja auch Kevin Kelly oder so eine Technologie ganz im Sinne von Das sind ja alles kleine Agenten.
Wenn man jetzt soziologisch so vom Agenten spricht wie ich beim letzten Mal Dirk Becker da sieht den Computer nicht nur als Vermittler sondern der tut noch irgendwas limitiert.
Schön und gut aber das kann man glaube ich dass TweetDeck sich gerade fragte das ist so dumm das Dinge wissen nicht.
Es könnte auch ein reiner mechanischer Mechanismus sein.
Bei Dawkins kommen die Gene gleich wieder mit super Gehirn und haben so ein Riches Nervensystem und wissen was sie wollen und provozieren dann auch irgendetwas.
Das fand ich auch interessant. Manche Systemtheorie die sich rein auf soziale Phänomene ausgerichtet ihr Ding das sich mit Gesellschaft befasst das kennt auch den Begriff des Immunsystems,
und es widme diesen diese Funktion dem Rechtssystem weil das Recht kann einfach mal Bremsklötze einwerfen Leute aus den,
üblichen Sachen rausziehen und sagen Hey Leute wir verhandeln jetzt hier mal auch wenn ihr dachte es ist ganz cool zu skypen Es wird hier vor Ort gemacht und mündlich,
und dann werden da so Sachen ausgebrütet die dann auch so eine Allgemeinverbindlichkeit für viele andere ähnlich gelagerte Fälle haben und so,
diese Form des Immunsystems das über die Stränge schlagen kann.
Ist ja auch im Grunde das was wir die ganze Zeit diskutieren bei Drosten ist das ja ganz deutlich Es ist vor allem die immun hyper Reaktion die den Körper so lähmt.
Bei einer Erkältung genauso. Eigentlich spüren wir sie gar nicht aber die Immunreaktion führt dazu dass wir uns krank fühlen und meinen Gang runterschalten und so weiter.
Man kommt aus dem Intelligent Design nicht so richtig raus weil der Mechanismus so clever ist irgendwie so raffiniert dann wirklich klar wenn man.
Man muss sich nur mal die Evolution die anderen Sachen haben nicht überlebt aber das hat halt funktioniert und deswegen ist es so muss man sich immer wieder vergegenwärtigen aber das Immun das Immunsystem.
Überreagieren können im Sinne von 20 Prozent Minus war vielleicht eine überreaktion des Immunsystems oder des Sozialen Immunsystems.
Das sollte man auch mal so ein bisschen drin haben ich glaube das ist auch so eine Diskussion die im Nachgang dann kommt.
Spätestens wenn wir die Gesichtsmasken für alle haben und feststellen die 75 Prozent weniger infektiöse die man in Japan hat die stimmt die gilt auch für Deutschland.
Vielleicht hätten wir mal mit Gesichtsmaske einkaufen gehen soll. In österreich übrigens kamen jetzt gerade das Verbot nicht mehr ohne Mundschutz einkaufen.
Es raubt sich so langsam an die dpa hat es gemeldet genau es setzt diese flächendeckende Versorgung voraus oder man muss sich anders den Mund irgendwie zu halten in dem Moment also irgendwie abdecken so.
Für eine flächendeckende Versorgung besorgt.
Dass der Husten wirklich mit 3 hierher fliegen ja die Dinger aus dem Mund wenn du abgebremst wird,
immun überreaktion nicht nur biologisch sondern auch sozial sind.
Diskussion die uns auch noch schmerzlich schmerzlich denn es geht sehr vielen Leuten sehr schlecht und wenn es am Ende dann heißt ja leider überreagiert es natürlich dann auch nicht so schön.
Wir sind aber nicht Tiere sondern wir sind spirituelle Wesen sagt sogar der Atheist Schutzweg. Das ist der letzte Abschnitt daraus.
Humor Respekt Spiritualität.
Respekt.
Ich will.
Viel,
Humanity.
Er lacht,
Ich.
Selber.
Spirituell hier,
Morden,
spirituell Animals of Animals.
Das ist der was sie sehr gut nachvollziehen kann Ich finde es sehr schön dass es diesen Bezug dann nochmal gibt.
Und das führt uns zu einem weiteren Intellektuellen Ich weiß nicht ob du es gesehen hast urbi et orbi sonst ja nur zu Weihnachten und Ostern. Ich habe es mir angesehen,
Petersplatz in Rom vollkommen leer der Papst allein hält dort diese unglaubliche eigentlich für diese hochfeste gedachte Feierlichkeit ab.
Beeindruckende Bilder also sollte man sich auf jeden Fall ansehen wurde ja dann auch vom,
ZDF gezeigt und es gibt dort zunächst mal eine Lesung aus dem Lukas-Evangelium da geht es um einen großen,
Sturm Plötzlich erhob sich ein heftiger Wirbelsturm und die Wellen schlugen in das Boot sodass es sich mit Wasser zu füllen begann.
Er lag hinten im Boot auf einem Kissen und schlief und die Jünger weckten ihn und riefen Meister.
Kümmert es dich nicht dass wir zugrunde gehen da stand er auf drohte dem Wind und sagte zu dem See Schweig still und der See legte sich und es trat völlige Stille ein und er sagt dann zu ihnen,
Warum habt ihr solche Angst habt ihr noch keinen Glauben und das ist ein Leitmotiv das sich,
durch die Predigt ziehen wird von Papst Franziskus und auch da wollen wir mal reinhören und man sieht Da gibt es gewisse ähnlichkeiten zu dem was die Philosophen uns zu sagen haben.
Der Sturm legt unsere Verwundbarkeit bloß und deckt jene falschen und unnötigen Gewissheiten auf auf die wir bei unseren Plänen Projekten Gewohnheiten und Prioritäten gebaut haben.
Der Sturm macht sichtbar wie wir die Dinge vernachlässigt und aufgegeben haben die unser Leben und unsere Gemeinschaft nähren erhalten und stark machen.
Der Sturm entlarvt alle unsere Vorhaben. Was die Seele unserer Völker ernährt hat Weg zu packen und zu vergessen.
All die Versuche mit scheinbar Heil bringenden Angewohnheiten die jedoch nicht in der Lage sind sich auf unsere Wurzeln zu berufen.
Mit dem Sturm sind auch die stereotypen Masken gefallen mit denen wir unser Ego in ständiger Sorge um unser eigenes Image verkleidet haben.
Und es wurde wieder einmal jene gesegnete gemeinsame Zugehörigkeit offenbar der wir uns nicht entziehen können,
warum habt ihr solche Angst. Habt ihr noch keinen Glauben Herr dein Wort Heute Abend trifft und betrifft uns alle,
in unserer Welt die du noch mehr liebst als wir sind wir mit voller Geschwindigkeit weiter gerast und haben das Gefühl stark zu sein und alles zu vermögen,
in unserer Gewinnsucht haben wir uns ganz von den materiellen Dingen in Anspruch nehmen lassen und von der Eile betäuben lassen.
Wir haben deinen Anruf nicht angehalten. Wir haben uns von Kriegen und weltweiter Ungerechtigkeit nicht aufrütteln lassen.
Wir haben nicht auf den Schrei der Armen und unseres Schwerkranken Planeten gehört.
Wir haben unerschrocken weitergemacht in der Meinung dass wir in einer kranken Welt immer gesund bleiben würden.
In dieser Fastenzeit erklingt ein eindringlicher Ruf kehrt um kehrt um zu mir von ganzem Herzen mit Fasten Weinen und Klagen,
Du rufst uns auf diese Zeit der Prüfung als eine Zeit der Entscheidung zu nutzen.
Es ist nicht die Zeit deines Urteils sondern unseres Urteils die Zeit zu entscheiden was wirklich zählt und was vergänglich ist.
Die Zeit das notwendige von dem zu unterscheiden was nicht notwendig ist.
Es ist das Leben aus dem Heiligen Geist das in der Lage ist zu befreien.
Werkschutz setzt Werte zu schätzen und zu zeigen wie unser Leben von gewöhnlichen Menschen die gewöhnlich Vergessenwerden gestaltet und erhalten wird,
die weder in den Schlagzeilen der Zeitungen und Zeitschriften noch sonst im Rampenlicht der neusten Shows stehen die aber heute zweifellos eine bedeutende Seite unserer Geschichte schreiben.
Inmitten der Isolation in der wir unter einem Mangel an Zuneigung und Begegnung leiden und den Mangel an vielen Dingen erleben Lasst uns erneut die Botschaft hören die uns rettet,
er ist auferstanden und lebt unter uns.
Tja was soll man dazu sagen.
Sehr viel drin. Das Wichtige vom Unwichtigen unterscheiden was Bazon Brock sagte Da ist nochmal diese Menschheit Familie da ist auch ein bisschen Posth Wachstums ökonomie drin.
Wir waren zu schnell wir haben es übertrieben kehrt um.
Das ist selbstverständlich nochmal religiös unterfüttert aber das ist doch immerhin der Papst.
Da hat man schon nochmal einige Aspekte die die Philosophen auch so äußern und was man hier sehen kann. Originalität ist momentan gerade von den Philosophen nicht so sehr zu erwarten. Jetzt alles was wir gehört haben.
Bedenkenswert mitunter manches ist auch ein bisschen obskur. Aber es ist nicht so dass wir jetzt hier die neue Theorie vorgelegt bekommen die neue große These mit der das funktioniert.
Das ist doch erstaunlich. Eigentlich sind sie geradezu deckungsgleich zum Teil mit dem Papst sie hätten das auch gemeinsam formulieren können.
Also ich würde jetzt keine neue Theorie fordern in dem Moment aber eine Anwendung bestehender Theorien zum Beispiel Luhmann.
Dieser symbiotischen Mechanismus das Immunsystem steckt da alles so drin man kann es auch Fragen zur Moral das ist ja ganz interessant,
die Moral der Gesellschaft hat ja immer das Funktionieren der Gesellschaft die einzelnen Monografien die Moral von der Gesellschaft und die Moral der Gesellschaft,
ist keine derartige Monographie sondern es ist eine Zusammenfassung von Texten zum Thema Die fällt aber auch dadurch raus dass sie alle anderen Funktions Systems Bücher aufhebt,
weil die Funktions Systeme immer symbolisch die Kommunikationsmedien also der Umgang mit Geld wie funktioniert es mit Macht mit juristischer.
Mit dem Urteil mit der wissenschaftlichen Wahrheit Wie gehen wir damit um.
All das zählt plötzlich nichts mehr wenn es um Moral geht weil Moral eben nicht das große irgendwie keine Ahnung.
Carolin Emcke Denkgebäude wie sollten wir jetzt so sondern Moral summiert im Grunde die Bedingungen auf denen wir uns im konkreten Kontakt nach denen wir uns richten.
Und eigentlich brauchen wir diese Form der Moral Soziologie jetzt eine die nicht auf die große Ethik und hier nochmal der Ethikrat und so weiter.
Die großen Fragen sondern Wie begegnen wir uns jetzt künftig. Welche Bedingungen gelten.
Wann kommt Respekt.
Asymmetrien und so weiter ins Spiel. Verehrung und so weiter ja man hat ja so neue Prominenz plötzlich Drosten z.B.
Bei Trossen muss man ja einfach sagen oder sagen wir mal so sehr viele Menschen nutzen das Thema oder die Methode Podcasts um eine gewisse Prominenz in Medien Aufmerksamkeit umzumünzen.
Die steigen dann gleich Top mäßig in irgendwelchen Charts ein und so weiter und alle normalen Journalisten sitzen so daneben und denken Oh das ist jetzt voll den Vorteil genommen nur weil auf YouTube schon so ein toller Geimer ist ja der uns jetzt auch noch bei dem Podcast die Aufmerksamkeit weg.
Und jetzt haben wir das Interessante Modell das mit dem Drosten nicht einfach nur irgend wer redet sondern dass Podcast ist für ihn immer sekundär.
Also der Typ der das Reichweiten Spiel am besten spielt für den Podcast nur sekundär das macht eine halbe Stunde am Tag die anderen siebeneinhalb Stunden Arbeitszeit ist er in einem Gebiet,
tätig das derzeit das Wichtigste ist und er ist auch noch die weltweite Koryphäe.
Das ist eine ganz große Kränkung für alle die jetzt versuchen auch so ein bisschen mit Kuroda Podcasts mitzuspielen und so weiter.
Weil das ist jetzt unerreichbar da kann man jetzt nicht eingreifen Man muss jetzt mit dem Drosten anders umgehen als mit anderen Menschen hier müssen jetzt Respekt und Ehre und Achtung und so weiter werden jetzt einfach anders verteilt.
Grundsätzlich ist aber ein ganz neues Gefühl bei dieser Moral.
Beim Thema Moral müsste man jetzt nicht dieses typische Wir wollen das alles besser ist welche Lehre können wir schon mal daraus ziehen sondern Moral betrifft ganz konkret ein,
soziales Phänomen Phänomen nämlich das der Begegnung das immer auf Asymmetrie ausgerichtet ist also in dem Moment wo ich die Straßenseite nicht wechseln.
Wenn ich einen alten Mann mir gegenüber wird das,
erkannt und dann verhalte ich mich falsch in diesem Sinne und dann muss man gucken baue ich dann bei dem irgendwelche Aggressivität gegen junge Menschen auf und so ganz,
wie soll man sagen So richtig im soziologischen Nahkampf die Kleinigkeiten spielen jetzt eine ganz große Rolle weil die Schmetterlings Flügel die jetzt geschlagen werden die lösen.
In drei Monaten so Orkane aussehen. Das kann man jetzt also mit Moral soziologischen Möglichkeiten wie sie Luhmann ausgebreitet hat rein funktional argumentiert und nicht normativ.
Das müsste man jetzt alles mal aufarbeiten. Bestehende Theorie mal so richtig anwenden auf die Herausforderung die wir jetzt haben und dann würde man niemals anfangen mit.
Wir sitzen ja alle in einem Boot und es ist ja auch voll gut weil es stecken voll Chancen drin.
Davon muss man vielleicht mal. Also Wir sitzen in einem Boot und wir sind auch nicht nur Schranken sondern es geht jetzt auch darum die Gefahr vielleicht ein bisschen krasser abzuwenden als die andere die uns droht und so weiter.
Und da ist natürlich wirklich enttäuschend wenn man sich die Liste anschaut. Selbst bei CTK.
Was er noch dazu sagt Es gibt aber noch etwas was sehr wichtig ist.
Was vielleicht noch nicht alle so mitbekommen haben es gibt einen Philosophen Streit.
Der hat sich jetzt auch an Corona entzündet und zwar gibt es da einen Philosophen der seiner Theorie seinem Paradigma treu geblieben ist. Giorgio Agamben.
Agamben ist ein wichtiger Staatsphilosophie in Italien ein links Schmit Janna das heißt Er bezieht sich auf Carl Schmitt ließ das aber von links Agamben wurde besonders populär. Nach dem 11.
September als er sagte Es wird jetzt so etwas wie ein permanenter Ausnahmezustand produziert man imaginiert eine ständige Bedrohung um dann eben einen.
Autoritären Staat zu errichten mit überwachung und vielem was wir dann auch erlebt haben.
Der Mensch wird zugleich reduziert auf das nackte Leben sagt er und das ist dann wirklich auch das nackte Leben eines Biopolitik Körpers.
Dieses Paradigma das hat er nun jetzt zur Coruña Krise wieder aufgegriffen und sagt Ja das geschieht ja jetzt gerade und er schrieb dann in einem Text,
Es ist fast so als ob die Erfindung einer Epidemie mit dem erschöpften Terrorismus als Ursache für außerordentliche Maßnahmen den idealen Vorwand für deren Ausweitung über jede Begrenzung hinaus bot.
Man versucht jetzt mit sagte er mit dieser Epidemie diesen totalitären Staat den autoritären Staat weiter.
Zu manifestieren und alle Stimmen dazu,
stimmen damit ein denn es gilt ja Leben zu retten und man muss sagen Agamben hat den Text im Februar geschrieben hat da dann noch,
bezogen auf Italien gesagt Na ja das ist eigentlich nicht schlimmer als bei einer Grippe und hat das sehr heruntergespielt und er wurde dann sehr stark auch dafür angegriffen.
Und was man aber sagen kann ist natürlich ist es nicht eine Erfindung.
Was jetzt mit corona ist und auch žižek hat sich dazu geäußert dann wiederum in der er sagt der italienische Philosoph schildert einen wichtigen Aspekt der Funktionsweise staatlicher Kontrolle im Rahmen der laufenden Epidemie.
Doch es bleiben entscheidende Fragen offen Warum sollte staatliche Macht daran interessiert sein eine derartige Panik zu fördern,
die mit Misstrauen gegenüber der Staatsmacht einhergeht und zudem die reibungslose Reproduktion des Kapitals stört.
Liegt es wirklich im Interesse von Kapital und Staatsmacht eine globale Wirtschaftskrise auszulösen damit ihre Herrschaft erneuert werden kann.
Da kann man in der Tat skeptisch sein und Kiyak sagt doch diese Idee dass das eine Erfindung sei sei pure Ideologie.
Und ganz interessant ist dass nicht nur Agamben sich zu Wort meldet und Zizek Dann kontert sondern auch Jean-Luc Nancy ein französischer Philosoph hat sich auch in die Debatte eingemischt.
Und der hat dann gesagt Gegen Agamben Wir müssen aufpassen dass wir nicht das falsche Ziel treffen eine ganze Zivilisation steht in Frage.
Daran besteht kein Zweifel Es gibt eine Art virale Ausnahme biologisch Computerwissenschaftler kulturell.
Die eine Pandemie ist. Regierungen sind nichts weiter als grimmige Henker.
Und es an ihnen auszulassen scheint eher ein Ablenkungsmanöver als eine politische Reflexion zu sein.
Er sagte Ja die sind aber jetzt ja gar nicht die souveräne.
Es ist nicht wie bei der Politik beim 11.
September dass man es mit souverän zu tun haben und die machen jetzt vollkommen übertriebene Maßnahmen um einfach ihre Herrschaft zu stabilisieren sondern die Politiker sind selbst und ich glaube das können wir an unseren Leuten wie Sparen oder so am besten beobachten.
Stehen mit dem Rücken an der Wand und müssen irgendwie agieren. Das heißt Die sind gar nicht die souveräne.
Und dann kommt eine sehr schöne Anmerkung So etwas hat man in Philosophie sehr selten deswegen lese ich es vor.
Ich habe erwähnt dass Giorgio ein alter Freund ist und ich entschuldige mich dafür dass ich eine persönliche Erinnerung vorgebracht habe.
Aber ich habe damit nicht ein Register allgemeiner überlegungen auf.
Vor fast 30 Jahren entschieden die ärzte dass ich eine Herztransplantation brauche.
Giorgio war einer der ganz wenigen die mir rieten nicht auf sie zu hören.
Hätte ich seinen Rat befolgt wäre ich wahrscheinlich früh gestorben.
Nancy hat ein sehr schönes Buch darüber geschrieben an seinen Essay Der Eindringling der Eindringling heißt.
Dieser Essay wie das eigentlich ist wenn man etwas Fremdes plötzlich im eigenen Körper hat nämlich ein Herz.
Und worum es hier geht was sich hier auf persönlicher Ebene nur zeigt ist Nancy überhaupt niemand der diesen Begriff Biopolitik gut findet.
Das ist ja etwas was man nicht nur bei Agamben findet sondern auch bei Foucault.
Fukuoka jetzt ganz viel wieder zitiert dass man sagt Wir haben hier den den den Körper.
Und deshalb haben die Biopolitik und die sorgt jetzt für so etwas wie Volksgesundheit und deswegen kann das mit Fug zugleich problematisiert werden.
Agamben tut das auch noch sie ist aber ganz fern von diesem Paradigma und deswegen äußert er sich auch noch einmal so auf persönliche Weise dass er sagt Na ja du bist immer Technik kritisch und all das.
Aber ich wäre schon längst tot wenn ich auf dich gehört hätte.
Also haben wir nochmal so eine ganz konkretes Beispiel wo man auch sagen muss Ja das ist ja tatsächlich eine sehr große Gefahr die ich im übrigen auch sehe.
Dass wir jetzt einen dauerhaften Ausnahmezustand bekommen bei dem alles Mögliche bewilligt wird weil man immer sagte Ach wir retten da gerade Leute vor Corona.
Aber zugleich muss man sagen Es gibt ja reales Leid es ist ja nicht nur eine rein imaginierte Bedrohung sondern es gibt reales Leitung gerade in Italien,
wo eben sehr viele Menschen sterben wo man nicht sagen kann Das ist nur so ein interessantes Paradigma.
Womit sich die Herrschenden im Prinzip stabilisieren können.
Ja allerdings. Ich finde bei Agamben zu dem ich wenig Zugang habe ich habe zwar auch seinen Ausnahmezustand hier aber ich konnte es nie so richtig lesen.
Ich fand aber immer bewundernswert wie Kommilitonen die ich sehr geschätzt habe weil sie sehr klug waren also totale Fans davon waren sowas zu lesen.
Das ist doch toll.
Vielleicht sollte ich mir nochmal anschauen. Ich finde jedenfalls die Herangehensweise.
Mal ausdrücklich nicht von einem Boot Bild heranzugehen sondern es umzudrehen und zu sagen wer wer fährt denn gerade mit einem Schnellboot hier durch den Kanal wo wir uns alle retten müssen und spritzt uns auch noch alle nass während uns überholt.
Das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Wie vorhin schon gesagt nur weil die Gesellschaft nur noch ein Thema kennt und es zumindest so sich niederschlägt bei uns heißt das nicht dass die Organisation die Gesellschaft irgendwie sehr viel Verantwortung tragen dass die jetzt nicht irgendwelche Chancen nutzen oder mal so Sachen ausprobieren.
Man muss halt auch sagen so Kleinigkeiten wie das die Frisöre noch offen lassen durften.
Da zeigt sich ja auch dass es eben doch mit einer kontingenten Situation zu tun haben will man hätte die Frisöre zum Beispiel ja auch gleich schließen können statt noch drei Tage später.
Aber nein man hat halt überbelegung gehabt. Wer muss hier wegen Regress und so weiter.
Es ist eine Verpflichtung da irgendwie Entschädigung zu zahlen. Wollen wir nicht doch nochmal Trude die Möglichkeit geben morgen nochmal zur Helga Laden zu gehen und sich zu verabschieden für die nächsten drei Monate. Also alles solche Sachen.
Und daran sieht man schon es gibt Spielräume und die werden auch genutzt und wenn Agamben jetzt sagt Die Pandemie ist eine Erfindung dann müssen wir natürlich sagen Nee die Pandemie Pandemie ist einfach dieses kleine Virus der uns auf Zack hält.
Aber alle sozialen Reaktionen das Ganze.
Der ganze Abschwung der Wirtschaft bis hin zu minus zwanzig komma sieben Prozent das ist gemacht.
Ich möchte noch hinzufügen um wirklich auch eine kleine Ehrenrettung zumal für Agamben hat sich noch mal geäußert In einem weiteren Text und da sagte er Ich glaube das sollten wir uns auch,
im Gedächtnis bleiben vielleicht müssen wir es mal wieder in zwei Monaten zitieren Wenn Lockerung da sind aber gewisse andere Sachen dann uns drohen.
Er schreibt hier die Menschen haben sich so sehr daran gewöhnt unter Bedingungen ständiger Krisen und Notlagen zu leben,
dass sie nicht mehr zu bemerken scheinen dass ihr Leben auf einen rein biologischen Zustand reduziert wurde der nicht nur jede soziale und politische sondern auch jede mitfühlende und emotionale Dimension verloren hat.
Eine Gesellschaft die in einem permanenten Ausnahmezustand lebt kann keine freie Gesellschaft sein.
Wir leben tatsächlich in einer Gesellschaft die die Freiheit den sogenannten Sicherheitsgründen geopfert hat und sich infolgedessen dazu verurteilt hat in einem permanenten Zustand der Angst und Unsicherheit zu leben.
Das müssen wir mal überprüfen wie das so ist Wir haben uns auf jeden Fall nach dem 11.
September an etliche Einschränkungen die nicht sein müssten gewöhnt und man stellt doch immer fest dass Dinge wenn sie einmal gemacht wurden nicht mehr zurückgedreht wurden also gerade jetzt diese Geschichte mit der Handy überwachung.
Dass da auch sinnvolle Möglichkeiten in einer Art der Konzentration von Leuten,
darin besteht dass man da Dinge überwacht aber was bedeutet das eigentlich wenn sich irgendwann wieder politische Versammlungen oder Demonstrationen bilden.
Wie geht man dann mit einem solchen Tool um.
Andere sagen dann vielleicht ist das auch der interessanteste Philosoph weil er hier wirklich mal was ganz gegen den Konsens artikuliert und deswegen dann auch direkt von seinen Kollegen eins drauf bekommt haben sie ja noch viele weitere geäußert.
Und was dann auch noch ganz schönes ist dass Medienwissenschaftler über das Phänomen nachdenken.
Also du hast es auch schon angesprochen mit dem Podcast was das hier gerade eigentlich bedeutet wenn ein Virologe der Podcaster plötzlich ist.
Und wir haben ja jetzt gerade wurde wieder irgendwo ein Podcast Preis vergeben.
Die üblichen Verdächtigen oder so. Und dann hat man aber den eigentlich relevanten Podcast hat man da und den kannte man aber vor acht Wochen noch gar nicht.
Das ist natürlich wunderbar dass so etwas entstehen kann jetzt gerade das freut einen sehr.
Wer darüber auch nachdenkt über das jetzt eigentlich unsere Kommunikation in unserer Medienverhalten stattfindet ist Peter Weibel befreundet im übrigen mit Bazon Brock.
Der leitet das ZKM in Karlsruhe ist also großer Kunst Kurator und er hat einen Artikel geschrieben übrigens erschienen sehr viel in der entsetzter zu diesen ganzen Dingen.
Und da sagte er immer bedurfte es eines Boten der eine Botschaft überbrachte mit dem Telegramm und dem MORSE CODE konnten erstmals Zeichenketten Botschaften körperlos übertragen werden.
Körper des Senders. Der Körper des Senders blieb an einem Ort.
Die Botschaft wurde per Kabel übermittelt und der Empfänger am anderen Ort konnte die Information verarbeiten.
Diese fabelhafte Telecommunication wurde nach der Entdeckung der elektromagnetischen Wellen im 20.
Jahrhundert zu einer drahtlosen Kommunikation umgebaut zu einer den Globus umhüllen Einflußsphäre.
In dem Augenblick in dem Botschaften allein reisen konnten verwandelte sich eine Koerper basierte Neidgesellschaft in eine Fernsehgesellschaft.
Jede Technologie ob Auto oder Telefon dient der überwindung von ferne.
Wir leben seit mehr als hundert Jahren in einer Teles kommunikativen Gesellschaft.
Aber die Welt hat diesen Wechsel noch nicht vollzogen.
Und dann sagt er so schön na ja man hat Autos gebaut wie man Kutschen baut und hat immer den Fahrer mitgedacht.
Dabei bräuchten doch Autos gar keine Fahrer.
Oder warum sitzen eigentlich noch Zuschauer in einer Talkshow die im Fernsehen übertragen wird.
Und dann sagt er Der Verkehrsfluss wird zum Zeichen Fluss Wir fahren fahren Fahrn fahrn fahrn fahrn dessen Text von Virilio nicht nur auf der Autobahn sondern senden Signale auf dem elektronischen Highway.
Die Kultur wird zu einem Online Paradies das Virus zwingt durch seine Vitalität die Kultur zu einer Migration in virtuelle Welten.
Ein wichtiger Schritt für die Steigerung der Abstraktion und Symbolisierung des Menschen.
Das heißt für die Evolution.
Ja wenn du in Bielefeld anfängst Soziologie zu studieren kriegst du diese Standardfrage woraus besteht Gesellschaft dann sagen alle Erstsemester aus Menschen natürlich.
Und dann wird dir quasi über zehn Semester trainiert.
Nee Menschen also das hieße ja so Die Gesellschaft besteht aus Menschen und sie verwirklicht sich immer dann wenn sich Menschen begegnen wenn sie in Kontakt sind.
Und dann kommt Luhmann und sagt ab 1960 konsequent.
Die Gesellschaft besteht nicht aus diesen Kontakten sondern besteht aus Kommunikation und die Kommunikation setzt die Kontakte in Anwesenheit nicht voraus.
Und jetzt haben wir diese Turbo Erfahrung dass wir plötzlich alle zu Hause Schulunterricht machen sollen und dass es funktioniert.
Und dieser Satz Gesellschaft besteht aus Kommunikation und Kontakte sind eine Form von Kommunikation aber es muss nicht sein.
Man kann genauso Social Distanz mäßig Homeoffice und Schule zu Hause machen und so weiter.
Plötzlich ergibt dieser Satz so viel mehr Sinn und wenn man dann feststellt dass die ganze soziologische Systemtheorie auf diesem Satz beruht dass es um die Kommunikation geht dann hat man jetzt,
zwei Regalmeter Suhrkamp um das nachzulesen.
Also wir haben eigentlich alles da um das so zu verstehen.
Wo wir jetzt so rein geworfen werden plötzlich ist der Virus überlebenswichtig.
Bisher dachten wir irgendwie müssen alle anderen Themen die so in den Top Hundert geprügelt werden jetzt ist quasi nur noch das Virus.
Und wir lernen also Wir könnten jetzt genauso gut so viel über das soziale Lernen wie z.B.
Auch das in der Gesellschaft Einsamkeit das größte Problem war und nicht zu viel Kontakt.
Wir sind eigentlich schon eine recht kontaktlose Gesellschaft.
Ganz schön sehen wenn wir das Virus mal in seiner Begrifflichkeit begreifen wie wir es eigentlich in den letzten Jahren gebraucht haben dann denken wir Weibel weist darauf hin dass viral gehende im Netz.
Und das ist auch kein Zufall. Das kann man ja auch schon nachlesen bei,
Richard Dawkins der macht ja einen weiteren Begriff auf einmal aber er sagt es gibt auch irgendwas wie kulturelles übertragen wird eine Melodie,
ein Spruch irgendetwas was sich vererbt irgendwie von Generation zu Generation.
Was ist und es bei ihm das Mem.
Und nun ist es ja so dass ich selbst ein Mem geworden bin wie ich kürzlich festgestellt habe und zwar macht jemand bei Instagram macht zum Meme aus mir. Was sehr amüsant ist.
Aber das ist ja etwas was erst mal noch so sehr metaphorisch gebraucht wurde.
Von Dawkins wenngleich er das schon immer sehr ernst gemeint hat aber es gibt auch andere Evolutionsbiologen die sich damit auseinandersetzen.
Also ich habe das jetzt extra noch einmal gelesen.
Dieses Buch von Daniel Dennett von den Bakterien zu Bach und zurück und dort geht ja auch auf Meme ein und sagt erst einmal,
ganz ganz deutlich dass in Meme Wörter sind.
Wort ist für ihn ein Mem und Das übertragen wir uns dann ein und er sagt aber dann nicht nur ein Wort ist ein sondern auch ein Wort ist wie ein Virus eine minimale Art von Akteur.
Es will gesagt werden warum. Weil es andernfalls rasch aussterben wird.
Ein Wort ist genau die gleiche Weise egoistisch wie ein gehen.
Diese metaphorische Redeweise hat uns viele erhellende Perspektiven auf die Evolution beschert.
Keine Angst vor ein bisschen Metaphorik die beißt nicht.
Sie sollten nur jederzeit noch die nackten Tatsachen dahinter erkennen was hier deutlich wird.
Naja so ganz kann man das Paradigma jetzt nicht wirklich biologistisch anwenden.
Und ich würde auch davon abraten. Aber jetzt glaube ich um unsere Zeit doch zu verstehen um zu verstehen Wie kann es sein dass in WhatsApp-Gruppe plötzlich solche Fake News,
plötzlich Millionen Menschen erreichen und Eltern ihre Kinder anrufen und sagen Ja ich habe aber gerade gehört bei WhatsApp ist gar nicht so schlimm oder bald werden alle Supermärkte für immer schließen oder solche Dinge.
Auch was das wir hier ein Virus auf einer anderen Ebene noch einmal erleben nämlich auf dieser kommunikativen Ebene das sind die Viren die in der Fernsehgesellschaft wie Weibel Sie nennt sich so stark verbreiten und das ist schon erstaunlich dass,
so viel davon schon gedacht wurde bei den Evolutionsbiologen dass man auch sagte Na ja.
Das funktioniert eigentlich mit so einer Fähigkeit ohne Verständnis.
Gestaltet hat mancher kultureller Dinge hat weder einen einzelnen noch mehrere Urheber Architekten oder Designer.
Das heißt wir können einen klaren Autor gar nicht mehr ausmachen wie wir auch nicht mehr so genau wissen Wo kommt denn jetzt eigentlich dieses verflixte covert 19 her. Aber es verbreitet sich einfach.
Dann es eine gewisse Finesse.
Sie haben so eine Fitness wie wir das bei dem Virus auch haben und Meme sind informationelle Dinge heißt es noch sie sind Rezepte für Verhaltensweisen Sie können weitergegeben gespeichert und verändert werden ohne ausgeführt oder umgesetzt zu werden.
Und dann geht es eben auch noch einmal sehr stark darum dass wir uns nicht schützen können.
Wir werden von denen irgendwie überflutet und nehmen Sie wahr. Wir können sie vielleicht nur in andere Bahnen lenken das ist ganz schön zu sehen wenn es,
von rechts kommen von Rechten Influenza Nutzern oder so.
Und dann wird ein bisschen umgebaut.
Einen richtigen Impfstoff gibt es eigentlich nicht dagegen aber es wird ein bisschen umgebaut und wird dann plötzlich wieder von links verwendet.
Also Wir leben in einem viralen Zeitalter in doppelter Hinsicht.
Ja ganz genau. Also alles was du jetzt vorgetragen hast zeigt ja nur Eigentlich ist das ja alles nicht neu und ist auch schon da.
Nur das Coronavirus offenbart es uns eigentlich.
Plötzlich wird der Decke weggezogen. Wir haben entdeckt entdeckt dass alles so funktioniert.
Wir können ja dran erinnern wir haben ja vor zwei Wochen die erste Westwall Folge in einem Saloons Spezial,
beschrieben und da habe ich auch dieses Luhmann Zitat von dem Buchrücken mitgebracht Ich trage es immer vor wenn unsere Gesellschaft sich auf ein Symbol einigen müsste so würde es vermutlich nicht der Kreis,
nicht das Kreuz nicht die Linie sein sondern die schwindelerregende Kurspotential Kurve,
weil sich alles so entwickelt,
dass der Reichtum der Reichen wird genau durch so eine Kurve.
Wenn man einmal investiert ist verdoppelt verdoppelt sich das und dann kann man sich wieder verdoppeln.
Und wir haben den Begriff der Vitalität. Den haben wir schon längst inkorporiert in unsere Gesellschaft und den Begriff des Influencer.
Da steckt das Wort Flut drinne Zufall aber der Influenza lernen wir ja neue Krad kennen aus der Virologie der Breda.
Der Typ der in Getränke. Ja das ist der Supersportler.
Und ja wir können uns dagegen nicht wehren dann von ihm infiziert zu werden so wie eben sehr viel Geld ausgegeben wird 60 Milliarden im Jahr um in Instagram Stories in Facebook Newsfeed,
Instagram Timeline präsent zu sein.
So schnell kann man seine Augen nicht verschließen Ja man hat es dann aufgenommen ist dann infiziert von dieser werbe Idee die irgendwer sich ausgedacht hat.
Und wenn man es darauf anlegt tock tock dann hat es genau die exponentielle Kurve.
Dann braucht es genau ein Jahr und am Ende dieses Jahres Laden an einem Tag 100 Millionen Menschen diese App runter weil genau das die exponentielle Kurve vorhersagt. Ist gar nicht.
Großer Anlass mal die Modernität so richtig kennenzulernen Wir machen nicht nur,
wir lernen nicht nur gerade körperlich die Gesellschaft kennen indem sie mal richtig Zugriff auf uns nimmt sondern wir haben jetzt auch richtig intellektuell intellektuelles Ronde vu.
Mit der Globalisierung irgendwie kann man sich nicht mehr dagegen wehren dachte man sich.
Aber ich habe doch noch meinen Garten zu Hause und ich baue doch noch meine Zwiebeln selbst an. Und so weiter.
Aber jetzt zeigt sich. Wir sind jetzt alle in der Modernität angekommen.
Es ist immer noch ein bisschen ungleich verteilt. Aber man kann sich jetzt nicht dagegen wehren in dieser modernen Gesellschaft teilzunehmen.
Ich würde sagen zum Ende gehen jetzt nochmal auf Bananen.
Denn Bananen. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich dass es unglaublich Banane hat sich die Mathematik angeguckt hat gesehen das verbreitet sich viral in China.
Dann passiert das auf der ganzen Welt warte mal ab. Und dann hat er im Januar da war Wuhan noch nicht im Look down im Januar eine Sondersendung begonnen die heißt,
Twenty Twenty so ist die Sendung sowieso weil sie sich im Wahlkampf befasst und da gibt's eine Sparte und die heißt Pandemie.
Pandemie also warum die Pandemie.
Irgendwas ist mittlerweile 95 Folgen davon erschienen in den letzten drei Monaten.
Da hat man auch exponentielle Entwicklung irgendwann wird mittlerweile auch mit chinesischem Untertitel weltweit ausgestrahlt in Videoformate aber so dass man wirklich da teilnehmen kann wenn man es will.
Und jetzt ist die Frage die mich beschäftigt.
Wenn alles stimmt was wir jetzt gesagt haben die moderne Gesellschaft funktioniert sowieso so wie wir es gerade sehen auch wenn wir jetzt an der Abweichung der Fehler oder wie soll man sagen Der,
medizinische Begriff der ihr wisst schon an der Funktionstüchtigkeit man plötzlich anhand der Fehler kann man reproduzieren und erkennen was eigentlich der Normalzustand ist und.
Eigentlich könnte man ja auch davon ausgehen dass so ein Typ wie Bananen tatsächlich im Weißen Haus arbeitet und dort die Geschäfte führt.
Also einfach die Planung Geschäfte und ich glaube wir haben.
Wir verstehen unser Glück noch nicht dass das gerade nicht so ist weil Bananen breitet seine Theorie hier aus und,
da geht es wirklich ans Eingemachte und wir können sehr froh sein dass Donald Trump gerade nicht funktioniert sondern dass er dass wir ihn so sehen wie es eigentlich nicht funktionieren sollte und deswegen zum Anfang zwei Clips die das mal die unser Glück.
In Amerika sieht es schlimm aus.
Ich will das nie in Abrede stellen aber zum Glück haben da die Gouverneure gerade das Sagen und nicht der Präsident weil der Präsident der könnte jetzt auch richtig zulangen und die Nutzen daraus ziehen weil ich es aber so eindrücklich fand wie,
der New York Taverna Andrew Cuomo gerade die Geschäfte an sich Resa.
Das ist wirklich beeindruckend zu hören denn man kann natürlich bei aller Dramatik auch sagen die letzten 20 Jahre muss halt einfach nur politisch verwaltet werden was an Steuereinnahmen da ist und jetzt ist halt mal eine echte Aufgabe für Politiker.
Jetzt gibt's eine Herausforderung jetzt kann man mal sehen Es ist ein echter Beruf man muss es halt machen und der Komoß hat das ganz ganz wunderbare Worte gefasst. Er wurde noch am 18. 3.
Also vor zwei Wochen ungefähr von dem The Daily Podcast besucht.
Klar ist das New York muss man nicht weit fahren und so vor Ort.
Er hat dieses wunderbare einminütigen 50 Könige Stück mitgebracht in dem der Gouverneur der jetzt wirklich gerade in der Verantwortung steht seine Tätigkeit mal so umfasste.
Nee Nee Nee,
Nee.
In der deutschen Politik ein bisschen zumindest spüren können wir haben wir jetzt nicht so eine Figur wie Trump.
Aber wir merken plötzlich dass der Fokus der Aufmerksamkeit von der AfD vollkommen weg rückt weil man ihn nun wirklich nicht zutraut dass sie was Vernünftiges machen würden in dieser Lage und dass das ja,
alles wenn die Sonne scheint,
ein permanentes Spektakel ist man beschimpfte einander und man zappelt sich um irgendwelche Dinge und macht entsprechende Provokationen seitens Minderheiten hin.
Aber das alles ist nur dann möglich und ist auch für die Leute bei Facebook dann alles ganz ganz toll offenbar also die Wähler dass sie das Klicken kommentieren und sonst was machen.
Aber jetzt gerade haben wir ja einen ganz großen Vertrauensvorschuss wieder für die Große Koalition wie sich abzeichnet in Umfragen.
Zugleich ist ein System wie das öffentlich rechtliche Fernsehen und Radio das öffentlich rechtliche generell wieder viel viel wichtiger geworden weil die Leute sagen Na ja gut ich will mich jetzt doch nicht,
darauf verlassen dass das irgendwie stimmt oder Verschwörungstheorien kann man sich hingeben wenn es mich nicht selbst betrifft aber ich möchte ja schon jetzt wissen Kann ich dann krank werden oder nicht.
Zwar gab es da jetzt auch ein paar Fälle.
Natürlich blühen auch Verschwörungstheoretiker immer wieder solche Fälle aber es gibt doch generell eine große Entwicklung dahin dass man jetzt möchte dass vernünftig gehandelt wird und dass auch gehandelt wird.
Und viele atmeten vielleicht auch deshalb auf dass Merkel auftaucht weil man es ihr dann eher zutraut als Jens Spahn den man auch eher ein bisschen so als Sontags Minister eingestuft hat.
Das wird sich noch zeigen wie weit er da krisenfest das Ganze steuern kann. Aber ja das erleben wir.
Es ist Zeit für politische Profis. Wir haben uns noch vor einem halben Jahr darüber lustig gemacht über diesen Halbsatz von Christian Lindner aber jetzt ist er da. Es müssen jetzt Profis sein.
Und dieses Zitat ist von Como das könnte man auch als Kitsch durchgehen lassen wenn es irgendwie von der Seitenlinie so gegeben hätte aber er ist nun mal der Gouverneur gerade der nun,
in dem Staat ist in dem die Hälfte aller Kona Fälle inzwischen wohl 65 000 da aufgelaufen sind und alle Krankenhäuser sind jetzt überlastet.
Man kann das noch mal nachholen in zwei Wochen Er hat bis Juni so vorausplanen da ist dann die Spitze.
Die stehen jetzt richtig in der Gefahr ist eben auch richtig machen zu müssen versucht politisch zu handeln und in häckseln Tappert Mike Murphy der ansonsten,
amerikanische republikanische Kandidaten auf Präsidentschaftskandidatur vorbereitet.
Hier meine Empfehlung gegeben ums Weiße Haus den Bogen zu machen.
Governors.
Man arbeitet gerade an einem Workaround um Trump herum.
Und jetzt stellen Sie sich mal vor es wäre anders Trump hätte das von Anfang an erkannt als große Chance.
In China ist ein Virus. Wir hätten niemals unsere Produktion dahin auslagern sollen das war ein großer Fehler der demokratischen Präsidenten.
Es muss jetzt alles zurück nach Amerika und sofort abschotten Amerika abschotten hätte man ja alles machen können. Also sozusagen alles verpasst als Chance.
Frühen Aufsatz zu Corona den er bei Spiegel online publizierte.
Noch vor den Dingen die ich jetzt vorgelesen habe gesagt die werden das wahrscheinlich jetzt erkennen.
Das wird jetzt die Möglichkeit sein um den Nationalstaat Schiereck hat das geschrieben. Er hatte die Prognose dass jetzt jemand wie Trump oder sodas erkennt aber es ist nicht passiert.
Wer das geschrieben.
Es ist nicht passiert genau und in diesem Podcast am 20..
Also vor zehn Tagen war John Heilemann zu Gast von MSNBC und er hat ja mal so ein trampt Drehbuch nach Bellona durchgespielt wie es hätte sein können.
Wurde.
In
China.
Gerade.
Und das merken wir uns mal was Time President. Diesen Status hätte sich Trump ganz früh geben können die den Kampf gegen China hätte er strapazieren können mit seinem Huan Valérys und so weiter.
Und dieses Mal kapierst Ding alle Produktion zurück nach Amerika Es geht um die amerikanischen Arbeiter und so weiter.
Die voranstellen es wäre alles konsistent mit seiner bisherigen drei Jahren gewesen und er hat aber nichts von den dreien gemacht.
Statt zu sagen Ich bin der Vatan Brasilianer sagt Nee wir haben ja gar kein Problem.
Die Zahlen sind ja niedrig und so war er als genaues Gegenteil gemacht von dem was ihm Bananen empfohlen hätte.
Und wir wollen es mal rückwärts auf.
Ich muss dann noch mal ganz kurz unterbrechen weil wir verweisen auf unseren Podcast zu Kamera und der ganzen Thüringen Geschichte erscheint uns heute als eine kleine Laune der Geschichte wenn man sieht was Corona jetzt da ist.
Aber das war für uns das große Ereignis im Februar als wir drüber gesprochen haben und wir haben ja auch sehr viel darüber gesprochen wie Wieso Souveränität geht wie man ebenso Krisen.
Produziert bei der AfD um dann irgendwann sich Souveränität zu erlangen wie es so etwas wie einen autoritären Liberalismus gibt. Darauf haben wir verwiesen.
Und eigentlich ist es verrückt und man kann es wirklich nur Ja es ist wirklich ein glücklicher Zufall dass Trump offenbar diese Theorie,
die er an die er sich sonst gehalten hat sofort an die Macht zu kommen.
So ein Dekret nach dem anderen Chaos stiften und dann wieder als der große Ordner auftreten dass er das hier nicht getan hat dass er hier beschwichtigt hat.
Das ist wirklich kann man schon sagen ein Glücksfall oder für ihn ein Fiasko.
Dass er das nicht gesehen hat. Also wäre er einfach seiner Linie treu geblieben hätte er diese jetzt nur verstärken können und hätte sich als der große Macher denn man weiß ja bei solchen Krisen,
in der Regel der Krisenbewältigung auf jeden Fall wiedergewählt wird das schon bei kleineren Dingen erlebt.
Beim Hochwasser damals im Bundestagswahlkampf für Stoiber Schröder war es so dass Schröder sofort erkannt hat Das hat Harald Schmidt mal so schön geschildert.
Schröder war ja dann sofort mit den gelben Gummistiefeln da unterwegs und hat so quasi gemacht ich rette euch vor der Flut oder werde euch danach,
alles Gute tun und ich glaube Harald Schmidt war auf Sylt und saß dort in einem Restaurant und sah plötzlich nicht recht dort saß in diesem Restaurant auch Stoiber.
Während Schröder halt mit den Gummistiefeln darum lief dann war für ihn klar Wer jetzt die Wahl gewonnen hat und ja eigentlich die große Chance.
Ja George W. Bush hatte damals denkbar schlechten Start Man wusste gar nicht genau was will er denn jetzt als Präsident ist er einfach nur der Sohn des vorherigen Präsidenten.
11. September will Rating über 80 Prozent. Er geht heute immer noch also ist der schlechteste Präsident aller Zeiten.
Aber damals über 80 Prozent nach dem 11. September und bei Trump das dümpelt weiterhin bei 44 Prozent und ist historisch niedrig.
Es ist wirklich krass wie Trump sich selbst aus dem Spiel genommen hat bis hin zu dass jetzt die Gouverneure wirklich das Heft des Handelns in die Hand nehmen.
Mit Aufforderungen Mike Murphy Ja das werden Sie wahrscheinlich auch tun auch die republikanischen die werden nicht mehr gross Rücksicht nehmen.
Fidschi ist der einzige der da noch irgendwas koordiniert ansonsten hat Trump ja auch angesagt.
Liebe Gouverneure bitte sorgt mal selbst dafür Wir können zwar unterstützen aber es ist eure Aufgabe sozusagen für Nachschub zu sorgen.
Also hat sich da wirklich auch explizit selbst rausgenommen.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal ein bisschen Banane allerdings hintenrum auf.
Am 24. 3. also vor einer Woche hat Bananen das erste Mal angezeigt in seinem eigenen Podcast.
Das gefällt mir nicht was Trump hier macht. Er hat bis dahin über die Maske irgendein geiler President.
Und jetzt brach es dann auch ganz leicht aus ihm heraus.
Es geht um die Hilfe die die Bundesregierung in Amerika herstellt um die Unternehmen.
Oder es hat ja damals schon kritisiert.
2008 wurde ja nur Wallstreet rausgehauen und nicht die normalen Leute daraufhin Tea-Party und der ganze Kram mehr bis hin zu so überreaktion dass man dann auch einfach Trump wählt wenn man unzufrieden ist.
Man weiß nicht genau worum es geht hier um diesen Bail out der wieder nur die großen Konzerne erst adressiert gibt ein bisschen Helikoptergeld aber halt 200 000 Dollar das,
sitzt nicht nennenswert in Deutschland ist ja spezifiziert bis zu 15000 Euro ohne die du einfach bekommst und Bananen,
dokumentiert die erstmal dokumentieren.
Auch wenn mir danach ist wie sich das bei Bananen aufbaut wie kann man es erst einmal dokumentieren dass auch Bananen so langsam vom Glauben abfällt.
Das ist auch die saloppe Art mit der ein geiles Mihm 30 Tage über Amerika zu retten geil das wäre die geile Brücke gewesen.
Also ich glaube dieser Stimulus Park der zerschlug jetzt einfach das Band zwischen Balloon und Trump das ja Trump schon vor zwei Jahren zerschlagen hat.
B9 hielt immer noch daran fest aber jetzt reicht's ihm auch weil genau der gleiche Fehler wieder gemacht wird.
Statt dass Trump jetzt die Gelegenheit nutzt und sagt Liebe normale Menschen die hier nicht groß gefährdet seid aber unter den Immunreaktionen der politischen Handlungs,
Zwang dem wir jetzt unterliegen nehme ich hier alles mal runterzufahren Wir geben euch jetzt einfach das Geld und zwar jedem einzelnen und so weiter.
Das ist die Brücke zu.
Und dann hoffen wir einfach mal dass es funktioniert und dann kann man auch sagen Ich habe die letzten drei Monate eine Brücke gebaut. Die haben es nicht hingekriegt.
Und dieses ganze Bild funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Das klingt banal hier auch nicht mehr argumentiert weil dieser Stimulus völlig falsch konfiguriert ist.
Er nimmt halt wieder die großen Unternehmen im Blick und jetzt vergleichen wir mal,
Yossi die wir eh schon immer geschätzt Alexandra.
Alexandria Casio Kohtes.
Kaukasier Ossi steht im Repräsentantenhaus und argumentiert mal gegen den Stimulus Package Plan des Senats.
Kriminell ist dies konkret.
Ob
in
Schwarz oder in American History Schimpfwort.
Da
Ist die Idee mit Nothing Ozu Guide.
Es gab ihn aber vor eine Haftung.
Kommentiert jetzt Libanon wie folgt.
Payroll.
Beginn einer ist der Beginn einer wunderbaren Freundschaft zwischen Yossi und Brandon am Ende.
Verfolgt das seit einer Weile dieses Pandemie. Was er da macht.
Ich glaube Trump verliert gerade wirklich seine Bake und Balloon hat es Argumente gebracht.
Wenn man jetzt nicht darauf abzielt Programme zu machen die auf,
make Payroll zahle die Gehälter nicht darauf abzielt.
Wir schützen jetzt erst mal die Unternehmen davor und sagen Okay Leute vier Monate gilt der Arbeitsvertrag nicht in Deutschland Kurzarbeitergeld zielt ja auch wirklich nur auf,
wenn die Unternehmen das annehmen sie müssen es nicht freiwillig aber wenn sie Kurzarbeit annehmen muss die Beschäftigung bestehen bleiben und 60 Prozent des Lohnes kommt vom Staat in der Hoffnung dass das Unternehmen selbst ein bisschen ergänzt je nachdem vielleicht wird ja doch noch ein bisschen gearbeitet.
Aber während es in Deutschland ja unter den gegebenen Umständen ordentlich gezielt ist und wohl auch funktionieren sehe man natürlich erst im April und so ist das in Amerika hier absolut vernachlässigt worden.
Was seit 2008 als Kritik an diesem Bail outs hat komplett ignoriert von der Trump Regierung.
Ich glaube hier ist ein ganz großer Bruch drin weil das wird man auch sehen Die Menschen werden anfangen zu leiden und es wird alles nicht so richtig funktionieren und den Unternehmen nützt auch nichts wenn sie,
ihre Work Forstner irgendwie loswerden klar dann hat man erst einmal drei Monate sichere ihre Bilanz aber man will ja dann doch wieder einsteigen und dann neu rekrutieren rekrutieren ist ganz schön teuer und aufwendig und so,
glaube ich kann man an diesem Podcaster ein bisschen absehen wie es auseinanderbricht.
Frage ich mich ja wie kann man das jetzt mit Helikoptergeld gerade machen Helikoptergeld ist ja dann sinnvoll wenn der Laden mal wieder richtig laufen soll wenn man dann sagt Jetzt teilen wir aus.
Nehmen wir an es würde sich jetzt alles sehr gut hier Gestalten in Deutschland und wir wären so dass wir Mitte Mai sagen Alles kann wieder öffnen Außer ein paar Großveranstaltungen und wir haben genug und Mundschutz. Dann könnte man sagen Ok.
Und jetzt bekommt jeder nochmal 100 000 Euro Helikoptergeld als kleinen Anreiz damit die Leute auch sofort mal loslaufen in das Geschäft und kaufen sich jetzt das was sie immer schon kaufen wollten.
Dann würde das funktionieren aber wenn wir jetzt Helikoptergeld aus teilen würden was würde dann kommen dann würden die Leute vielleicht nur noch Klopapier kaufen.
Genau vor allem fehlt da die Perspektive.
Das ist ja das Wichtigste in Deutschland dass man die Perspektive hat. Der Arbeitsvertrag bleibt Es ist wie es ist.
Es ist eine Brücke. Wir haben so eine Perspektive auf Ende Juni oder so.
Und dann kann man wieder und genau das wird in Amerika komplett ignoriert und Bühnenwerk glaube ich sehr zufrieden mit dem wie es in Deutschland so funktioniert weil hier wird die Payroll.
Hier zahlt man einfach das Gehalt und um ein paar kleine Clips hier mal am 14. 3..
Ich wollte nicht nochmal in den Anfang reingehen wo ich mir noch nie damals rausgeschnitten habe was wann wie wo sagt.
Hier erinnert er sich nochmal rückblickend wie war das als wir mit diesem Pandemie Radio angefangen haben.
Bei.
Der.
Wir haben Situationen angeguckt politisch war das noch völlig unbedeutend es gab noch nicht mal ein lock down aber die Mathematik war so eindeutig sagt er rückblickend.
Und es ist nicht nur Legende Wir haben damals wirklich angefangen dieses dieses monothematische Radio dazu zu machen also täglich.
Und im Grunde ist es.
Jemand wie Banane sieht dass wir das in Deutschland so spät erkennen.
Ja und das muss man ja wirklich sagen wenn man sich das mal anschaut. Ein Tag bevor die Schulschließungen beschlossen wurden an diesem Freitag vor zwei Wochen.
Ein Tag vorher kam Drosten im Podcast zu seinem Sinneswandel Schulschließungen wäre doch vernünftig.
Zwei Tage vor derselben Woche hatte das noch ne braucht man im Grunde nicht. Und die Politiker sind an dem.
An äußerungen aus aus Januar und Februar. Die sind,
jetzt mit Verlaub gesagt nicht weit davon entfernt was wir bei Trump dann auch gehört haben somit Ja das ist weit weg und das ist nur kleine Krippe und da fängt man sich einen Schnupfen ein Wir wollen mal keine Panik.
Ja das Robert Koch-Institut war ja bis Februar noch der Ansicht das ist eine lokale Sache in China.
Das kann man dort begrenzen das wird hier nicht auffallen bevor bevor der Kekulé seine tägliche Radiosendung hatte wurde der vom MDR schon mal interviewt am 25. Januar.
Damals hat er noch so darüber gesprochen.
Andererseits wird es natürlich wenn Menschen einreisen dazu kommen dass die isoliert werden wenn Patienten einreisen. Das wird in der jeweiligen Lokalpresse für enorme Aufregung sorgen. Wenn man dann wieder die Menschen mit den gelben Anzügen sieht und ähnliches.
Es wird zu Tumulten in der Lokalpresse führen wenn Menschen mit gelben Anzügen am Flughafen isoliert werden,
der Drosten sagt dass er an seinem Podcast auch selber Er muss sich selber immer wieder dazu zwingen jetzt exponentiell zu denken.
Aber die Mathematik ist halt wirklich nicht beschreibbar. Also wenn du Sonne.
Also wenn du die Spezifikation des Virus kennst wie ansteckend ist musst du das nur auf die Gesellschaft legen wie sie ist.
Dann kannst du durchrechnen wie lange es dauert bis alle infiziert sind und dann heißt 70Prozent Infektionsrate innerhalb von drei Monaten.
Man kann sich halt wirklich nicht vorstellen aber die Mathematik ist,
ohne Erbarmen kein Erbarmen greift da einfach durch.
Man sollte man vielleicht auch einplanen inskünftig überlegung dass man wirklich auch so ein Modus des anderen Denkens schaffst.
Wenn Problem besteht dass man sagt Leute wir machen es jetzt nicht hier wir gehen jetzt mal in den Keller machen vorher fünf Minuten autogenes irgendwas Training und dann befassen wir uns mal mit dem echten Problem wenn das Virus hier ist breitet sich das so schnell aus.
Da nützt jetzt nichts Historisches Wissen mitzubringen oder so ist es reine Mathematik,
nennt sich das schon beeindruckend wie so ein Virus dann doch alle überflutet weil die Ministerpräsidenten die hatten am Mittwoch oder am Donnerstag ihr Treffen im Kanzleramt mit Drosten und Wiler und so weiter und am Freitag haben sie sich hingestellt sagt Ab jetzt Schulschließungen am Montag geht's los.
Hätte man schon gut in England ging das alles innerhalb von drei Tagen.
Bei uns ja wenigstens eine Kaskade an Eskalation die sie über zwei Wochen hinzog aber es geht also wie gesagt Die Herausforderung ist wirklich riesig.
Zu Trumps fast verpassten Chancen hat sie jetzt einen Ausschnitt vom 24.
Februar also relativ früh das ist jetzt schon über einen Monat her 24.
Februar so über Lieferketten und Globalisierung und Gier und die Corona Chancen und so weiter gesprochen.
In der Sendung von Banane Banane ist auch da ich glaube wir hören aber nicht nur.
Basic.
Cabs.
Great.
American way,
of government Offering Companies,
Persons You can do you can iPhones.
Tim Cook ist die Master of.
Arts auf China.
Was soll man dagegen sagen. Die Kette ist tatsächlich so dass amerikanische Arbeiter die in irgendwelche privaten Rentenfonds einzahlen dieses Geld sammelt sich Navas Shit wird als Kredit an Unternehmen gegeben die dann damit Lieferketten nach China aufbauen und die Produktion weg lagern aus Amerika raus.
Ich stelle mir vor Trump hätte das in so einer halbstündigen Rede irgendwie Weise als Problem markiert.
Wirklich erstaunlich.
So Yossi übergeben diesen Gedanken.
Hier noch einmal ein schöner Spruch der es wirklich so auf Einsatzpläne bringt.
Price Cost.
Shipping,
ordern bei Pippo.
Die ist vom 26. Februar.
Es gab allerdings jetzt Form von Felbermayr unter anderem,
Wirtschaftsleuten schon diese Gedanken im Februar,
durch Corona wahrscheinlich ein Denken ein Deeg denken sich breit machen wird das auf eine der Globalisierung hinausläuft.
Die haben offenbar schon erkannt dass man das,
nutzen kann dass Trump dann nicht in dieser Weise getan ist erstaunlich,
auch dass der Freihandel nach wie vor nicht groß kritikwürdig erscheint ist ja auch etwas was man erst mal so konstatieren muss das ist ja auch was.
Was jetzt damit rein spielt was bei hinausführt vielleicht wird das noch kommen aber das wäre jetzt sicherlich auch eine Gelegenheit ohne dass man jetzt zu so einer derGlobalisierung kommen muss denn die hat ja auch viele Nachteile dass man sich tatsächlich,
sehr kritisch damit befasst und das wäre dann wiederum für linke Parteien eigentlich angebracht gerade weil es Trump versäumt.
Naja also ich will auch nicht sagen dass jetzt beide irgendwie super klug ist im Sinne von zuerst an die Globalisierungsgegner gedacht denn das steckt natürlich steckte damals schon bei Bananen drin und hat Trump propagiert.
Die Frage ist warum diese Chance auf Crooner zu Münzen nicht genutzt wurde.
Und da hätte ja tatsächlich nur einer aus dem Weißen Haus statt mal einfach nur sinnlos Bürojobs Scheiße zu machen diesen Podcast hören und sich inspirieren lassen können.
Es gibt hier noch eine Aufnahme vom 29. den zweiten fasst es inhaltlich zusammen da ist leider nur durchs Telefon zu hören aber das schaffen wir trotzdem müssen jetzt gestellt Corona Zeiten an Audio Qualität und so weiter.
Also nochmal anderthalb Minuten auch noch aus dem Februar.
Adamek das Virus des Helferkreises Herr Wegnahme Quatsch Modeboutique Wer war China.
Manufacturing Justice scheinen des Globus Polyeder.
Merkel.
Ist.
Signifikant als Sauers.
In der,
Scharping.
Jasons sehr präsent.
Das Sowohl,
als Auch. Ja ja.
Wie kamen Sie da in Produktion,
Germanys.
Next Havemanns Campaigning.
Eine Ré Industrialisierung. Und zwar im Stile einer Kriegs Mobilisierung als Rettung aus diesem Fiasko und dem man als drinstecken.
Das Beispiel gab es jetzt häufiger zur Kriegswirtschaft. Man sieht wie schnell man Dinge umsetzen kann.
Und beim Krieg geht es auch in erster Linie um Bedarf und geht es darum dass Menschen nicht in großer Weise darben müssen.
Es geht um Sofortmaßnahmen weil keine Zeit zu verlieren ist. Insofern sind diese Vergleiche zum Krieg zwar ein bisschen martialisch aber grundsätzlich falsch. ökonomisch betrachtet ist es nicht unbedingt.
Erst einmal eine Einschätzung von David Axelrod sozusagen von der anderen politischen Seite.
So wie Mike Murphy der Berater amerikanischer republikanischer Kandidaten war war Axelrod z.B.
Wahlkampf Chef oder hoher Mitarbeiter bei Obama und dann auch noch mal hier zu diesem Wort Time President. Welche Chance lag eigentlich drin.
Feit.
Das ist dieses kurzfristige Denken was Trump einfach auf den Dow Jones zu gucken und zu denken Ach Scheiße geht morgen sowieso viel runter.
Statt dieses langfristige Planen und das Durchziehen der eigenen Strategie.
Also wirklich voll die Chance verpasst das zu machen. Glücklicherweise weil das wäre nicht gut gewesen denn wir haben auch in Deutschland Michael Hüther z.B.
Eine Diskussionssendung setzt wie hier im Forum vor zwei Wochen hätte da nichts gegen sagen können wenn Trump so eine Strategie gefahren wäre.
Wir haben hingenommen dass die räumliche Spezialisierung Muster in der Welt dazu führen dass beispielsweise im medizinischen Grundstoff Produktionsbereich bestimmte Dinge nur noch in China und Indien produziert werden weil Märkte immer a offen und b zugänglich sind.
Wir sehen dass die These mit wenig Lagerbeständen Kapital schonend das Unternehmen aufzustellen möglicherweise auch Kosten hat.
Und all das wird auch nachhaltig zu einer anderen Bewertung dieser Strukturen führen und deswegen dieses Bild der Wasserscheide ist schon berechtigt.
Wir werden danach nicht einfach neu die Dinge wieder in die Produktion bringen oder einfach nur weitermachen sondern es werden genau diese Fragen aufgerufen werden.
Man stelle sich mal vor Trump hätte diese Diskussion gestartet. Mehr stimmt im Grunde Industrielandes viel zu viel auslagert und eins wäre zum anderen gekommen hätte ich wirklich eine Wiederwahl von Trump gehabt aber,
wie gesagt ich kann mir das weiterhin nicht vorstellen.
In der Lage auch wenn ich jetzt nicht genau weiß wie Joe Biden jetzt Wahlkampf machen soll.
Wenigstens das nächste halbe Jahr steht alles irgendwie in den Sternen.
Hier ist mal noch ein Steven Balloon.
Wo er gerade auftritt. Man weiß es nicht.
Es ist ja interessant dass alle Politiker zu Hause sitzen.
Die Oppositions Leute die erreicht man alle zuhause wenn man sich irgendwie für seine Gespräche Anfragen hier nochmal ein Clip Stevan Bananen am 24..
Also nicht so lange her. Trump hat ja jetzt angefangen so zaghaft irgendwie mit seinem China weicheres und so weiter und dann auch,
so auf globaler Ebene die G7 so ein bisschen daran zu hindern zum Abschluss kommen nicht Gäste kommen weil man eben gerne Sheila Valérys als Begriff da drin hätte und.
Und auch da denkt man schon wieder an die Diplome Belz dies natürlich als armer Arbeiter in China auch und versucht hier,
nachwirken so ein Dreh bei Trump rein zu machen aber hier sitzt er wirklich nur in seinem Podcast Mikrofon und nicht im Weißen Haus und so weiter ansonsten sähe die Strategie ja auch anders aus.
CCP.
Man muss es nur spezifizieren wenn man so ein Programm fahren will es ist halt das Kommunisten.
Kommunistisches Virus.
In der Hinsicht.
Ganz klar Mensch das sind doch herrliche Worte. Nochmal.
Naja ich meine das was Trump jetzt droht am Ende ist er da komplett zum Nebendarsteller wird in dieser Krise.
Ja.
Das sieht man in Deutschland auch ein bisschen Es wird halt auf lokaler Ebene die Exekutive ist die Frage der Exekutive das ist die Zeit der Exekutive das sind die Gesundheitsämter und die Ministerpräsidenten und die Bürgermeister. In Amerika ist das ganz genau so..
Aber ich denke nicht dass uns die Krise so schnell verlassen wird sie wird uns hier im Podcast auch ganz gewiss begleiten aber,
da können wir schon mal an dieser Stelle Entwarnung geben Kein Coruna Podcast werden das war nur jetzt nochmal wichtig dass wir das alles so gesammelt haben denn wir müssen ja auch uns hier kritisch befragen.
Wir haben in den ersten beiden Ausgaben auch nicht darüber gesprochen wir hätten schon im Januar die Möglichkeit gehabt zu sagen Okay wir haben hier immer auch unsere Runde und sprechen darüber das haben wir ja nicht gemacht im Februar.
Jetzt kamen wir natürlich nicht umhin. Wir werden das aber bestimmt im April aufgreifen aber dann vielleicht nicht so monothematisch Man weiß ja nicht was sonst noch so geschieht wer hätte gedacht.
Es passiert ja wenig.
Wir waren ja schon mit Thüringen ganz erstaunt dass so viel passiert gerade in der Februar-Ausgabe und jetzt haben wir Coruña und wir sind da bei einer ganz anderen Dimension angekommen.
Wir wollen aber noch auf eins hinweisen nämlich nicht nur auf den Salone dass wir dort Literatur Empfehlung geben sondern wir wollen auch bald mal Fragen beantworten im Saloon die man uns stellen kann.
Da haben wir uns zumindest mal gedacht erinnere ich mich.
Das scheint ja ein großes Anliegen zu sein Ich mache natürlich gerne mit.
Fragen beantworten. Ich sehe das bisher immer so als bei Instagram wenn Leute nicht so genau wissen was sie senden sollen dann fragen Sie immer so nach Inspiration und das ist meistens die Form der Frage.
Ach so gibts glaub ich ein paar Leute die Fragen haben und ja.
Ich meine jetzt so grundsätzlich dieses Instagram Phänomen dass man da so.
Wir sind ja nicht auf Instagram mit diesem Podcast jedenfalls nicht mit einem eigenen Ding.
Aber ich wird die Fragen einsammeln. In welchem Modus schriftlich.
Schon sagen Es ist das Sinnvollste.
Man kann natürlich ansonsten auch Sprachnachrichten aber dann per E-Mail noch eine extra Telefonnummer habe ich nicht übrig.
Ja
Man kann auch gerne mündlich das müsse man einfach per E-Mail an uns beide Adressen sind ja soweit bekannt ansonsten gerne schriftlich als Kommentar unter die diese Folge jetzt die Folge.
Das wir wahrscheinlich am einfachsten am besten koordinieren.
Genau da kann man durch Scrollen und sowas sehr gut.
Dann weisen wir es noch kurz auf den Salon hin indem wir kurz in einem Halbsatz jeweils sagen um was es geht.
Ich fange mal an Ich habe Steven Levys Facebook Buch gelesen.
Das stellt nochmal mal die ganze Historie Facebooks in kurzen Pointen na dann ein Text übers hocken das offenbar gesünder ist als sitzen.
Dann hat Matthias Horx sich fast nicht getraut aber einen lesenswerten weil ziemlich albernen Text über die Welt geschrieben und dann möchte ich doch noch bei Crooner bleiben.
Es gibt ein Institut für irgendwas das einen sehr eindrücklichen und auch sehr funktionalen sehr guten Text über die vier wichtigsten Punkte wie man aus der Conakry rauskommt geschrieben hat sehr eindrücklich und sehr hilfreich vor allem,
saßen in der Zeit und haben gemeinsam über Crooner gesprochen Es ist natürlich interessant jetzt einen Top ökonomen und einen sehr interessanten Virologen zu hören.
Weitgehend Corona frei Ich werde mich auf einen Text beziehen der sich mit DNB auseinander setzt die natürlich jetzt durch Corona nochmal noch spezieller in die Krise gekommen sind.
Dann soll es um Kambodscha gehen da haben wir auch wieder Lieferketten zu tun.
Da beziehen wir unsere unsere Kleidung her.
Es wird nochmal um Bitcoin gehen eine Frage der Globalisierung die wir hier schon angesprochen haben die verhandelt wird in einem Aufsatz und dann noch mal um das was,
China eigentlich für uns ist Man sagt immer das ist die Werkstatt der Welt oder die Werkbank der Welt und da sagt ein Aufsatz Na ja,
das stimmt zwar aber vieles bleibt auch einfach jetzt da und das geht nicht einfach so durch und kommt dann wieder zu uns zurück.
Sehr gut. Außerdem im Salon gibt's,
zur ersten Folge der dritten Staffel.
Bahnbrechend. Das ist sehr gut Er sollte unbedingt Westwall gucken und natürlich auch unser Gespräch dazu hören.
Und damit würde ich sagen sind wir heute durch diesen März angeht.
Wir haben natürlich nicht allumfassend alles behandelt was es zu Coruña zu sagen gibt aber nur über Coruna gesprochen kein Wunder im April.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher gibt's auch wenn es vielleicht Nebenschauplätze zu Corona sind aber trotzdem Schauplätze auf denen einiges stattfinden wird.
Und sei es nur dass man mal zusammenfasst was man so gelernt haben sozial meine ich nicht nur individuell sondern sozial aus Sona krassen Zaid aber wir lassen uns alle überraschen Noch ist ja nicht April.
Ja dann Wir wünschen uns Gesundheit.
Gesundheit haut rein Leute bis dahin.
Intro/Outro